foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I hope you all had tea coffee
okay awesome
um we'll be starting shortly before that
publicist Sapient is conducting
interviews as we mentioned uh in another
Hall so anyone who wants to interview
for them it's Express interview you can
just walk away with your offer letters
so yay
and we are also conducting some quizzes
where you can win goodies uh you know if
you guess the answers right so please
during the breaks go to the booths and
have an interaction with them maybe you
walk away with something wonderful today
apart from the talks okay uh over to you
nikhil
foreign
welcome all to track two are you all
excited
only this one excited
are you all excited
Ah that's better everybody had their
coffee how's everybody feeling
all good yeah yeah nice nice good to see
that
all right so let's get started without
any further Ado to our amazing speaker
lineup for this particular track
so now let's call upon our first Speaker
who's gonna kick start this track he's a
software engineer at app right and he
works at some amazing stuff there and
he's going to talk about how real-time
communication uh actually works like and
like some amazing stuff about webrtc so
I hope you all are excited and with a
big round of applause let's invite on
stage Christy Jacob
[Applause]
a lot of energy in the room it's the
first session so yeah it's definitely
nervous but at the outdoors oh you're
gonna definitely lock the stage I know
that all right so another round of
applause for Christy
[Applause]
am I audible perfect so
um this is going to be the first talk of
this day so I'm really excited and uh
let's we're going to talk about really
fundamental technology that's present in
browsers today it's called webrtc it's
not new it's been around for quite some
time over 12 or 13 years old the
original version was released by Google
back in 2011. so it's been around for
quite some time but the hype recently
has come up again mostly due to covet
and stuff essentially people you know
have been using conferencing
applications a lot and it has caused
people to wonder how applications like
meet and zoom and stuff work and webrtc
is the answer there so to start with
webrtc is a peer-to-peer communication
protocol that enables real-time
transmission of data between different
peers we talk about webrtc mostly in the
context of browsers but webrtc is also
you know can be used in you know other
scenarios as well so essentially the
main highlights here are that it is
completely peer-to-peer that means it
doesn't require any server to relay
information between uh you know maybe
between the different peers it can be
used for transferring any arbitrary data
it can be either video audio or you know
images anything of that sort but mostly
it's used in the context of audio and
video sharing it's cross-platform
compatible most of the browsers
supported it's Opera Mozilla Edge Chrome
the latest versions of all of it and
it's open source so that's uh you know
always a plus point and it's the
application it's a technology that
powers you know things like Zoom meet
teams and any kind of video conferencing
application you can think of so in this
session we're going to cover about uh
that we're going to divide into two
parts so webrtc consists of the actual
media that flows between the different
devices and also the metadata about the
media so the metadata includes you know
stuff like the codecs there's the
different devices support the kind of
media streams are available and things
like that and uh in the first part we're
going to cover the media and how the
media flows between the different
machines and then we're going to look at
how the metadata part
so uh webrtc is built upon some
underlying sorry underlying protocols
fundamental underlying protocols that's
a new word for underlying uh so ice is
actually the framework that enables the
communication between uh you know the
different appears and eyes relies also
on certain other fun uh protocols like
Nat stun and turn which we're going to
take a look at
so let's say you want to talk to a
device on the internet what's the first
piece of information that you need any
any guesses
exactly so IB address is the fundamental
thing that you need to be able to access
or address another machine on the
internet
you know a few maybe I don't know 30 40
years back it was much easier because
every device had its own public IP you
could address each device uniquely
however with the with the number of
devices that we have and the limitation
of addresses in the ipv4 space we have
resorted to new technologies or new
techniques called Nats uh for to
mitigate you know the transition to IPv6
right so we have only limited address
space of ipv4 addresses so we can't
really you know with more than billions
of devices and uh lesser less IB
addresses which are less than that so we
introduced a new technology called nat
which is essentially allows you to share
a public IP for for a lot of devices
within a private Network so they can all
uh you know access the internet using a
single public IP address and let's you
know most of us have look learned about
Nat and back in college so we're just
going to do a quick primer on that right
so if we have a net which has a single
public IP this is usually given to you
by your ISP uh you know Airtel or
Vodafone whatever and within your
network you have certain devices and you
have different applications running on
different ports right so let's say an
application on Port 3000 wants to
communicate with the website on the
outside it's going to send a request to
the website it's going to go through the
net and the NAT is going to create a
mapping from the public sorry the
private IP port pair to the public IP
port pair and it's going to create a new
port for it within its table and create
that mapping so in this way a single IP
address of that of the router is can be
used for by many processes within the
network to communicate with the outside
world so this is what Nat essentially
does
but we have a problem
so if you have run ipconfig or ifconfig
on your terminal the IP address that you
get is of your local device right it's
your private IP so and this private IP
as we discussed is of no use if you want
to establish a peer-to-peer
communication so we need a way to be
able to you know find the other peers
public IP so let's say in a world
without mirrors or without in a world
without cameras what is the best way to
get a description of your face you would
probably ask your friend to describe it
to you you probably ask your friend to
sketch something for you right that is
similar there's similar analogy uh
that's that can be used here which is
the stun server so stun stands for
session traversal utilities net so in
scenarios where we have a net that is in
front of your device we need a way to
detect its public IP address so
essentially the server just says uh so
you send a request to a stand server
saying hey Stan server what's my IP
address and the sun server it can see
you know the IP address of the NAT that
it came from and it's going to return
the address back to it in a packet and
then the the peer can you know for that
packet and figure out its IP address and
Port pair right and so it also helps
determine any router restrictions that
can be present so it's not always this
scenario that you know your peers are
able to talk to each other even if there
is even if you find out the public IP
you cannot really establish a
communication so the NAT needs to allow
the port forwarding and things like that
right so there are a lot of restrictions
in place which prevent it from happening
ah so without any networking class is
not complete without Alice and Bob so
let's bring them back here uh but
there's not a cyber security class so
there's no Eve in this scenario so let's
say Alice wants to establish a
connection with Bob and Alice is going
to establish uh he's going to send a
request to the nearest stun server which
we configure in our you know in our code
and uh it's just going to ask hey Astan
say oh what's my IP address Sun server
sends back Alice this is your IP address
and this is the port that you're talking
to me from and uh you're also behind the
net which employs certain restrictions
similarly Bob performs a similar request
and it's going to get back its IP
address and port and finally they are
going to be able to talk to each other
assuming there are no restrictions
okay but we're not in the ideal world
and we do have some problems so there
are different kinds of nat the basic or
the most permissive kind of nat is
called a full code Nat essentially it
means that any internal device can
communicate with any device on the
outside and vice versa so the first kind
of net restriction is called restricted
net and in that case you can an outside
device can only communicate with a
device inside the network if there has
been a mapping in the table already now
the mapping is only present if a device
from within the network initiates the
communication first so unless peer a has
already talked to prb Prior pob is not
going to be able to talk to pra because
that mapping is not going to be present
in the NAT table there's also an example
of a symmetric Nat wherein the IP
address or the port that's assigned to a
device depends on the destination so
let's say peer a tries to make a request
to the stun server it's assigned the
port 15001 and if the prb were to use
the same 15001 port to talk to pra that
wouldn't would it wouldn't work because
in case of a symmetric Nat even the port
number or the IP address is different
based on the destination that you're
trying to talk to so what do we do
no we have to come up with another
workaround and that's called a turn
server so a turn a turn stands for
traversal using relays around that as
the name suggests the turn server is a
relay that lets you relay your
information between the peers now this
is a scenario now initially I told you
about how webrtc is completely
peer-to-peer but here's the scenario
where you know it doesn't respect that
this is the scenario where all your data
actually needs to pass through another
machine and then go to the other peer
so in this case the turn server is you
know does need to do some processing it
needs to be decently powerful to be able
to handle all the media streams and it
does have some additional overhead
because you have latencies in coming
into picture
cool so we talked about all of these
Technologies and this is where ice comes
in so ice is the overseeing protocol
which uses all of these things we
discussed so far to handle all the
connection data behind connection
details behind the scenes So within each
browser you have an ice agent which
handles the generation of ice candidates
and it does all of this behind the
behind under the hood so you don't need
to worry about any of the complexities
so it's a communication between peers
may not be possible because of
unavailability of IP addresses Nat
restrictions firewalls and so on so ice
makes that possible now when we start a
webrtc connection we initiate the ice
generation process so when we trigger
the ice generation process both the
peers or as many peers as they are start
to generate a set of ice candidates an
ice candidate is essentially a
description of a route that a packet can
take to reach from Pure a to pob so this
is an example of you know we have five
ice candidates here
so you can see that the different ice
candidates have different types the
first one is of type host the second one
is called stun server reflexive the
third one is also Stan server reflexive
then we have relay two relay addresses
essentially what it means is uh the
candidates are going to try each of
these parts in the order of their
Network cost so each uh candidate also
has a network cost Associated to it so
the first one is just 10 17 and 17 and
so on right so obviously you want to
find the path of least resistance so
obviously they're going to try with the
first candidate first and this scenario
will work when both the devices are on
the same private Network so if you look
at the IP address it's a 192.168 it's
usually a private IP and this this
candidate would work in scenarios where
all the devices are on the same network
now let's say that doesn't work
your the next option uh which is the IP
address that is returned from this done
server so the 122.171 is actually my
public IP and if there were if we were
in a scenario where my Nat was
completely permissive this is the next
best option where I can directly
communicate with another peer using my
public IP uh and similarly we have
another candidate which is which is also
using the Civil stand server and finally
if that fails as well we have the
address of the turn server which is the
216.39 and that is the last option
that's going to be Tried by all both the
candidates so we have a small demo here
uh this is an example from the webrtc uh
official guide itself and here we can
configure a list of turn and stun
servers and then we can start generating
the ice candidates so you can see that
it has generated some ice candidates for
us to try so firstly we have the host we
have four variations of the host some of
them are based on UDP and some of them
are based on TCP naturally
UDP is preferred for these kind of
applications because we can tolerate a
little bit of packet loss in these kind
of applications right but wherever
wherever data Integrity is of more
critical is more critical you would use
your TCP over udb and then you have the
relay addresses for some reason you can
see that the Stan server host lookup has
failed so it has not been able to
generate these turn server reflexive
address for some reason probably the sun
server that I'm using is not valid
anymore but this is an example of all
those candidates that are generated by
ice and finally you get a message saying
it was done
great so now that we have covered the
media part of you know the uh the webrtc
framework now we're going to look at how
the metadata is passed and how the
connection is initiated
so metadata is passed so with with
internet or with any when any kind of
communication is involved between two
parties whether it's in the context of
you know the internet or otherwise you
need to establish some common protocol
or some common framework for them to be
able to communicate between you know
people it's usually a language right
between a devices on the internet it can
be Frameworks or it can be standards
like rest or you know graphql right you
need a standard to be able to talk and
communicate information with each other
so in case of webrtc and exchanging the
metadata that webrtc is concerned with
we have something called STP or a
session description protocol even though
it's called a protocol it's essentially
just a data format that describes uh you
know what kind of media and what kind of
streams are available at appear and that
can be sent to the other peer so there
are different parameters we don't really
need to go in depth but if you're
curious there's a website which you know
goes
um which you know deciphers an stb
packet and you can go ahead and read
about each of the fields that are
present and you know you can learn more
about that if you're interested
cool so coming back we have a quick
recap between STP and ice so sdp
describes the metadata about the session
it contains information about the
supported codecs the supported audio and
media audio and video streams and it is
used only during the initial handshake
process whereas ice is concerned with
the networking part of the connection
and how to establish a connection uh the
best connection between the two peers
and it gathers a list of candidates that
you can use and it chooses the best or
the path of least resistance between the
two peers to communicate
so now we cover a lot of theory and now
we can move ahead to the Practical stuff
so in the browser if you were to
implement uh you know webrtc or if you
were to use webrtc you need to handle
three main tasks firstly you need to
acquire audio and video from all any of
the devices that are connected to the
machine next you need a way to
communicate the audio and video and
finally you also need a way to
communicate the arbitrary data if if
your use case requires it and similar
for the three tasks we have three apis
that help us do it firstly we have the
media stream API and this is facilitated
with the get user media function in the
browser it's pretty common and it's used
to access all the devices that are
attached to your browser to to your
device through the browser and then this
is the main API which is used for all
the signaling the sorry for the STP
stuff for the ice candidate generation
and everything in between rtcpa
connection and this is the class or the
API that performs all the heavy lifting
out of the hood and finally we have RTC
data Channel which is used for
communicating the data
cool
so let's take a look at the first API
which is the media stream API and here
you can see that if you were to you know
get access to your media you need to
First establish a set of constraints now
constraints in this case are just video
equal to true so that is it's going to
return any device which supports a video
so we use a navigator.media
devices.getusermedia function and we
pass in the constraints and there's a
success and error callback that has
passed on success we just get access to
the stream and assign it to a video
object that is present on our Dom
previously we used to use video SRC but
now that has been deprecated and we use
SRC object and finally there's an error
callback if something goes wrong we can
get information about that as well
so there's a small demo for get user
media this is again from webrtc samples
it's a really good resource you can
check it out so when I click on the open
camera button it's essentially gonna
request for my camera permissions I've
already granted it permissions so it's
automatically just started but typically
it will ask you for the permission and
only once you explicitly allow it it's
gonna get the stream and display it on
the on on the video element here
there's a simple demo and now we can
talk a little bit more about the
constraints that you can pass so
constraints are really powerful feature
of the get user media it allows you
let's say you have you know hundreds of
devices connected to your machine it
allows you to filter out those devices
based on the exact scenario or you know
the use case that you want let's say you
want a camera that is only that is only
supporting 480p you can specify those
constraints using the Min width and Min
height arguments you can also do that
for you know 720p 1080P and so on and
finally you can pass it to the get user
media function like before so here's
another example of us trying to fetch
different kinds of different resolutions
of video streams so firstly we start
with qvga which is a very basic image we
start with we go with VGA which is much
larger than HT and Full HD and beyond
that if you try to increase the request
for something with additional
constraints you're going to get the over
constrained error because there's no
device which can satisfy a resolution
greater than 1080p as you know the Mac
camera is only a 1080p camera so beyond
that it is not possible so you get the
over constrained error
we have another example here which is
also incorporating frame rates into the
equation
so let's try to set the frame rate to
something really low and when we try to
get media you can see the clear uh you
know the stuttering of the video right
and when I I'm going to increase it to
something much higher and you can see
that it's got much smoother
right so in this way you can also uh you
know filter out different audio devices
as well based on the bitrate that the
different audio devices support and a
lot of other things as well
so it's a really powerful API the next
API that we have is rtcpr connection now
this is as I mentioned the main part of
webrtc this handles a lot of things
under the hood so if you can look at the
the image below it's kind of an
abstraction of all the things that it
encapsulates so it handles everything
from signal processing to codec handling
pure coming peer-together communication
security bandwidth management and
everything in between
so here's a quick sample of how you
would establish or create a webrtc
connection from your site
so if we start off with the constraints
and we Define some you know ice servers
so in this case it's only a stunt server
but you can also Define turn servers in
additional servers you start off by
creating an instance of the rtcpr
connection then you get your uh you know
your user media from the get user media
function you get your streams and for
every track in the Stream you add it to
the peer connection object then you go
ahead and create an offer and this is
what generates the STP or the session
description protocol object and you set
your local description to that object
now you need a way to send this uh to
across to the other peer we'll discuss
that later and then you also need to
receive an answer so there are two there
are two versions of the sdp there's an
sdp offer that you generate or the
caller generates there's an STP answer
which is generated in response to your
offer so the answer needs to come back
to this client and we need to set it as
a remote description and finally we need
to handle the ice candidates so when the
ice candidates are generated we need to
send it across to the other client okay
so let's take a quick uh demo as well
so we use get user media to start the
streams to get access to the user's
devices and upon clicking the call uh
you know button essentially it's doing
all the things that we discussed in this
page here and it transmits My Stream
over to another video element on the
same page right so this is a very simple
example very trivial one but in you know
in the real world you would be sending
that across the network to another
device
okay so let's get let's take a deep dive
into this code example so let's say
Alice and Bob want to talk to each other
again uh so Alice starts off by creating
an instance of the rtcpr connection
object Alice gets access to uh you know
their stream using the get user media
and add subtract to their instance of
rtcpr connection Alice creates an offer
and meanwhile Bob also creates their own
instance of the rtcpr connection object
and you need to start you need to create
a Handler for receiving the ice
candidate so when Alice generates a nice
candidate Alice needs to send it over to
Bob so Bob receives them and Bob adds
those ice candidates to their instance
of rtcpa connection similarly Bob does
the same thing
finally when you click when you run the
set local description this is what
triggers the ice candidate generation
process and because we've already
defined a Handler these will be sent
over to Bob and Bob when he receives the
audio stream uh we can we need to tap
into the on track method which will set
the which will receive the stream and we
can set it to the video element on Bob's
end
finally Bob receives the offer from
Alice Bob sets the remote description to
the offer and Bob generates a counter
answer to that which is also an STP
object and Bob returns it back to Alice
who then sets it as their remote
description and the connection is
complete
okay so here's uh you know a detailed
example of what we discussed all the
steps we discussed so first we get the
you know the uh the device or the stream
using get user media we create a peer
connection which is uh the step we
discussed uh here
uh creation of the peer connection right
and then we go ahead and create the
offer which will generate the STP
and we need to send this offer across uh
first we need to set it uh as a local
description and this will start
generating the ice candidates from Alice
site then we create the answer from Bob
so Bob generates the answer for based on
this specific offer and then we set the
answer on Alice end and that starts the
connection
and then you can hang up right
okay
so uh between all all of this we do not
discuss one step how do we send this
information all the control information
from one client to the other so that is
where we also need a server again it's
called a signaling server and
essentially its only job is to relay
these packets or the STP and the ice
candidates from one peer to the other
apart from that it has no responsibility
does not need to interpret any of those
messages it just needs to relate that's
it and this signaling server is only
used in the initial part of the process
where we were establishing the
connection once the connection kicks off
then it's completely peer-to-peer and
it's fine right and webrtc does not
enforce a standard on the signaling
mechanism you're free to choose any
mechanism that you would like and you're
left to using you know rest apis you can
communicate that with websockets message
queues and postcards emails literally
anything you can think of and even a
carrier period like literally you can
generate the sdp you know print it on a
piece of paper send it with a pigeon
receive it at the other end and write it
down and it will still work now in our
example we're going to be using upright
for as our carrier pigeon so abroad is
going to be that signaling server in
between and we're going to use that the
real-time capabilities of app right to
be able to relay these messages between
the two peers so uh has anybody heard of
app right here
okay a few hands so so a quick intro
about apprite apprite is an open source
back-end server uh it is you know it is
a it's basically makes it makes your
life easy when it comes to building apps
uh all the backend uh you know tasks
that you keep repeating yourselves for
example the authentication the databases
storage and functions and things like
that all of that is encapsulated in
really nice apis for you to use so all
you need to worry about is your
front-end are your business logic and
everything on the back end will be taken
care of by upright so here's a you know
quick summary of apprite's architecture
and all the things that it encapsulates
so upright is built on a microservice
architecture and all the different
services are different micro services
and you can access app right through the
rest API through graphql through real
time or grpc also in the future and you
can access it with any of the your
favorite sdks uh we have a host of you
know web JavaScript sdks for the front
end we have backend sdks in Python Ruby
node.js and so on so how do you get
started there are two ways to get
started firstly it's uh you know you can
self-host it so that's the best part
about app right you you can completely
own your data and stack and with a
simple Docker command you can get it up
and running or the the way we recommend
is applied Cloud which which is you know
One Stop solution which is a hosted
version of app right so all you need to
do is create an account and go ahead and
create your first project now once you
create your first project you're going
to have access to your project ID and
your endpoint so you can install the SDK
locally uh and you can initialize the
SDK with by creating a new client and
setting up your project and endpoint
okay now we go back to our example and
see how apprite comes into the picture
here in the example when I when Alice
was generating an ice candidate we just
set you know we just sent it over to Bob
directly because we had access to both
the objects in the same browser but
where Apple comes in is here so let's
say they you know they are on different
machines right so we need to send this
information uh to Bob so once Alice
generates the ice candidates Alice is
going to use the send to server method
to send this STP offer sorry the ice
candidates to Bob
similarly when Bob generates an ice
candidate Bob also needs to send that
information over to Alice right then
comes the STP part so once Alice creates
an offer or offer for the call Alice
needs to send it over to Bob and then
Bob receives it and then Bob can set up
the offer as their remote description
similarly on Bob's side once Bob
receives the offer Bob creates an answer
and Bob sends the answer back to Alice
then Alice can set the answer on Alice's
end right okay so let's take a look at
the center server method it's something
that we implemented it's not something
present out of the box essentially it's
just creating a document with an app
right so you can again we're coming to
signaling mechanism you can use any
method here to send you know to
implement the logic of send to server it
can be a websocket connection where you
you know write to a specific Channel you
can send a message to a specific queue
or a topic you can you know send an
email you can do anything here the the
whole point is you need to get this
information to the other client that's
it so in this case we create a document
in the database that contains this
information
and finally we also need to handle the
signals right so we discussed how we're
going to send the signals now we need to
handle the signals so in this case uh
this is an example with swelt so where
we're using the on Mount and on Destroy
callbacks but it's similar you know
you'll have similar uh callbacks and
other Frameworks as well essentially I
am creating a real-time connection to a
specific uh to the documents in a
specific collection so anytime a new
document is written to this collection
it's going to trigger a message that I'm
going to receive and if it applies to my
username and my room or you know my chat
room which I just created I'm going to
process it so to process it I have a
couple of scenarios which is the video
offer the video answer and the ice
candidate So based on these three
different scenarios you would be doing
different operations on our on our end
and there are some useful tools that
Chrome provides which you can use to
access a webrtc or debugging information
so let's say you have any open
connections with webrtc you can see all
the metadata about it and all the
debugging and information that you need
and you know to to fix any issues that
you have and finally we have some
resources for you to get started we have
the upright documentation and this is a
really good guide from the mdn docs uh
really wonderful stuff I've taken a lot
of inspiration from this guide and you
can also use that to get started and
there's some really good talks about
webrtc from Google I O as well as some
really good videos by fireship and
Traverse media as well and that brings
us to the end of our talk so thank you
for being a wonderful audience I hope
you are able to get some good takeaways
from this session this just touch the
surface and I'm hoping that you know
you're gonna go back and do some
research and probably build some nice
apps and share it with me so yeah thank
you very much and all the best for the
next sessions
thank you so much Christy
um I hope all of you had a lot to learn
from this talk
our next talk
um oh by the way this was uh actually
like this uh Workshop session and uh
didn't seem like a talk at all so thank
you again so much Christy uh for this
wonderful amazing Workshop slash talk
that you have that you gave us
um next we have atisha bed who's an
engineering manager at birdai and he
will be talking about maximizing
efficiency and security at birdai
through Innovative front-end development
um please give a round of applause for
atisha
all the best for your talk looking
forward to learn a lot from you
so hello everyone good morning
my name is atisha and I'm really excited
to be here to share some of the insights
that I learned while working at Burda
and scaling their large-scale B2B
application so currently I am serving as
an engineering manager with bird eye
where I have a privilege of leading an
exceptional team of talented individuals
I would be really delighted if you guys
can follow me on social media Network so
that we can take the conversation about
this talk or anything in general about
JavaScript forward on the social media
yeah so now uh let's look at the
application that I would be referring to
uh in my talk so uh birdai is a B2B
application you can think of it as a
extensive Hub of various micro apps in
itself so we have apps ranging from a
chat messenger you can compare it with
uh slack and the scale which we are
operating in this uh chat messenger is
like like any user is receiving like
more than 8 to 10 concurrent messages
per second and then we have apps ranging
from like a review monitoring system to
a listing monitoring system payment
system like we have more than 15 micro
apps and itself so and uh if I go by the
Numbers we are operating at around like
more than one lakh global locations and
uh
the average session time which we are
maintaining is the user uses our app
very stickyly so it's uh like more than
six seven hours uh daily on a continuous
basis and that's what I'm going to talk
about that what are the challenges that
we uh faced with this skill
so firstly um before moving forward let
me set the agenda of what we are going
to cover in this talk so we will see
that how does a front-end code base
Falls if there are the system is lacking
and if the code base has scaled to a
large and uh what bottlenecks it would
present then we will see that why these
bottlenecks are relevant in the current
ERA why we were not seeing this problem
like six or seven years back and then we
will see that why it is difficult to
debug these problems then like I'll pick
one of the problem like a memory problem
and then we'll see that how we can
utilize the systems to make increase the
observability so that we can take the
decisions efficiently
yeah so how many in this room are
familiar with this term like Enterprise
user interface development or Enterprise
front-end development like what what is
means like can you like uh show by a
raise of hand quick raise offense like
how how many of us are familiar with the
definition
all right
so when we say that a front-end code
base is of Enterprise level it is very
different from a back-end scale like a
back-end scale could be like you are
handling a million connections or a
databases uh like operating at a larger
scale and the front end never goes down
like a backend does it would not like
never stop like responding but there are
like few problems that will occur uh and
and these problems will slowly occur you
will not realize that uh initially these
problems are there or not but once the
scale is getting larger these problems
would occur so uh
the the problem like examples are like
the performance so whenever I mean you
are adding some new features and you
will always hear that the performance of
your uh site is uh going down the load
time is getting uh increased and uh that
is a concern and then
since the code base has like increased a
lot the development cycle let's say that
you are having a your Dev team is having
a like small ticket like a one or a
three uh story Point ticket but uh they
may say that it would take around like a
couple of weeks to implement this
because uh I mean there is a fear that
something might go go wrong or I'm not
aware of the complete code base
it would take a significant amount of
time
the other characteristics is uh like
whenever your code base or your end
application is using uh like running on
end devices like a mobile or uh like low
end uh Windows laptop it may consume a
lot of device resources like memory uh
and and devices may like go wrong you
may face some heating problems and all
and then uh like uh the dev team would
realize that we need to uh refactor we
need to like upgrade the dependencies uh
that the version of react we want to
upgrade from 16 to 18 or we want to
replace that moment.js Library within
some like lightweight dates library but
people fear that should we do is it the
correct time or is it not the correct
time and then
finally the product development like
your business core logic implementation
would impact because
again there's a fear that uh I mean um
you you are doing something and someone
else code base
or a page may go down so now the next
tempting thing which uh like any
developer would think is uh that we
should go for a rewrite of the
application because we are seeing a lot
of problems we should go for a rewrite
and I can share you by my experience
that rewrites never work as we like
supposed to uh and again you you do a
read write it would start creating the
similar problems if you if the systems
are not in the place
so now why these problems are relevant
in the current ERA why we were not
seeing these uh problems like uh a few
years back and and what has changed in
the current uh development strategies of
web application with respect to front
end
so the major change occurred uh is in
the architecture or the code base which
we are following so if you go back to
the era of when server side languages
were popular like in the like days of
PHP or JSP what used to happen was uh
the server was responsible for doing a
lot of desktops like it would do
maintain the persistence from routing to
data fetching so a server would generate
the complete HTML and it would send
across to the browser too and browser
would just do the work of the rendering
and even when like user would like uh
navigate there would be a complete page
refresh but now uh like we wanted the
user experience to be better so we we
shifted to a SP era and uh
so uh what we did was with the rise of
Frameworks like react or view or angular
we tried to maintain a lot many things
in the browser
like from everything it's a more complex
than maintaining a back-end system like
you are you are maintaining everything
from data fetching to mutations to
rendering to uh providing user feedbacks
and and we did this purposefully because
we wanted that the end user should be uh
like you should feel uh better when he's
using our application
and we were quite successful in doing
that but like what ended up happening
was uh as a side effect of the like this
uh we uh like got caught into a few
other problems like the bundle size has
increased or the memory leak has been
started to occur and the website
complete size has been increased you are
you are caught up in the waterfalls and
and that's what like average internet uh
like survey tells that if you compare
the websites that are now like if you
compare any popular web application it's
like the average is like it's like five
times bigger than it used to be at a
decade before and and this has like uh
made even the use of the systems more
important because now we are facing like
lot many problems
so we were facing like similar problems
that were not not very straightforward
to uh debug so uh I'll I'll like quickly
like run through a few of the problems
that uh we were facing so our
application would slow down in Long
sessions so uh like what users would
report that let's say uh we are using
your app for like continuously for three
four hours and uh like there is
something which is uh not working and uh
like we are seeing some page ranks and
uh these kind of things are happening
and and the other thing which we faced
was like related to like how JavaScript
uh single thread works
so as I mentioned before that we are we
have uh like extensive chat application
and like the scale was like we were
receiving anytime any anything between
like six to ten ten messages any user
would receive in a particular second so
what was happening was the JavaScript
main thread was uh always busy in
getting those messages from the socket
and then do the process and then to
render the render the incoming message
and in between if a user would like try
to navigate anything in the site or if
if he would like click anywhere you
would see that the the feedback is not
very smooth and uh that that was another
problem the third challenge we were
facing was how how we can like secure
the chatting application uh data because
we wanted it to be like compliant and uh
because people were sharing like what
not like their health information their
like diagnostic reports so so how how
should we transfer that over the wire
so what I will do is I like uh focus on
one of the problem in the interest of
the time I'll go deep into that why the
application was getting slowed down uh
and then we'll see that how um it was
due to memory leak problems and if you
are like interested in knowing about the
other problems or the other Solutions
which we did like I'll be around you can
like always reach out to me and discuss
with me
so uh what was happening for us was when
we started debugging that people are
complaining that it is getting uh slowed
down uh the the load time of any page is
fine like our page would like load in
like 1.2 seconds even like apis were
responding like very smoothly then what
is the problem so we conducted several
user interviews uh like uh we went on
the calls with the users and then we
figured out that that there is something
wrong on how our app is running in the
browser if someone is using it uh
continuously and that's why like uh it
it is becoming like unresponsive
and then like even the this problem was
then when I was like searching it was
like it is relevant uh to a lot of
people and uh that like on low end
devices like Windows uh like a majority
of the crashes happens due to this leak
problems and even like it is impacting
business metrics directly because if
someone's like uh your website page is
getting crashed there's like very few
chances that someone would come back to
the website and see so it would directly
impact the uh the business Matrix
now to understand that
how the memory is getting
allocated we need to see that how memory
management works like not just in the
JavaScript but to any language so there
are like three essential things any
memory management system would do it
would allocate the memory so so it is
allocated by the any engine or the
operating system which uh which would
allow like make it available for your
program to use and whenever your program
is running it would do some read and
write operation and that's where it
would like utilize the memory then once
uh the program is finished executing it
has to release the memory release the
memory back to the system and that's
where the majority of the problem occurs
because releasing a memory is not a very
deterministic task and uh even like
JavaScript engine cannot figure out that
what is the right time to release the
memory can I release it memory now and
and there is always approximation that
takes place and that's where the problem
arises when the scale becomes large
so why releasing is uh difficult to that
we need to go again to how under the
hood a garbage collector works in the
browser so again a garbage collector
again has to do three things like it
will identify which objects are or which
variables are live and which are dead
once it has done the identification it
will start to recycle it it has like
started to recycle it with compact like
those small small bits of memory you can
think of as like old school hard
Hardware like hard disk defragmentation
which you you might have done in your
college days uh and and that's what like
on the fly a browser is doing
so visually uh any uh or uh like the
memory management works looks like this
so you have your
JavaScript call stack and then you have
your Global window so these two things
serves as a pointer to uh the garbage
collector garbage collector like starts
looking from the stack and Global window
then it like checks for the references
so let's say there is some object which
is in the stack or the window then what
other object it is referring to then
internally what it does is it will like
break down these into the heaps of like
500 kilobytes so that it it can do like
things uh parallely
and then it will start marking the ones
and the ones which it it like predicts
that these are like maybe they can be
used in the future it would not clean
and and it would keep themselves in the
in the uh main stack
so uh
that's how any uh like uh GC is doing
the um it's like the elbow is called as
Mark and sweep it's marking the objects
which are connected and then it's
sweeping the objects which are
non-connected and the work of this GC is
uh not uh synchronous stock so it's a
combination of async and a synchronous
process so the marking process would be
done like synchronously uh when your
program is running and the sweeping
would be done asynchronously like you
cannot predict that this is the right
time to do the sweep and that that is
the challenge to manage the manage the
memory
and if you like graphically uh look like
it depends on lot many scenarios like
what is the available Ram of any uh end
device and how many objects are
currently in the Heap and that's when
the next GC will be collected and and if
like if somewhere in between the memory
of the end system is less you may see
the crashes or the website would be slow
and that's what was the problem which we
were also facing
so I found a like funny GIF on internet
so uh it's not exactly like it does not
like it spills this but can resemble it
the working of the GC
so by seeing all these complexity like
uh there could be a like common uh
question that yeah GC is so complex so
can't we like trigger uh GC
programmatically so a simple answer is
no you cannot trigger GC there cannot be
any API which would uh trigger uh GC uh
and because it's not a part of
JavaScript and like a different browser
implementation uh like different
versions of GC so there cannot be a
global switch so uh like what we can do
and how we can like start debugging uh
the memory problem so the the number one
step and the simplest one would be go to
the Chrome task manager it shows the
memory you can like right click and go
to the JavaScript footprint uh it's a
snapshot of our uh like footprint like a
while back and then when it realized
that yeah 1.2 GB or it's it's large then
you need to go to the next steps
so then ah
like then you can go into the
performance tab to see figure out that
what exactly is leaking the memory so
that's what like I I was uh like we were
doing the navigations and then we were
checking that how the behavior is
working uh this video is little the
blurry
let me go to the results yeah so so for
us this was the like
so this uh
so the line was uh like really vertical
and uh and uh you you should always
check for these patterns uh if these
patterns are there that means there is a
memory leak I mean using memory is never
the bad thing but it it should go down
immediately or in a while and now once
you figure out that uh
there's a leak so what all the objects
are there you can go and do a hip
snapshot and if snapshot would like give
you the what are objects are currently
objects or arrays or anything what is
currently present and then it shows the
like a couple of things like shallow
size and retained size and distance like
you can ignore it's just the distance
from the window object but these two
things like shallow and retained are
really important so a cello size would
like tell you that
whatever memory it is consuming but it
would not take care of the references
and the like child parent uh things but
retained will be the most important one
because once that variable is deleted it
will show that how much memory would be
free if you delete that memory then in
the snapshot you can like figure out
that which objects and now the next step
should be to go to uh like uh if you see
this by a code like there are like three
objects object a b and c the like
shallow memory of object a object would
be just the like size contained by the
object but that real memory would be the
circular references which it is doing
then next would be to go to exactly the
code base which is creating the problem
so uh
for us when we did the allocation
sampling it is a wonderful tool it will
take you to the like exactly the code
base so so for us the culprit was using
uh immutable JS with Redux so so what
was happening was we use immutable JS
purposefully because we want like uh
every time the fresh objects but what
end up happening is like the uh the
immutable JS in large scale uh like it
creates very de-attached objects and
these objects does not get cleaned very
easily and this was the main culprit of
uh because we were using like immutable
JS and web state to props and
every time like there would be a read
and there would be a like a memory leak
of a large object
yeah
then like what should be a standard uh
size of a web page and there is no like
straightforward answer that how Slimmer
web page should be uh and and to figure
out you need some methodologies like you
can do some debugging or you can do the
methodologies which I'll be talking
about and uh and there are like several
misconceptions when it comes to like
memory or like how JavaScript is working
so so that so it is like uh very popular
saying that yes JavaScript is a fast
language so these problems should not
occur so let's figure out that uh is
does this like holds true in JavaScript
so there was a like once of scientists
who sat down on the popular languages
and there was a research uh conducted on
uh uh this part and then uh they ran
through like various algorithms like a
binary tree or a hash map or a linked
list and how JavaScript is working under
the hood and then they figured out that
there is no relation between uh like how
JavaScript is fast and how it is
relating them to the memory so they came
to a conclusion that it's not always
true that uh language which is fast can
can never be a memory efficient it's
it's there is no correlation but there
is a straightforward correlation that if
you want to uh make a website that is
fast you you have to be Memory efficient
and then like people may argue that why
can't we catch the memory problems in
the code reviews yeah I mean code
reviews are great but they uh like from
my experience I can tell you that they
don't work at Large Scale because like
people may not have like that attention
to the details of these problems and
like everyone gets tired and they they
cannot like figure out that yes this
would really relate to memory or
anything in general which that can
cannot be like predictable while
reviewing the code so uh what should we
like do so uh you you should like always
like have some systems in place which
would like help you to generate this
architecture and they will help you to
uh like predict these problems because
once these problems are created it would
be like really hard to debug and then to
fix uh problems
so
what you can do is there are like
several apis which is available uh so
there's a recent API it is currently
experimental it's like user agent memory
it gives you like this user agent memory
it gives the you can like uh add it as a
reference in your code on any event
listener or you can like trigger that
when whenever this user memory is like
exceeding a particular threshold you can
like connect a web hook and send a alert
then you will realize that yes it is
like having a problem to the end user
because while developing or while the
testing your QA team or on on your like
pre-prod servers you will not be able to
figure out
the other thing is uh you you can always
like write the test cases uh and these
test cases are really important not just
for the memory problems but for other
problems in general you can write the
assets and you you can have some markers
and every time like someone changes the
code you can have this as a like uh
GitHub action and these test cases would
say that yes everything is correct or
everything is not correct then there's a
like very good open source software that
was released by the guys at Facebook
like uh memlab it does the work to some
extent to analyze the like JavaScript
Heats Heap and what is the like uh
leaking in the browser it it like
attaches some of some markers markers
and once it runs you can figure out that
yes the code pattern has changed and
then internally you can attach it with
some uh some analytic tools to the like
see that how the memory is memory or
anything in general is like changing
with respect to your builds or with
respect to the
PRS and even you can utilize like I'm
big fan of uh Puppeteer The Headless uh
version of Chrome
um you can like configure your
integration test using Puppeteer and
this Puppeteer can help you to detect
memory problems either you can use the
API performance dot memory or you can
use user specific memory but this will
give you a good indication of
like how a system is behaving so overall
like what I'm like trying to tell is
these systems should be the base of any
architecture when you are developing any
front-end application because people
don't realize the importance of test
cases or any system because when you
start the code base is small and it
works wonderfully the bundles are small
and it would work wonderfully but once
it reaches a certain level or once your
Dev team size has increased so for us
like our Dev team currently is more than
like 50 people who are working on a like
single
repository because that's the scale now
we have reached and that's where like
problem started to occur and you cannot
like blame anyone you cannot blame that
you reviewed his code and why this code
is creating the problem and that's why
for any software architecture
the system should be the Baseline and
then you should think about once the
system is in place because in this
current ERA if the systems are not in
place uh like sooner or later you will
realize that problem has occurred and
even like the productivity of the team
would uh like really uh hamper and uh
you would be fixing the bugs over like
weekends and uh you would be arguing
that uh why the website is not
performant and why why the bugs are
increasing and why like people are
reporting because maybe internally you
would say that the lighthouse time of
your page is like couple of milliseconds
but uh when users are using it for
longer time is it like just the
load time you should measure or there
are like several other things which you
should measure and without systems you
cannot measure it on the production and
then you should go for the processes
like code reviews architecture
Blueprints and uh
these things should be the second to the
system and then on top of it would be
the patterns like the Frameworks like
react or next.js or any design patterns
that you should use and that's how you
should like structure any front-end
application or even you structure your
team yeah
so that's all for my talk I hope you
guys enjoyed it and you guys took some
like lessons from this uh so if you have
any questions about this thing or the
other problems which I was referring you
you can like I'll be around you can
reach out to me and we'll like I'll be
more than happy to discuss the things
thank you thanks everyone
[Applause]
wow wow that was a super amazing talk I
think also uh very technical and greatly
put so thanks a lot for this talk I
think now my brain cells are like just
have nearly exploded all listing about
heaps and memory leaks so that has
that's something that I have not been
good at since College uh but yeah all
right so uh time for introducing our
next speaker of uh track two uh he's I'm
sure I think you can guess him uh while
I give the intro he is an associate
software engineer at Red Hat he's super
passionate about stuff at open source
and all and uh he really loves like
coding around uh like things like Moto
repos and that's also what his talk is
all about so we have with us Aditya
Krishna who is going to Enlighten us
about some interesting usages about Mono
repos at red hat so please give a huge
round of applause to Aditya Krishna
[Applause]
which is that exact place that you're
from right so how about let me play a
small game with our audience
okay so let's start with a small game
right uh you folks have to guess from
which place in India he is from I'll
start giving you some maybe some small
hints to help you out uh okay let's
start with the place is on some southern
side in India any guesses
what can be the place
okay I see Kerala okay
who else
Bangalore okay so Kerala and Bangalore
two options okay I'll give you some
Morehead some more hint I don't want to
there's very
Hyderabad Chennai okay so so many
options all right one more hint that
I'll give is that place is known for its
traffic
Bangalore now it's obvious so Bangalore
is it Bangalore is it ah so Bangalore it
is
it's open oh sorry
yeah it is Bangla only and though I
would argue that there's uh not too much
traffic like a proper bangalorean so so
what's the so I'll maybe start with you
what's the best thing you love about
Bangalore
um the street food uh I really love
street food and then the filter coffee
uh visited a couple of uh Parts in India
but the filter coffee is
next level in Bangalore and then uh yeah
uh we have conferences meetups happening
every week you get a network with a lot
of people
India the weather obviously
nice yes oh yeah definitely I'm gonna
ask you if it's for some like good
references of filter coffee after this
talk by the way but yeah I'll not take
too much of your time so without any
further Ado let's start with the talk so
Aditya stage is yours give a big round
of applause
[Applause]
uh am I Audible
okay uh
my talk is related to uh
monorepose and how we uh basically use
it at red hat so
okay uh to start off with I have a small
joke
so why did Mona repo go into therapy
or any guesses
uh because because basically you uh
merge you split and then you give rise
to conflicts and uh that's that's uh
real-time uh commitment issues for you
so
yeah
okay
so yeah
um uh nikhil actually introduced me so
I'll just skip this slide and then uh
this is the agenda we are going to talk
about uh basically
reports and uh at the last
how we use learner tread hat
so
yeah
um monorepo
okay
yeah
um
uh so using you basically use one
repository for the uh whole source code
management and uh let's say let's say
you know uh you can consider this room
to be a mono repo and you individual
people will be the specific uh projects
or uh
various packages inside a mono repo and
uh another thing is uh all the code
components gather Under One Roof
basically so
um like like basically like a family
reunion kind of thing
and uh
coming to poly repo uh you basically
have like you know
um let's say let's say
for example
um
yeah you have two or three projects uh
like components you have configs
utilities Etc and you divide them into
multiple things uh or multiple
repositories and you have a specific
repository for each of them and that is
uh poly repo
now uh before we move on to the uh next
slide uh
political uh
another thing okay yeah
sorry
yeah uh basically poly repo
we at the red hat also we use a lot of
poly repo things and we use microfen
times as well
and coming to the similarities
um you know uh both architectures
ultimately track the same source code
and uh for our our project at Red Hat we
use mono repo itself and uh a sibling
project uses a poly wrapper
now
um coming to the differences uh so these
are basically a couple of differences
and then you know let's say you have ah
a mono Ripple contains multiple projects
and then a poly wrapper contains one
single uh project or product or
something similar to that and uh in a
mono repo let's say uh you make some
change and this enables all the
workflows unless you have uh proper
ignoring specifications given
and uh yeah
[Music]
so uh the various monitor managers out
there are we have NX we have turbo repo
uh we have Basel uh and learner uh
a couple of months back the stewardship
of lerna was handed over to uh nrwl that
is the company behind NX and uh they
have been doing pretty pretty good work
uh keeping learner up to date
no um
yeah uh we have local Computing uh
caching
um
yeah so
so what basically you can consider uh
local Computing caching uh it's I would
say it's the ability to store and uh
replay
and processes uh or output of task
basically
um
and then you have a local task
orchestration
so yeah um for this something is like
you know it's the ability to run uh
tasks in correct order and in parallely
so let's say
um
most of us are here uh we are listening
to the we are listening to my talk as
well as using phones or probably uh
chatting with the person next to you so
you are basically running multiple tasks
parallely this is basically like you
know uh local task orchestration in
layman terms
and then uh you have distributed
computing caching uh so it's the ability
to share cash artifacts across uh
different environments basically you
know you have a Dev environment you have
a broad environment and all and the cash
is shared across uh multiple
environments
this is this can include CI as well uh a
couple of tools like uh MX uh turbo
report uh uh even learner also allow for
distributed computing caching
now uh distributed task execution uh
it's the ability to to basically
distribute comment across many machines
while we largely uh preserve the Econo
economics of uh running it on a single
one so in layman terms I would say you
know let's say you get a
multiple tasks or uh issues or something
like that and then you divide it into
your team uh you give a front-end person
the front-end task back-end person the
back-end task and all and you basically
ensure that
all the tasks gets distributed and
executed at the same time
now uh determining affected projects or
packages so uh
let's say you do a specific change in
one of the package in a mono repo and
then uh you you would not want to have
like you know uh run build for each and
every packages in the monorail right so
a very crucial feature of mono repo
manager says to determine what changes
you have done and only publish those
packages
now um coming to the demo uh will be
I'll be showing you a small demo of how
uh we use learner and uh even uh we're
kind of working on a POC to migrate it
into turbo repo uh but due to a couple
of constraints I'm not allowed to show
the turbo report one uh
so yeah uh lerna uh and how we use uh
basically you know uh we use all of the
features what comes with learner like we
have bootstrapping publishing versioning
and running commands concurrently uh
bootstrapping is basically you know uh
let's say you have multiple packages in
a mono repo and you want to run uh npm
install in uh each of them and you give
a learner bootstrap and it installs in
every other packages
publishing uh publishing it something
like you know uh you have
you made changes to a specific package
in a repository and uh you want to
publish that specific package uh using
your Ci or uh your CLI itself basically
and you can do the same using uh learner
as well repo actually does not support
uh publishing of packages unless you use
some uh
other tools like change sets or npm
workspaces
and uh learner can also run comments
concurrently
so ah
this is a small diagram of basically how
uh lerna bootstrap works so let's say
you have the before thing uh shows uh
one package having uh in a sorry uh you
have child a and child B uh being the
packages and then child BS at one
version and let's say you run a learner
bootstrap after that you know you
basically uh the node modules and the
build file of uh child b gets copied
into child a and you can use the child
the B inside cell there basically
now um let me show you a small demo uh
okay
yeah uh so this is basically uh
what uh our project is uh we are uh I'm
working on the team which is responsible
for the customer portal of uh uh red hat
and then uh you know you have these
packages like uh apis cases components
config utilities and uh permissions
basically
and then all of this are inside one
specific repository uh that's the very
secret area 51 app uh
uh and now
yeah so uh we have learner to do most of
our tasks like oh um
yeah uh lerna can uh
bootstrap and this is another feature in
learner basically uh hoist what it does
is basically uh you know uh
when you run run learner bootstrap the
node modules get copied into
each and every package but let's say you
don't want to do that and you want to uh
uh have it globally such that only one
uh
uh only one folder will have the node
modules so you can do that by using a
hoist and then uh we have the build
script which runs build in all the
packages and even for test also we have
a
thing such that it you know
runs test parallely
so this is this is uh one thing now
let's say if I uh do something like you
know uh
yeah um so this is this is like a uh
was created in a very urgent manner uh I
have perf.js that is responsible for uh
showing the current time uh and then we
have uh npm run build and then again uh
purchase
now you may get a question like why
didn't I use uh performance dot no which
is available in node.js so for that we
are currently using uh node version
14.18 so that does not support uh
performance.now yet
uh so let's say if I run
this come uh run build and I have the
time set at 10 52 41
seconds
so this is gonna take uh a couple of
time to uh
build the application basically
so um until then uh I'm
uh so I have a I have a joke for you so
um
go on a diet
any answers
basically it wanted to become lean and
mean so that's why it uh basically went
to uh went on it ahead
so yeah uh currently what's happening is
uh you know uh all the CSS from uh
various packages are getting copied and
then you know uh it will be put into a
build folder
and it's the same case with
uh
[Music]
the code as well you know you have uh UI
components in one and then utilities and
all and this
come together and will be run parallely
to uh give a building
so yeah uh
from not wrong we started somewhere at
uh
today
yeah we started at 10 50 to 41 and then
current time is somewhere around 54 14
that's
um
one minute some odd seconds
uh so if I there's another one actually
uh as as learner
stewardship was handed over to NX so
what NX did this uh they basically you
know added some steroids to learn to
make it even more buff
uh
oh
okay my
and uh they added a new feature in NX
like uh again uh this was a a couple of
months back itself uh
using one specific flag use NX you can
instruct lerna to uh
uh send all the commands uh to
NX and NX will take care of it under the
hood so if I just enable it like
true
uh
and then if I if I run the same
comment again
the performance difference is not a lot
I would say uh as ours is not a very
huge mono repo and the gain is somewhere
around uh 10 15 seconds uh
but still uh we are saving some time and
then if it comes to CI uh as as my the
performance of my specific computer is
uh a lot higher compared to the CI so in
CI it actually gives like a benefit of
around 30 to 40 seconds which is like a
a very huge saving
and uh even even for uh
running tests or uh
um running build bootstrap the CIA is
pretty fast if you use NX compared to
lerna uh even though we are using uh
learn on the surface level and NX Works
under the hood but just enabling uh NX
flag use NX to be true it can actually
give you a very significant uh
Improvement in terms of performance
so
okay that's
so 1056 it started and it's somewhere
around uh 10 uh 57 I would consider it
to be so again it's not a very huge uh
Improvement in terms of uh uh
the whole thing but again uh 10 15
seconds on your local PC wouldn't matter
much but uh having like around 40 or 30
40 seconds in CA is Gonna Save a lot of
time and uh let's say you are you are uh
you create a change you basically add a
new feature and then you have multiple
commits you send one commit and then the
CI starts running and it uh checks for
uh
it tests it runs the lint check and then
it again uh runs the bill check uh here
for all the three things you can
consider to be consider the amount of
time saved to be somewhere around uh a
minute to two minutes and then uh if you
again uh lose learner you're gonna have
a disadvantage of uh uh around one and a
half minute per each commit let's say
you send one commit and then after a
couple of minutes you send another
commit uh
if your changes are tested uh sometimes
you know we tend to uh send test changes
uh if I'm not wrong so uh whenever you
send this test changes
you basically want to check okay if the
CIA is running or not and then at that
moment I would say
saving a minute or two is
a very huge Improvement
so yeah uh
that's basically the whole thing uh
related to my talk uh I was supposed to
show a small POC of uh
how we use turbo repo uh that's what
that's something which I've been working
on uh but yeah due to some constraints I
won't be able to show that
yeah thank you so much everyone
thank you so much for this wonderful
talk and it's okay glitches happen but
it was amazing do you all agree
okay I see there's a little dull energy
in the room and I don't like it uh so
maybe we'll live you know liven it up a
little
um I want some volunteers coming in on
stage uh four on my side four on nickel
side please
come on come on have a cup of coffee
maybe and come up for some something fun
four on my side four on nikhil's side
let's see some raise of hands who want
to come
any people yes please come you don't
have to raise your hands
who else who else
how many people do we have here can we
give them a cheer please
[Music]
okay he's in my team now okay
come on people come on you can come on
stage
who else okay
okay yes yes
you just got live stream and that's
that's the trick part of it okay okay we
have three on my side two on nickel side
actually now there is okay so there are
three now here ah you got four I need
one more please one more now
I don't want to lose
come on guys who can who can join us who
can join us come on
hey yay girl power
okay so now we have some balance teams
okay a big round of applause for all our
volunteers here please it's going to be
fun you don't want to miss it but let me
quickly ask your names please
soccer
okay and on this side uh
hi I'm juhi
I'm Nico Singh
what's up
hi I'm lavish goel okay awesome so I
think I'll call I'll call my team team
okay
the Dosa theme
and the verapao team competing with each
other so nikhil and I are going to give
scenarios to each other
so I'll give one scenario to nikhil's
team and nikhil will give one scenario
to my team all right and the and the
challenge is that you have to sing the
first song that comes to your mind when
you hear that challenge right and you
will get on the clock 10 seconds do you
have a stopwatch because I left my phone
there yeah you will get me don't cheat
right to sing the right song or the most
app song in that scenario
yeah shall we start so everybody excited
should we start the challenge and and
and the job of all of you people is to
judge who's the winner okay
so I think you've I don't I don't uh
rely on you but I rely on these forces
Let's Get It Started let's have the
first scenario
okay so I think we'll start from our end
and let's uh let's give a scenario to
them yes so one scenario that we can
give is let's say you have
so you are planning some party on a
Friday night and suddenly an incident
pops up
so what should be the song
that you should yeah so what will be the
song
so back on a Friday night at an incident
what will be your song
let's see which song can be most
appropriate
it's a nice one yeah
I think we'll switch turns maybe yes and
the scenario that I would like to give
to your team
is um that you are happily working from
home
but your evil manager calls you three
days a week to the office
in Bangalore traffic
no
come on guys we can we can think of
something come on what can be that song
eight
seven
okay in the end it doesn't even matter
how you try you still have to go to
office when you manage your calls for it
trying to sing the Linkin Park song
can you can you please sing it better
in the audience anyone the Linkin Park
song
okay okay
I tried so hard and got so far but in
the end it doesn't even matter
all right nice one
big claps
all right so audience agrees it's a tie
or are we better
oh okay maybe like just let's just maybe
vote who all are with uh like this team
team Dosa No Hands no hands I don't see
hands okay how many hands are there
seriously who all think team Dosa did
better yes
okay there are some hands okay
oh
foreign
so I think I see like a mix of emotions
here I see so there are some mixes okay
next scenario please make it yeah okay
do does my team have any scenario
production
that's the same thing as Friday night
that's
okay ah this is like a very uh you know
a very different one so you come to your
office offside and you're struggling to
find a PG or like a place to stay
so what will be your song in that case
by the way like till the time they are
like thinking of this who all like
relate to this so you were working from
home who already like finding anything
right so you need to find a place and
you are struggling to find a place to
live
that's not even a fun scenario come on
you can give us better scenarios yeah
this is that this was a good scenario
you know yeah so like maybe let's try
thinking of something something
different yeah give us happy scenarios
okay I'll throw a challenge okay maximum
number of challenges also wins by the
way so I'll throw a challenge you ha you
just got calibrated you were expecting a
promotion you didn't get one
okay you got you were not expecting a
promotion but you got one yeah
unfair team
okay we got the song okay yes overpower
team already
the song by Adnan Sami
oh but awesome awesome
[Applause]
nice yeah nice good suggestions okay
give us a happy scenario back okay let's
think of some happy scenario
any scenarios in mind
let's try to have some happy scenarios
for these people
ah oh heaven
when the manager is off when the manager
is on leave he's on leave oh it's not
off
I assume
[Music]
yeah
that's some awesome a big round of
applause for both these teams
such fun people yeah um Can Can we now
say that team Dosa is winning I need a
yes
do you have like planted people in the
audience
we have not like they are the most uh
you know uh
intellectual people here that I can see
they are the most best yeah most well so
let's go I think maybe let's help them
out a bit maybe let's give them one more
scenario for them to decide let's have a
decider round like the one last thing I
think the audience should give the
scenario and the one who sings the
better song wins how about that
so anyone in the audience wants to give
the scenario I'll come down and give you
the mic
anyone please please show our friends
please so that I can come
I can already hear some suggestions but
yeah let's have a show of hands whoever
wants to give a scenario yeah there are
some hands on the back okay
uh changing the product specs after the
development is done
anyone from the audience wants to sing a
song on that
anyone
oh by the way if you do sing a song so
I know they're like very talented people
just like team badappao here who can
sing good songs oh come on team those
are rocks
let's see if there are like amazing
singers from the audience wants to do
this
yeah I think I see one hand here yes I
see a very relaxed
do it
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
office
a pair of Footwear in office because you
were in a rush or something
okay okay that's a very quirky scenario
I've never heard of it have you ever
worn different pair of Footwear in
office
okay anybody wants to sing a song on
that
I think for this scenario mine yeah my
awesome team has one so so yeah let's
heat it up for them
okay
awesome
this was really good okay I think team
and team Dosa can come back and both of
you did great
um I wouldn't take audience sport on it
because you all are biased uh but both
of you will get some goodies please give
it a big round of applause for all these
people and you all volunteers can we
please note down their names please
can we please note down their names
please yeah please take your seats
thanks a lot
now I want another set of people four
here four there uh this is again going
to be something amazing so four people
decide four people that side
anyone any volunteers
let's see some new faces we won't ask
you to sing don't worry this is going to
be much more complicated than that
anyone any volunteers here
come on people
you see a moment in that area
yes yes yes go for it yes nice
anyone else do you want to come on stage
please
so I think we have two okay yes yeah
three from this side yes nice awesome
anyone else you sir
yes you no no no no don't point to
someone else please
thank you thank you for cooperating
anyone from that side I see a group of
guys not even looking at me
pretending hard not to be seen and now
you're smiling so please
please I'm inviting you to the stage
please
come on come on you can do it be a sport
come on come on on stage
I think we have nominated someone yeah
that's the spirit okay okay nice I think
we we do have four but I have my eyes on
you I'll get back to you
okay so the next
challenge round
and this is going to be tough
is that each of these teams four of you
right four of you each have managers
right or are you a freelancer or
something managers you all have managers
okay I want the most honest two-word
feedback for your manager
most honest and the audience will decide
who's honest your managers are not here
right
and the audience will decide who has
given us the best or the most honest
answers about their managers because
trust me I don't like mine either
so
shall we start
oh I am a manager but my reporters still
don't love me
no no you don't have to give me good
good boy answers okay
give me your honest feedbacks honest
feedbacks let's start
I have a positive feedback
hi my name is Lippi I'm from Zita
so I actually have a positive feedback
about my manager because he's pretty
cool he gets blackout drunk with us on
the offsides so I'm not gonna deny that
he's not cool
thank you for that Honesty blackout
drunk I'll on offsides okay thanks
thanks
yeah hi I'm nitin I'm also from Zita so
about my manager so he gives me some
tickets
yeah so he gives me some tickets to work
on the Sprint and then all email or
anything he gets like he forwards to me
and I work on those and after two weeks
I say key I didn't work on this I worked
on this
no it's not changing the requirement
like the thing I do is not the thing
that is decided
saying that his expectations and your
work do not match but whose problem is
it it's the managers or your problem
definitely the managers definitely the
manager's problem okay good thank you
for that Honesty
yeah hi this is trishla from Zita so
yes
oh this is team yeah there's actually
team Zita here oh nice I'll say my
manager is somewhat diplomatic at the
time of review
if Zeta managers are hearing this you
can find us on track too
and you can find the relevant people
but he's really supportive as well
it's uh yeah it's the prime time to say
okay
that's very necessary in this culture
nowadays
okay okay
hey all I am Anamika and I work at
Philips so my manager is very chill
until I fix the bug that I have created
[Laughter]
okay okay we had some good managerial
feedback here let's see what you got
here yeah let's see what the team here
has to say all right
hi all my name is Praveen so there are a
lot I can say in
yeah so there are a lot I can say in
plus point but I don't want to do that
so there are some negatives why I don't
like my manager so they give you some
timelines or they want to finish your
tasks within the timelines but they want
you in the same time you will be calling
in all the meetings so if you are in
meetings I don't work or if you want me
in meeting like either give me meetings
or work I can't handle both good so yeah
it's a developer perspective according
to me I think I think this was an
eye-opener for me because I do the same
I expect my people to attend meetings
and also work so sorry
that's okay that's okay I don't mend it
she's also a manager
yeah yeah yeah we'll find one for you
you and me and your manager should chat
yeah
and you are
all right so let's go to the next one
okay
okay so I'm from Bloomberg and my
manager is pretty chill I think we give
him more trouble
so most of the time it's like a team of
11 people and some time or the other
someone is saying
okay like that I think his main problem
and because there's a lot of like
retention in our team so
that's a big issue so he's kind of
scared
then that's a big issue so you scare
your manager this is that code word if a
manager like whenever things are not
right he'll just use and you're like no
he is
and you know just leave
this kind of thing this can become a
secret word of managers whenever they
are like pissed off or like they're not
happy and everybody will be like ah now
we are going to be in big trouble all
right let's go to the next one
hi uh this is nafis from ymo
um can you repeat that and can you hold
that closer okay I'm the fish from vimo
software and uh my manager is very
supportive but when a critical issue
comes now yeah he's like the Devil with
the horns huh
all right all right that is the main
problem how do you handle that devil
that's nice I like the honesty all right
time for the last one
um yeah I'm abhinav and actually uh
mine's a little different because I come
from a non-profit organization and so
basically we are actually a research
organization turning into a
venture-based organization so the
problem I think I have with my manager
is like she's too um
soft-spoken like very much so I'm sort
spoken so because that because of the
knowledge so she cannot be tough she
cannot be the tough girl and I feel at
times that she requires to be that
person interesting interesting anybody
in the audience now that you know what
we are asking any insights any
Innovative insights on your manager that
you want to share here
the the dirtier the better
you stand to win goodies so it's goodies
versus you know buttering your managers
so decide I think I think I think they
might also have a lot varsha to discuss
but I think uh now let's also like get
back to the main event to like is it 11
20 years oh yeah definitely okay okay
but since I already asked the audience
can can someone quickly quickly okay
let's have some quick thing
anybody who wants to discuss something
about their managers don't worry we'll
cut this live stream no worries
okay do we have some okay yes I see a
very strong raise of hand so I think you
have something very interesting to say
I'm actually kind of scared uh is your
manager here uh not really but then my
colleagues are here so it might go to
office what is Kelly so who are present
in the room okay you know not dig deeper
so uh what happens is uh although he's
really cool as a person right also might
be an empathetic being but then uh
uh there is one thing that kind of pokes
me a lot that he's from back in domain
and I am a full-fledged core front-end
you know
and you know more than him
I mean if you ask front and maybe yes
that's what it is right
so then what I feel uh many of the times
no I get a little vibe from him that he
consider front ends to be like not as
significant or not as you know like a
heavy lifting as could be attacking
and you know many there are many peoples
who are like okay you know we are the
mainstream developers that's the backup
and then I'm like very much uh you know
you might be true maybe 10 years back
but the industry has evolved a lot and
things and situations are different now
I agree with you dude I don't care if
your colleagues are here front end rocks
can you say that out loud please
all your front-end developers we rock
right and do some people uh
uh not my manager maybe did some people
it might be like hey they just play with
colors and some HTML templates yeah yeah
that's what no no no no no no it's not
that simple
simple actually you're from which
company actually
why are you on a call yeah
yes and he's with me yeah you can find
him on track too yeah
but yeah nobody no no but I'll take
class of your manager because front end
definitely rocks and our next lineup
will prove to you I mean you don't need
any proving because your lord belong to
the same group but let's welcome our
next speaker
um
all right
yes yes we'll say goodbye to yours thank
you for being a sport thank you for
helping us out figure out what we do
collectively bad as managers I have some
notes to take
all right over to you varsha then
right uh so our next talk is by
Siddharth dayalwal
Siddharth can we have you on stage
please
a very good morning Siddharth and thank
you for joining us
yes that's the energy we need
yay
Siddharth will be talking about creating
scalable and flexible web applications
in a headless approach I think maybe you
should tell your manager that
right okay over to you Siddharth have a
good talk thank you everyone
hello just bear with me while I'm
connecting this oh it is actually
connected
but I do not need to show everything to
you also I'll just hide couple of things
because of course Secrets there should
be Secrets everywhere
so just bear with me quickly
cool
all right I guess this was good
foreign
sorry for that
cool so hello everyone can I get a quick
hooting or something just like a wave a
hand raise quickly hey everyone
yeah that's what I like so this is what
we're gonna do actually this is a
lightning talk I'm not gonna take much
of your time quickly let's say seven ten
minutes hardly uh that's even more I'm
saying but welcome to my talk thank you
so much for being present at track two I
know there are two tracks and you
sitting here uh skipping the track means
a lot to me actually so thanks a lot for
staying here of course this is me first
time speaking at jsconf India so I was
quite looking forward to it uh and I'm
quite happy to be here interact with a
lot of folks a lot of people I actually
know and I'm knowing more about many
others today so yeah excited for that
but as you can see headless cm is
creating scalable and flexible web
application that's what we're gonna talk
about but
is it that actually we'll get to know
while we are proceeding with the talk uh
I'll say Nama you'll say Bengaluru
sounds good nama
a little louder nama
yes that's what we wanted so thank you
so much for being here talking more
about me I am as mentioned by the host I
am working as a developer Community
specialist at storyblock which means I
look out for all things Community
programs and events there I'm also a
guitar field expert from the India
region I'm a major league hacking coach
organizer for hack this fall and of
course speaker for today
but
before even jumping I really want to
share this special thing that we are
giving away a couple of things on our
booth which you can find in the
community Lounge so make sure you check
that out and don't forget to take some
good pictures while I'm talking so that
you can tweet about it and get some cool
facts from our both and also you can
take a quick photo of this because we
are giving I get DOTA subscription worth
two hundred dollars so I guess I would
not miss as a developer I can get any
front-end course for me using this one
so why not let's give it a try cool but
moving on let's talk about this term
which you see Swiss army knife of the
web now if you might have attended my
talks from previous conferences I've
used this term over there as well so
how many of you all know what Swiss army
knife is quick raise of hand just tag
couple of them if you have watched Man
versus wild you might have seen Bear
Grylls using that on a daily basis and I
am very fond of this tool because this
is multi-purpose I can use it anywhere
for anything right and headless CMS is
kind of a Swiss army knife but for web
how we'll talk about it
yeah that is Swiss army knife for all of
those who didn't raise their hand and
this is the web but you see a
exclamation with a red icon over there
of course there is something which is
missing and which is headless CMS so can
anyone like even before jumping on that
how many of you all know what headless
CMS is quick raise of hands once again
only a few but I am hoping that after my
talk you would know more about it
actually and even if you can't know we
already have our own both at storyblock
here in the community Lounge so when I
talk about headless CMS CMS stands for
Content management system now you might
be knowing about something like
WordPress right Wix all of these are
like more of Monolithic or traditional
CMS but while I'm while I'm talking
about storyblock it's a headless CMS
which means you can work independently
irrespective of your front end or
back-end means they both are decoupled
in a way so let's say if you want to do
some changes you necessarily do not
affect what's live you can actually see
what's happening in the back end the
back end cm is totally different than
that but
yeah it's a solution so using the same
body to support any number of different
heads so it's like headless right so
here you obviously see the answer why
front end back end is separated and it
is a decoupled way but
what does headless CMS does or how is
that helpful what are the features of it
let's talk more about it faster
implementation and flexible now here's
the thing when I say fast implementation
I do not necessarily need to code all
these sections or components of my
website let's say right I can just
Define my own blocks I can Define my own
components and use it anywhere so it's
just like super fast implementation
multiple ways and it becomes super
flexible as well at the same time
because I necessarily do not need to see
what page I'm working on or what
component I need to you know find out I
can just create the structure of it and
then directly start using and just you
know call it out maybe fetching an API
from my own code base and just work
around it
future proof of course because I have
defined my own blocks on Define Sigma or
let's say components for that matter I
can keep it using for all the future
website I'm gonna build I just need to
work on my ux maybe do some tweaks
around how it looks and I guess I do not
need to actually code it out all because
I already have things defined beforehand
omnichannel architecture now it's not
necessary that we are only going to use
our website let's say for a single
platform many times we use it for web
mobile let's say our smart watches or
anything now because headless is an
omnichannel architecture it allows us to
see our content on each and every
platform while we are actually building
it so no matter whatever platforms you
are having for yourself you can see how
that experience will be for your users
or for anyone who are going to use your
website or something
cost effective why not like I do not
necessarily need to go around here and
there find out different uh Services
which can help me manage my content I do
not need to depend on what kind of
front-end Frameworks I'm using good
thing a very interesting one which I
love about headless CMS is that you can
use it with any of your favorite
front-ended Frameworks you name it and
you can use it with that so that is
quite easy for us to manage as well
scalable of course the above Four Points
I guess obviously Define how scalable it
can be speed and is I am sure uh once we
start defining more components around
CMS space or while we are working with
the back end only platforms this comes
in handy because this again goes with
the flexible feature of it software
architecture now let's say we have
different content blocks there may be
nestable there may be nestable or not
but when it comes to many more
sub-branches or more of it we can
actually put it under each and every
other and we can create a good hierarchy
and that makes it even more structured
it helps you with your SEO of your
website and multiple other uh
things as well
but now of course while I'm talking
about headless CMS I cannot miss talking
about storyblock uh I'm working there
right and it's not something which I
have been forced to do but because I
love what storyblock does around the
space right so storyblock is a back-end
only headless CMS which essentially
helps developers in content editors to
make their content experience across all
digital platforms even more better
this is how it actually looks like so if
you see uh this is like a live preview
on the very right you'll see our own
visulator one super unique thing about
storyblock which makes it different from
other cms's out there is it's visual
editor so anything which you're working
on with you can actually see it
happening right in front of you even
before you go ahead and publish your
content
so what to watch out for in a headless
CMS you might be thinking that okay I
know what a headless CMS is but what
things should I consider while I'm maybe
choosing a headless CMS so I would just
like to summarize it in four options
first is visual editor which I recommend
you all to go and check out on
storyblock.com because it's not just
about me pitching about what
storyblock.com is or it is about how
better the experience can be once you
start building on the starter templates
fetching your code base using our own
apis I think that can be a game changer
for you how you see the digital content
experiences you know growing from one
platform to other
component approach I've I guess
mentioned in multiple times uh component
approach is basically something which
helps you a lot while you're working on
your website and also when it's
Omni Channel I guess the next point and
the advanced technology which I said it
works with all your front-end Frameworks
so you can take it forward from there so
I guess if you try going around and
seeing these particular things while you
are choosing your headless CMS more than
enough I feel and if there's anything
you are looking out for please let me
know I can help you with that
but whom is it for okay
we got to know what headless EMS is what
to watch out for but is it for you is it
actually for me how to know that or whom
is it for
actually it is for everyone and uh when
I say headless CMS I would also mean
soil block works for everyone right
starting with developers of course just
like you all people right uh I know you
all love coding maybe in your favorite
Technologies uh react view knocks Nooks
gets me anything right so works with
everything content editors I feel uh in
today's world content editors needs a
lot of scalability and flexibility with
the kind of content they are working on
scheduling things on websites you know
adding a lot of collaborations and so
much more
marketers I guess they have a lot of uh
initiatives lot of campaigns running out
this can be wonders for them and
Enterprises like of course like at the
end of the day there are many
Enterprises who are looking for fast
solution more flexible and more reliable
solution so this is the thing for them
actually so they do not necessarily need
to run behind live coding or just coding
their websites bugging their developers
again and again this can just make it
simple for everyone
I would have loved to do some demo and
show you the story block but what we are
going to do is we are actually live
showcasing the visual editor and all the
demos uh you can come with us with your
Technologies or anything and we are
actually doing it in our booth so this
is my time to introduce you even more
about storyblock and welcome you all to
our booth so feel free to reach out to
us with any questions and anything and
uh
by end of this conference we are there
we are not going anywhere so you can
always find us over there
but yeah your headless CMS sorry blog it
is and uh thank you so much means a lot
to me that you listened and uh went was
what were with me so far and yeah
appreciate everyone uh thank you so much
I hope I was on time
awesome
yeah all right
thanks to that I think uh everybody I'm
sure everybody loved your your talk uh
thanks for uh taking us through these
insights about uh headless CMS so yeah
all right so we uh we have with us our
uh diversity sponsors Publius is Sapien
who are actually conducting Express
interviews so feel free to find them at
our community lounge and who knows you
might be walking out with an offer so
feel uh don't forget to check them out
also I know that uh with all these talks
and and like the ceremony going in uh we
might have I don't know I know we might
have bored you a bit not the speakers
like uh we MCS I think we might have
like bored you a little so it's time for
us to I think take a quick shot uh
coffee break of around 10 minutes uh
feel free to find people uh at the area
and uh network with them chat with the
speakers and we'll be back in around 10
minutes so see you back
please be back in about 10 minutes so
that our next talk can start on time
foreign
[Music]
could help your organization change the
world for the better better Technologies
better experiences better tomorrows
we're publicist Sapient a global digital
business transformation partner helping
organizations improve lives through
digital elevating experiences optimizing
data and Reinventing products all to
create a better tomorrow for who matters
most everyone
poopless is sapient
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
we just need to understand the data
see the proof
know what works call that being
particular we call it being precise
we don't want head scratching gaps
guesses assumptions or opinions We crave
insights and Answers born from data
we're Engineers who love how having all
of our Telemetry metrics events logs and
traces cuts through the crosstalk
separate signal from noise
fact from opinion
it's not data for show it's data that
shows because it saves us time settles
debate cancels meetings before they even
start and says hey look over here this
is the problem when Dev Ops security and
business teams come together around data
it washes away the doubt it reveals the
connections we all know are there the
threads that point to the path forward
and what will really work
this is Theta for engineers
[Music]
the visual editor is the heart of
storyblock
the intuitive user interface allows you
to manage your content simply by
browsing your website
by clicking on a component in your live
preview the configuration appears on the
right hand side
you can jump to multiple components and
drag and drop your content wherever you
prefer
able to add and change the layout of
your content
rearranging text or optimizing and
adding new images is as easy as it can
be
creating great content is a team effort
storyblock makes it easy for all teams
to collaborate in real time within the
visual editor
once you're finished editing you can
either start a feedback loop with a
custom publishing workflow
or publish instantly
users create content and go to market
faster with storyblocks visual editor
try for free at storyblock.com
tired of missing out on event photos
with pre-magic those days are gone just
scan the QR code snap a selfie and let
the AI work its magic instantly access
event photos through a link sent via
email and WhatsApp but that's not all
boost event sponsors Roi and visibility
with our in gallery placements
supercharge your event experiences with
three Magics real-time photo
distribution pre-magic your memories
delivered in real time
what if digital could help your
organization change the world for the
better better Technologies better
experiences better tomorrows we're
publicist Sapient a global digital
business transformation partner helping
organizations improve lives through
digital elevating experiences optimizing
data and Reinventing products all to
create a better tomorrow for who matters
most everyone
publicist Sapient
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
we just need to understand the data
see the proof
know what works call that being
particular we call it being precise
we don't want head scratching gaps
guesses assumptions or opinions We crave
insights and Answers born from data
we're Engineers who love how having all
of our Telemetry metrics events logs and
traces cuts through the crosstalk
separate signal from noise
fact from opinion
it's not data for Shell it's data that
shows because it saves us time settles
debate cancels meetings before they even
start and says hey look over here this
is the problem when Dev Ops security and
business teams come together around data
it washes away the doubt it reveals the
connections we all know are there the
threads that point to the path forward
and what will really work
[Music]
this is Theta for engineers
the visual editor is the heart of
storyblock
the intuitive user interface allows you
to manage your content simply by
browsing your website
by clicking on a component in your live
preview the configuration appears on the
right hand side
you can jump to multiple components and
drag and drop your content wherever you
prefer
able to add and change the layout of
your content
rearranging text or optimizing and
adding new images is as easy as it can
be
creating great content is a team effort
storyblock makes it easy for all teams
to collaborate in real time within the
visual editor
once you're finished editing you can
either start a feedback loop with a
custom publishing workflow
or publish instantly users create
content and go to market faster with
storyblocks visual editor
try for free at storyblock.com
missing on event photos with pre-magic
do SE days are gone just scan the QR
code snap a selfie and let the AI work
its magic instantly access event photos
through a link sent via email and
WhatsApp but that's not all boost event
sponsors Roi and visibility with our in
gallery placements supercharge your
event experiences with three Magics
real-time photo distribution pre-magic
your memories delivered in real time
what if digital could help your
organization change the world for the
better better Technologies better
experiences better tomorrows we're
publicist Sapient a global digital
business transformation partner helping
organizations improve lives through
digital elevating experiences optimizing
data and Reinventing products all to
create a better tomorrow for who matters
most everyone
poopless is sapient
oh
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
we just need to understand the data
see the proof
know what works call that being
particular we call it being precise
we don't want head scratching gaps
guesses assumptions or opinions We crave
insights and Answers born from data
we're Engineers who love how having all
of our Telemetry metrics events logs and
traces cuts through the crosstalk
separate signal from noise
fact from opinion
it's not data for show it's data that
shows because it saves us time settles
debate cancels meetings before they even
start and says hey look over here this
is the problem when Dev Ops
welcome back everyone
maybe you can quickly text and reach out
to your friends and ask them to be back
because we'll be starting shortly
can we all please settle down
all right how was coffee
not good
I thought people would be more energetic
after the coffee break
okay thank you
are you all excited for the next lineup
awesome so without further delay because
uh I think we were supposed to start at
11 45
um I would like to welcome karthikeya
Sharma on stage
is a software architect at epam systems
and he will be talking about unlocking
Dynamic visual experiences and
unleashing the power of web assembly
just just uh a couple of questions uh is
is webassembly a field of interest for
you yeah we are trying to explore new
dimensions of the web where you know uh
the perform we are more focusing on the
more performant applications
where the web uh the web assembly plays
a very crucial role in terms of
visualizations where you need to do
compute intensive you have three dot JS
you have webgl coming into the picture
you need computers compute intensive
JavaScript as it is like you know we
have a single threaded uh single
threaded thing but webassembly provides
us a lot of binary code in the browser
where we can execute a lot of binary
code in the browser itself and it helps
us to create more faster applications
awesome that's that sounds amazing I
think uh we all including me have a lot
to learn from this talk over to over to
you karthikeya and all the best
thank you
please a round of applause
[Applause]
uh thank
am I Audible
okay
thank you so much for the introduction
um as I've been introduced as karthika
Sharma so let me tell you a little bit
about myself
I am a hardcore coder so I started my
journey as a you know SQL PL SQL I
graduated to be a full stock I am
working as a software architect as
introduced so now I'm here like I tend
to explore more and more things about
the web new new things coming into the
web and one of the one of the fields of
Interest which you are seeing on the
screen is unleashing the power of
webassembly and webgl now these are the
two technologies where we'll be talking
about in this um today in today's agenda
where I'll be going through you what is
webassembly
what are the advantages of webassembly
how does the web assembly work
webgl benefits of benefits of webgl
whichever just happened I'm sorry
your power is there
us to your JavaScript application and
this is a field of interest for me too
so I hope all of you are interested as
well please welcome on stage shivai
thank you
let me know when to start
uh
the time
so of course uh first of all welcome
everyone to my talk I'm super excited to
be presenting at my first ever gsconf
and interestingly it's also my first
ever James concert I'm attending as a
attendee so super excited to be
presenting and uh before we start uh I'd
like to ask everyone to just take a
minute and scan this QR code uh it's
from slido and before I start my talk I
just want to kind of get a glimpse of
what the audience knows or what are they
aware of the term webml which of course
I'll be introducing in today's session
so would love to just see uh what
everyone thinks about uh this particular
term and what do you info from this term
of course I'll be giving a lot more
clarity of what I'm going to be talking
about but this one to start off so we
see machine learning in the browser uh
then we have webml machine learning
things flow in the browser okay perfect
uh integrating web ml with a web app so
looks good and I think like so seeing so
many different amazing answers we can
actually get started with today's talk
officially so hi I'm shivai I'm a
install jsegg and working group lead
from India and also part of the tensor
User Group uh India and my talk is about
bringing machine learning capabilities
for your web applications uh with the
help of different open source tools that
you can leverage in your JavaScript
applications now we are in a very
interesting era right now of course uh
we see the terms of open AI daily it's
at GPT everywhere right and I am of
course uh confident that at least you
might have interacted with machine
learning in some of the other form
whether it is trying to find answers on
charge GPT or it is to probably try to
make your code better with the help of
rgbt or drawing some AI amazing amazing
a based images that you can generate
with the help of different tools like
dally and that brings us a fundamental
question that as a JavaScript developer
can we leverage these tools and can we
actually learn machine learning because
typically machine learning is generally
considered to be a thing that you'll
require PhD you might have to use
different other languages like python or
R so what is in store for a JavaScript
developer to be able to interact with
machine learning so that you don't have
to leverage another tool or another
language stack and of course I mean we
know that JavaScript itself is so
complex right that we won't we don't
want to learn some other language or
some other tools set so um as a software
developer you don't want to learn
another language right so let's see how
we can actually implement or tackle
machine learning problems with the help
of JavaScript
and what you can actually do is that of
course another thing that you might have
also heard is that machine learning
models they require a lot of compute
power you require like thousands of gpus
to be able to power a simple machine
learning model but what if I told you
that you can actually do that now on
your browser itself without having to
need any dedicated server and have save
up all of the costs related to the
servers and also have a lot less latency
because you can actually do everything
from the powers of your browser itself
so that's what my talk is going to be
all about how all of you can get started
with machine learning in the web and how
everyone can without having any
knowledge of machine learning whatsoever
can very quickly and uh bootstrap
applications with the help of machine
learning
and we also know that JavaScript is by
far the most popular programming
language right how many people agree
because of course we are at a JavaScript
conference uh it's usually a tussle
between Python and JavaScript but I am
from the JavaScript team so yeah it's
the most popular language and also the
fact that JavaScript is truly
inspirational because it can run not
just on the browser it can also run on
edge devices on server with node.js and
even for desktop applications using
tools like electron JS that can leverage
the use of JavaScript on the desktop
and that of course makes it this like
you know without a doubt that if we are
able to leverage machine learning in
JavaScript you're truly unlocking the
capabilities of being able to leverage
machine learning capabilities for
different uh for different Tech stacks
and for different types of devices as
well so whether it's being able to run
machine learning inference on the
browser itself or outside the browser as
well
and that kind of brings today uh
introducing a lot of different open
source tooling that exists today that
allows you to be able to run machine
learning models not just in the browser
but also on things like node.js so we
have different open source toolings open
source libraries including media by
Transformers JS tensorflow.js Onyx that
you can leverage in your web
applications and build end-to-end
machine learning capable applications uh
that you can serve to thousands of
people
and if we specifically look at one of
the most popular machine learning
libraries that stands for JS uh it has
seen an incredible and unfounded growth
especially in the past uh five years and
especially in the last one year it has
seen more than 20 million downloads on
npm and a lot of companies both in
startups and a lot of large mncs are
actually today using these libraries to
be able to bring machine learning
capability in the browser
so I'll of course take this time now to
officially introduce the library
tensorflows yes so tensor.js is an open
source machine learning library that is
developed by Google at as a way to be
able to leverage machine learning
capabilities inside of JavaScript so
earlier of course a lot of us used to
probably write Django based models and
then serve them up with JavaScript
instead of a web application but we saw
that capability of being able to
actually run end-to-end machine learning
models directly with the help of
JavaScript so that basically gave rise
to tensorflow.js it's essentially a
embedding of how tensorflow which is
basically a very popular machine
learning library written in C plus so
this is an implementation for that in
JavaScript and it does provide you
capability of being able to run it
directly on the client side on the
browser and we'll see that how we can
actually do that throughout the course
of today's session
and again the biggest point is we might
have actually heard this term right once
use anywhere uh this is used for a lot
of different languages especially like
with Java and how jvm kind of brought
into the picture but it's essentially
the similar for a tensible JS as well
that you write one piece of machine
learning logic with the help of
tensorflow.js and you can truly serve it
on web on browser on your electron based
desktop app or even on Raspberry Pi for
that matter
and there are primarily three different
ways in which you can actually interact
with this Library so starting off with
running existing models so this is I I
would say the best or the easiest way
for you to get started with machine
learning for JavaScript where you don't
have to even know about what that
particular machine learning model does
or have to build that particular machine
learning model from scratch all of the
logic has already been pre-configured
for you with these pre-built models it's
simply just making simple JavaScript
calls to be able to load this model and
use some ready to use functions such as
dot predict that will essentially uh
take any data that you might have and
make the machine learning model do the
predictions on top of it and then have
something like dot showcase that will of
course demonstrate the results for you
and we'll be seeing that how you can
just leverage simple easy to use
functions with these pre-built models
apart from that you can also use some uh
more advanced training mechanisms such
as transfer learning which essentially
takes a pre-built model an existing
model and you can retrain it over your
own data so whether you have text based
data you might have image based data
video based data so you can retrain the
model and leverage it and of course if
you are a machine learning and you want
to leverage machine learning and write
machine learning models from scratch you
can actually do that with the help of
JavaScript itself only to use python or
R for that matter
and of course talking more about the
pre-train models because this will I
assume will be of most use for all of
you so there are a number of different
use cases that I can actually leverage
so including Vision based models uh that
allow you for doing computation tasks
then you have text-based models that
allow you to determine like let's say
text toxicity if you're using some kind
of a vulgar language you can
automatically detect that and all of
these are again just to remind are being
run exclusively on the browser itself on
the client side
so here are some examples so this one is
one of the most popular machine learning
models uh which is the Coco SSD that is
primarily used for object detection so
here you can see that how we can
leverage the use of objective object
detection to be able to detect different
types of objects for example in this
case we are doing it for dogs then this
is another very popular machine learning
model which is the face mesh and it's
actually being used right now live by
L'Oreal to be able to do things like
makeup on your face so it uses a bunch
of different facial detection points
that are being tracked on top of your
face and again this is being run on the
browser itself
similarly there's uh I mean of course we
know that with the current landscape of
JavaScript being such a popular language
there are so many different NP modules
that actually you can actually use so
here's one example where uh one of these
developer relation engineers at Google
uh for the webml project uh were able to
basically do teleportation by a
combination of webrtc there's a talk for
about webrtc by Christie today and they
used A-frame which is essentially for
augmented reality in JavaScript and
using tensorflow.js they were able to
build this really cool teleportation
demonstration
and here's like one sample code that
should give you a very quick idea of how
quickly we can get started so at the top
in the first two lines uh we just import
the necessary npm libraries uh for
JavaScript so this one includes uh tfjs
which is the tensorflow.js score and
also the automl that will be used for
like detecting uh items within a
particular image and then we simply just
introduce a new image with an image tag
and inside of a script function we first
wait for our model to load on the
browser and then we just pass that
particular image through our load image
classification uh function to basically
use the model.classify function and that
will take the image classify it based on
what is what is detecting in the image
and it will give the results to you so
no need for understanding what's the
mathematics behind that particular model
and simply in the being able to use like
just three to four lines of machine
learning of tensorflow.s code you're
able to create very easy to use machine
learning models and applications with
the help of tensorflow.js
and of course if you are probably uh not
very nervous JavaScript developer
there's also the capabilities of using
low code tools uh something like visual
blocks which is an ml power tool
especially for uh like you know newcom
new new developers to understand that
how you can actually build entire
end-to-end machine learning pipelines so
here's one example where I wanted to
build like a sample uh AR filter and a
custom video uh background where you can
see over here I basically took a
background image of jsconf India and I
had a very small air filter if you can
actually see it on top of my face and
this again is being leveraged with the
help of webml with a lot of different
machine learning libraries that are
provided by tensorflow this which will
not go too deep into that right now but
the idea is that you can try out this
visual blocks for ML yourself as well
and just play around and see how you can
build end-to-end machine learning
pipelines so in this case we are
leveraging a couple of different machine
learning models one is segmentation that
allows you to uniquely identify human
bodies in an entire web frame like in
the canvas so that you can actually put
on that particular background and I'll
be actually demonstrating that in a code
uh demonstration uh later in in today's
session and then we are using like for
AR filters we are again using face API
that will uniquely dip your face and you
can very easily then add a canvas on top
of it to have like a very cool air
filter
and uh just to also like you know share
some real world use cases right because
that's of course one of the most
important things to keep in mind that if
you are working in your companies and
you have a very interesting use case for
machine learning uh I just want to
demonstrate with the help of a couple of
slides where that today webml and
especially like open source tooling such
as tensorflow.js and media pipe are also
being used by companies right so hairs
include Health which is a very famous AI
based uh Health startup that uses
tensorflow.js to be able to track and uh
to be able to like track your rep counts
and the exercises that you're doing and
similarly uh there is Adobe which of
course a lot of you might be knowing uh
they recently introduced Adobe Photoshop
for web and they are able to use webml
for being able to do things so that's
object detection within the entire Adobe
Photoshop application itself and
Linkedin itself also uses uh webml but
that's not really for the client side
they use for node.js and to be able to
optimize the images that they serve as
you know that you know LinkedIn is being
used by millions of people so they want
to optimize their server cost by
displaying the images that they uh
showcase on their platform so they use
machine learning on the Node on the
server side with the help of node.js to
a calibrate and improve their
performance
so these are just some of the very small
examples where both large mncs and
startups are actually using webml uh for
their use cases as well in production so
it's completely production ready it's
very simple to use and get started with
so that's just the main motive uh to
Showcase some of these examples
and uh this kind of brings us uh the
most probably the most uh technical
aspect of today's talk and that's
essentially what is powering all of this
webml right we have been talking about
webml uh in all this while but let's uh
probably break this down into the for
the next couple of minutes let's break
this down into understanding that what
is the secret sauce behind being able to
get that much amount of performance uh
because of course we typically assume
that machine learning models are very
heavy right they are very compute
intensive and that's true right
JavaScript itself as a language is not
very well suited for being able to run
very compute intensive tasks so the
first question comes that how then we
are able to leverage and use these
machine learning models on the browser
and still get very performant
applications so the reasoning and the
way that we are able to achieve that is
uh and I'll be exploring this particular
diagram right so of course you can
directly run your machine learning
models natively in JavaScript but the
performance that you'll get is not that
great so because the browser apis are
able to actually leverage both your
system Hardware resources so whether
you're running a CPU or your GPU so with
the help of browser-based apis and
different back-end tooling such as webgl
webassembly and web GPU you're able to
actually leverage those particular tools
to be able to accelerate your machine
learning in browser uh both the training
and both the inference so coupled with
the JavaScript functions and the
applications that you write and the
Machine learning models that you use you
can leverage these back-end Technologies
and when I say back-end that doesn't
mean that it's on the server these are
just essentially these are toolings that
you can run inside of your Chrome
browser or any other browser for that
matter and be able to actually
accelerate your applications they're
also typically used for a lot of 3D
rendering uh I think like we already had
to talk about 3GS that actually
leverages the use of webgl for that
matter so by using these Technologies
they actually help you to accelerate
your entire machine learning inference
and the compute time that it actually
takes to do that inference or the
training directly in the browser is a
lot faster right so you can leverage
these tools now apart from uh the second
layer that you see you have all these
particular functions such as like
tensor.js you have media pipe and uh if
you are coming from a python background
there's also support for being able to
directly transfer or change uh the
machine learning models that you might
be typically writing in let's say core
tensorflow or using tensorflow Hub or
tensorflow Lite to be directly converted
into tensorflow.js and then serve them
on the browser so in browser
implementation is very simple and there
are tons of different ways in which you
can actually leverage so of course we
spoke about the in uh browser
implementation with like you know the
ready to use models and also of course
being able to convert some existing
models that you might have in in python
or in TF Lite and then convert them into
a model.json file that you can then just
serve with your JavaScript application
to be able to leverage them inside your
uh JavaScript based web application
and of course uh this is just a bit more
information about how you can leverage
these particular different types of
backends that are capable for being able
to serve these applications on uh the
browser so of course you're supposed to
have an uh talk about webassembly uh
webassembly is essentially a universal
bytecode that uh it's a universal Target
compulsion Target that performs very
near to Native speed and you can
leverage that as well to be able to run
these models so just think of this way
that your code JavaScript function will
just take care of running the web
application whereas the compute
intensive tasks such as the inference is
being taken care of by these backends so
you can very easily just use any of
these backends and switch between the
one that you want to use and it's very
simple to use uh you just have to do npm
install
tensor.js with the particular backend so
it's like tfjs webgl efgs web GPU tfgs
awesome and just compare which
particular type of backend performs the
best for the particular machine learning
model that you want to use and you will
be able to compare between them there's
also some tools in which you can
actually compare the performance between
the different toolings so that's about
the hardware acceleration that you can
use uh to be able to make the con the
compute a lot more faster as compared to
standard computer
and of course uh some of the biggest
benefits right that you get by
leveraging Machine learning on the
browser is that a you don't need a
dedicated server because historically
the way that you would used to actually
run these machine learning models is
that you would need a decade server now
your front-end API will make an API call
where it will either send some data to
that dedicated server and then your
server will take that input data it will
take some time to do the inference and
then send back the response so you're
dealing with a lot of dedicated server
costs you're dealing with latency right
because of having a server so just
imagine that if we are able to remove
that particular server itself you're
having privacy because now you're no
longer sending any data to a dedicate
server so all of your data that is
you're dealing with is residing inside
your own browser so it's a lot more
secure then you're also saving up costs
for the server right you don't have to
have a dedicated server so you're saving
up what's over there and you're also
dealing with saving a lot of latency
because the browser is responsible for
being able to do the inference and you
are getting the results right there at
the same time so that's the impact that
we get by having a serverless approach
and not having a dedicated server and
trust me that a lot of the popular
machine learning models today have been
optimized so that you can run them
directly in the browser itself
and of course not to forget about
node.js as well because a lot of the
people over here at gsconf will be back
in developers so you can also actually
leverage the use of these models
directly in node so there is a dedicated
tfjs node uh NP model that you can use
and if you want to get started again uh
you can use with either GPU with CPU or
with wasm all these are dedicated
website these are dedicated JavaScript
uh NBA models that you can leverage and
of course uh there's a lot of
performance benefits that you actually
get with using something like node.js
because uh a lot of us might be aware
that nodes basically uses just in time
compilation right and by using and
leveraging the standard compilation uh
the performance that you get by running
these models with node.js is a lot of
times faster as compared to even with
something like python so here's one
example where digital bird is one of the
most popular NLP which is natural
language processing it's one of the most
popular machine learning models for NLP
and you can see that it actually
performs twice as faster as compared to
the standard python implementation for
which it is originally designed as
compared to when you're using it with
nodes yes so this this should give you
an idea that how performant JavaScript
is and how well optimized some of the
features for JavaScript are that
leverage allow you to actually leverage
these machine learning capability for
your web applications whether you are
using it on the client side or on the on
or on the back end and here are some
like the benefits that you get so of
course if you have a very large model
right so sometimes your model sizes
typically if you talk about like machine
learning model sizes they are uh usually
between like let's say starting off with
1 to 10 megabytes in size or they could
even be like like you know 10 15
gigabytes in size so let's say if you
are dealing with a very large model and
especially given the fact that today you
might have heard of the term large
language models like llms that are
essentially powering these tools such as
open AI chat CPT so if you have those
kind of large language models you could
serve them with the help of node.js and
have the dedicated server support as
well that of course you will get in case
you are having a use case dealing with
larger machine learning models so you
get access to of course JavaScript
that's just in time comparison with
node.js so you get very performant
applications uh running on the server
side as well with the help of node.js
or of course you can also leverage the
use of external apis so of course open
AI provides a lot of different uh apis
like the whisper API text completion API
that you can leverage in your web
applications because there are
JavaScript sdks so you can leverage
those of course these are not really
open source but uh just some of the
other toolings that you can explore
because we are talking about webml so we
are essentially looking at a lot of the
different existing tooling that exist
today for getting started with machine
learning on the browser and you can also
use tools like replicate that allow you
to do things such as uh like you know
stable diffusion uh daily like image
generation so here's one example of this
room CBD how many of you have actually
heard of the room zbt probably it
actually grew in a lot of attention it
was also covered in like uh like you
know different magazines and news
publication sites like a Business
Insider and it has like more than
hundreds and thousands of downloads at
this point in time and it uses open AI
one of the open AI models that takes one
image and it will help generate like uh
like you know a very artistic room for
you so it again leverages the open AI
tooling open AI models that you can
actually use and again these often are
just like you know often these are just
uh side projects that get a lot of
different traction so when you're
leveraging these tools uh you can very
easily create web applications that are
powered by Machine learning in a matter
of a few seconds and not seconds but in
a matter of a few hours and get them up
and running and in production news for
thousands of people to actually leverage
and use
and of course if you're interested to
from this particular talk to get started
uh here's a really amazing course uh for
the tensorflow.js which of course is
kind of the biggest open source machine
learning library for webml so you can uh
take a look at this particular Tool uh
this particular course uh it's also live
on YouTube and you can just enroll for
it by going to this particular link so
if you're interested feel free to
actually do that and now of course
before I kind of conclude my talk I just
want to showcase a quick demonstration
so I'll just uh increase my size so here
I have a very simple index.html file
where I'll be creating a virtual
background with the help of a media pipe
so I spoke about like different types of
Open Source libraries right so one of
the ones that I'll be showing is an
example of uh selfie segmentation so I
spoke about the segmentation so what
segmentation allows you to do is that
you take let's say a canvas and you have
a web frame right so your using let's
say your webcam and you get your frame
so it will be able to uniquely detect
the uh humans so the entire human body
and as let's say you interact with it it
will be able to keep a track of where
that particular human body is going
inside of that entire frame so the
segmentation allows you to uniquely
identify human bodies and like in fact
multiple human bodies in just one single
frame and then you can just do whatever
you want in this case uh a lot of us
might have used virtual backgrounds with
uh Google Chrome Google meet for that
instance and Google meet actually uses
tensorflow this and media pipe to be
able to power up that virtual background
and that's what I just wanted to quickly
demonstrate so uh what I'll be doing is
that over here I have included two
different scripts so one is Media pipe
so that's an npm uh package for media
pipe and the one that I'll be
specifically using is the cell physic
meditation model now in a matter of just
40 to 50 lines of code if I look at my
index.js so so first what I've done is
I've just taken a video element that I'm
fetching from my webcam and I have my
canvas element where I'll be displaying
the virtual background so essentially
whatever webcam footage is being is
being showcased you're just putting it
on top of your HTML canvas and running
the inference on top of it so here on
this particular function if you see
which is uh the const camera so first we
are just taking the webcam footage and
this is a primarily the
the machine learning code that we are
writing this is just the so in like less
than four lines of code that's the only
machine learning part apart from that
it's all the standard JavaScript where
I'm taking the webcam footage adding it
on top of the canvas element so over
here we are using the selfie
segmentation model where uh we are of
course using the npm model for that and
we just simply take our camera footage
and using the on results function we are
basically finding that particular human
body instead of the foot inside of that
particular canvas element and then using
the virtual background so if you take a
look at this on uh results function so
first we will draw that image based on
the results that we get from the selfie
segmentation model and then we will
simply just go ahead and also we can of
course download that particular image
once we have created it so let me go
ahead and make this live and showcase
that how it kind of looks like so in
this case
as you're able to see that I'm able to
get like a virtual background which is
like webml at jsconf India and I can
also of course download this particular
image so the only thing that is
happening over here is that we are using
the selfie segmentation model which is
able to detect me uniquely and the
background that you see is the virtual
background that we have put so this is
exactly how the web uh like you know
when you put a virtual background on
something like Google meet or for that
matter on Zoom that's how they are
actually able to leverage it I've also
deployed this application and what I
love for everyone to kind of do is just
go to this link called
jscon.versal.app and all of you can also
take your own uh images and share on
Twitter using the hashtag hashtag webml
and just tag me for as well if you want
and just uh of course you you can change
the code as well if you want if you want
to use some other imits but of course
I'll recommend everyone to this go to uh
jscon.versal.app and uh create your own
selfie at jsconf and share it with in in
the entire world so that's a quick
demonstration that I wanted to Showcase
and I'll go back to my slides of course
we're just running out of time so these
are some of the resources if you want to
get started with webml with
tensorflow.js there are some books there
are some courses as I showcased this
particular Zero to Hero tends for this
code uh Course and there are some code
samples if you want to get get inspired
uh in fact like since these libraries
are open source so there is a particular
GitHub repository for tensorflow slash
tfjs examples where you can see a lot of
these particular pre-trained models that
I showcased and just play around with
them try to see which one might be
fitting your use case and then start
implementing them right that's the major
use case and of course the entire webml
Community is a really fun one because
you can leverage these machine learning
models for doing a lot of like good
social work as well but also you can
leverage them for making a lot of
different fun side projects right you
can see some of them over here and if
you want to get more inspiration just go
on to Twitter and look at the hashtag
made with tfjs or hashtag
webml if you want to see some really
cool interesting ideas that you can
actually leverage to make these side
projects or make your next machine
learning powered startup idea because
these tools are there for you to
leverage and make uh very easy to use
machine learning models and machine
learning based JavaScript applications
whether it's on the browser or it's on
the Node in fact like there is another
talk by Jamal today who will be talking
about tensorflow.js specifically with a
use case for node.js so if you are
interested from this talk definitely do
attend that I'm not sure if with
particular track it is but you can take
a look at the schedule he'll be using
time series data to do some data
analysis uh which of course like you
know probably five six years back you
might have thought that it's only
possible with uh python but today you
can actually use JavaScript for that
matter but yeah with that uh I would
like to officially announce adsconf
India let the webml error start and I
hope that everyone today will be able to
leverage these two links and leverage
these open source uh libraries to build
really interesting machine learning
based use cases and integrate machine
learning in your workflows so whether
it's like you know engineering managers
over here you can see the power of these
tools or if it's an Engineers like you
know go ahead to tell your engineering
managers if your student tell your
teachers or build projects build
hackathon projects with machine learning
you don't have to be scared now as a
duster developer to use machine learning
so with that I'll conclude my talk thank
you so much and I'll be around if you
have any questions yep thank you so much
very well said
thanks for this amazing talk uh oh sorry
sorry
it's uh I'm sorry I think I have like
messed up my script a little so a tech
glitch for my side as well but yeah this
was a super amazing talk very well put
so yeah
I think but like that's that's the story
of us developers and like us JavaScript
developers right technical glitches bugs
it's our everyday story that we tackle
with yeah but yeah again a super music
talk again and uh with that uh I would
like to uh start with our previous or
next I think yeah and anything previous
or next are the upcoming upcoming
speaker on the stage uh so please
welcome with a huge round of applause
foreign
okay
okay so I guess we can start it
uh apologies for the last hiccup as the
Murphy law says anything will go wrong
can go wrong and will go wrong so yeah
so welcome back to the
um webassembly and webgl session
uh
in continuation for the last uh from my
previous I'll continue from that point
itself so today we'll be talking about
webassembly what is webassembly what are
the advantages of webassembly what is
webgl how these two technologies amalgam
with each other and you know what are
the particular use cases for it uh how
do we get started on it
so before we start like let's get into
the introduction about what is
webassembly
so now web assembly is nothing but a
binary instruction format which you can
run on your browser now what what is
binary instruction format so whatever
whatever we we code we like JavaScript
Java anything say it at the end of the
day it transpiles or it compiles into
the binary code now how can we do that
binary code with JavaScript now there
are few mechanisms there the the hair
comes the concept of webassembly now in
webassembly we can actually compile our
code into the binary language and we can
run it on the browser
now what is the point of having that
wave assembly we have then we have
JavaScript yeah that's that's a very
valid question
basically the web assembly is
just it's it is used within conjunction
of with JavaScript so it actually not
directly interacts with the Dom
or browser model but in order to
interact with the browser it needs
JavaScript to interact but in order to
use webassembly
we uh in uh when we need to have very
great and powerful applications compute
intensive applications in the last of we
were hearing a lot of a lot of ml things
when we have ml languages ml models
coming into the browser the new your
application need to be compute intensive
and in order to do the compute intensive
work you need a web assembly it stores
your code into the binary
now uh what are the advantages of web
assembly you know as I said it improves
your
performance of an application
you know it is language agnostic so you
can actually create web assembly in any
of the languages you can use JavaScript
so there is a binding which JavaScript
known as assembly script so if you are
very familiar with typescript you can go
ahead and use assembly script to convert
to you know to produce your web assembly
modules and use it in the browser you uh
there is a new programming language
called rust python there are many Java
so there are plugins available to create
your binary modules in the webassembly
modules and you can use it on the
browser portability like you know
webassembly is
runs on different platforms across
different web browsers it's just a it's
just a binary piece of code which can
run on any on you know if it can run on
any environment security
uh it's a Sandbox as like you know it's
it's a piece of binary code it's very
sandboxed environment so you don't have
to worry much about about the security
aspect of it uh you cannot uh nobody can
you know
put on a malicious code in your sandbox
environment so it's pretty much secure
environment
now how does this web assembly works
uh as I was suggesting earlier
webassembly is nothing but a binary
piece of format you know and uh you know
you can you can use you can convert your
webassembly modules into you know dot
wasn't file it is known as generally
awesome file and you can uh use
languages like rust or assembly script
or JavaScript languages and you can
easily fetch these modules to fetch like
you know you can actually get these
modules through Fetch and you know just
run your programs as it is
uh the browser compiles the web assembly
into the just in time compiler so it's
known as the just in time compiler so
it's just like you know it downloads it
into your browser compiles it and it's
called known as just in time compiler
and you know it runs
and I was me as I was mentioning earlier
webassembly doesn't interact with the
object model directly in order to uh
browse our Dom model so in order to
interact with such modules you need to
you know you need to have a JavaScript
uh you know interfaces so it's very good
amalgamation often web simply module uh
module binary language with the
JavaScript
uh to in order to interface with the Dom
browser module
uh coming to the next is what is webgl
now how these two technologies are
related probably
as I was saying like you know as I was
giving an introduction before about the
web uh web assembly now webgl now webgl
is nothing but a web Graphics library of
the JavaScript API so now you you are
seeing the new new visualizations are
coming up new three or three dot JS if
you have heard of 3.js there are a set
of new visualizations 3D Dynamics are
going on 3D games are coming on the
browser now this is all because of the
three webgl now rendering to the 3D
Graphics now these when when we render
these Graphics you need
a more immensible amount of calculations
or you know it's a compute intensive job
now in order to do this compute
intensive job we can you we can leverage
the web assembly over here so that's how
these Technologies amalgam with each
other
now what are the benefits of FGL you
know you can get a hardware acceleration
class cross platform compatibility
real-time rendering and you know uh you
know these are some of the benefits you
can get of the webgl
um
again
okay yeah I'm good
okay
so these are the some of the benefits of
the webgl as I was saying
and uh how these two technologies
interact I I just told you like like a
minute ago these Technologies you know
webgl needs a lot of compute intensive
work
and in order to do those compute
intensive work we need to include
webassembly modules
now you know uh web assembly and web
webgl integration it's pretty easy to
use both of them together uh I as I was
saying earlier if my laptop like in a
good condition then I would have showed
you the demo where I've just created a
small application on react where I've
integrated the web assembly module with
the webgl with a lot of compute
intensive tasks so we are just
amalgaming these three new technologies
coming together on the front end and
creating a beautiful rendering MC
patterns visualization patterns it's
it's just starting of the unlocking a
lot of potential of creating a dynamic
visualizations a dynamic rendering
so the these these are some of the
things which you know webassembly and
webgl can do with each other
uh web assembly modules can leverage
webgl to render and display compute
results like you know as I was
mentioning earlier
now you know about the use cases of
these um these these Technologies
this as I was saying like you know game
development webassembly and webgl are
together can be used for the game
development there are a lot of 3D
effects 2dfx can come into the browser
ml uh data visualization virtual reality
uh are some of the use cases there are
other use cases like you know ml image
more fish and image processing on the
browser itself and you know nowadays uh
it's been a saying browser is a new
server browser capabilities are now
going day by day is coming more now we
can leverage a lot of browser utilities
and that's what we are trying to achieve
by achieve by leveraging the browser
capabilities by introducing the web
assembly modules together with webgl and
that's that's some of the use cases
that's the that's just the beginning of
an error
ah how do we get started with these
Technologies as I was saying earlier
like you know it's it's pretty simple to
use with your react application just do
npx react create react app install
webassembly have a webassembly script in
your in your modules and fetch it it's
just pretty simple to use I would love
to show you in the next one minute but
unfortunately my laptop is broke so uh
but uh if you do have any questions I am
at the e-pam booth please feel free to
reach out to me my name is karthika
Sharma and as my favorite also say is
Mark Twain
getting ahead is just getting started so
just get started on the web assembly and
webgl thank you so much
[Applause]
thank you so much yeah and we are also
happy that you were finally able to
deliver the talk and it was really great
uh as he mentioned you can connect with
katikia further for at the epambooth and
get to know more
um
next uh we have Philip
um he's the co-founder and CTO at view
storefront and he will be talking about
turning a product for view developers
into framework framework agnostic
architecture a case study uh
from The View storefront
a round of applause
for Philly
hi uh before you can get started I have
a question for you
you can please put your laptop there and
somebody can help him connect in the
meantime
um
hey please say hi everyone
okay so you have been the co-founder and
CTO for how long
for Fears and actually I'm no longer a
CTO so I hired a CTO a few months ago
which is quite a luxury if you're a
Founder uh to you know find a successor
right now I'm focusing more on developer
experience which is absolutely something
I love and which is something you will
hear a lot about
during my talk so yeah okay okay so can
you tell us one thing or one funny
incident in your tenure as the CTO for
view storefront
maybe maybe you can think about it and
talk about it post your talk
if you will see my presentation you will
see that basically we are running in
Circus a lot of times and during this
talk I want to kind of demystify uh some
things like a lot of companies appeal as
extremely successful from the outside
but in the inside the reality is like no
one knows what they are doing and well
my talk is more or less about this
thank you thank you that made me feel
better all the best Philip
let's cheer for Philip everyone I have
speaker nothing here and slides
oh wait a minute
in here
yeah wait for it it's worth it
okay
then which one is the main one
where would I see this
okay yes I see this I see this it's
close
yes
yes okay now the only thing that I have
to do
wait for this
is window
uh
nope
yep
okay yes it works
yeah congrats for me right
uh
yeah so
today I'm gonna talk about building the
perfect toolkit for e-commerce
developers and basically it is a history
of how we created we storefront six
years ago I won't tell you what we saw
from this because the whole talk is
basically about that
so I'm Phil Krakowski I'm a co-founder a
chief developer experience officer at
view storefront if you never ever met
anyone with this title is because I
invented it
because I hope wow how cool is that
right I'm also a member of Technology
Council in mahalayas Mahala is an
organization that is basically focusing
on bringing
much better enterprise software to the
e-commerce space and I'm really proud to
represent that
and
I live in a beautiful city of Roswell in
Poland anyone recalls Roswell anyone
been there raise your hand
no one I highly recommend that really uh
it's also called a city of 100 degrees
and I'm really really excited about
being here it's my first time in India
first time on Indian event but I'm a
foodie so as you could imagine it's kind
of like a paradise for me
and I have a question for you please
raise your hand if you ever beat or
contributed to a library or a framework
yes yes nice nice there's a lot of you
actually
nice
so
if you plan to build tools for
developers you will hear about real
struggles that we have to overcome to
build this perfect toolkit and it took
us six years and we learned a lot and
hope that after hearing this talk you
won't repeat our mistakes and this
knowledge is universal so it doesn't
only apply to building libraries or
building talks but for those use cases I
think it is most transferable so I want
to share with you how we solve certain
problems that I think are quite
Universal for most of the developer
tools big small so sit comfortable here
about the problems we encountered while
building visual front and how we solve
them
so let's start with the Catalyst like
the problem zero because every product
ever built has to solve a problem right
at least in theory because of course we
are beating dozen projects just to test
some technologies right uh so it was no
difference in our case really so what
problem did we encounter and what led us
to the creation of this storefront
and that time I was working at devanta
it was a software house that was
focusing on building e-commerce shops
and it was mostly using Magento how many
of you heard about Magento here
a lot of people how many of you like it
really no one
yeah so magenta was one of the most
popular e-commerce Platforms in that
time and it was really well known
in the open source community
but unfortunately it was not catching up
well with the
authentic market and mobile first
approach so honestly not that much has
changed since the aw acquisition those
some things were improved
and the problem that we faced uh when we
were using magenta were mostly around
flexibility of the stack developer
experience and performance a lot of you
raise your hands so I'm pretty sure you
can relate to that so we're trying to
fix those things within magenta itself
but it was a dead end really and when we
realized that we started looking for
alternatives
and this is where we heard about the
term headless how many of you heard
about headless
good if you are front-end developers
you're probably doing headless without
even realizing this so while it sounds
weird is actually pretty
self-descriptive and you'll see why in a
moment and to understand headless first
let's understand uh the opposite of
headless which is the monolith
so when we build applications they
usually contain few layers and each of
them has a different responsibility
presentation layer is what the user
interacts with and it has to be fast
into ETF delightful then we have a
business logic layer and this one is
responsible for manipulating the data
and sending it to the presentation layer
and both data and business logic has to
be fast reliable under heavy load
and in short a monolith is an
application that has all of those three
layers back into a single framework on
single application there is no logical
separation it is deployed
as one app uh
and because of that each of the layers
has high influence on each other for
example if you're back in business logic
execute slowly then everything is slow
your front end is slow
while headless is all about separating
the front-end layer
from the back end
and if we treat the front end as a head
of our application then we can say that
we are just detaching the head and
changing this with a better one and
hence the name headless
I don't know who came up with this but I
think it's it's pretty genius
so the front end communicates with the
back end only through an API and
actually the API is the only element of
the backend service that impacts the
front end so we can also call headless
API first
so in August 2017 we pushed our first
commit to our open source repository and
this is where everything started like
this servant was open source from the
day one and I think that was the main
catalyst of our success
so by detaching the front end we're
already able to
completely separate build completely
separate application on the front end
using modern dramatic framework which
was VJs at that time and by doing that
we already fixed three of the problems
that we had but unfortunately we didn't
solve the most important one the
slowness of Magento why
the reason behind that was quite simple
uh even when we did starched magenta
completely the database was super slow
therefore the API responses were also oh
were also slow and the front end was
slow so especially complex and large
queries they were taking a lot of time
and again like if you ever work with
magenta and a lot of you raise your
hands I think you know what I'm talking
about
and I said that the first problem
with poor performance was the most
important one and I really mean that
because speed equals money and I'm sure
you can relate to that from your own
experience like imagine that you're
entering a shop and it is slow you're
getting frustrated you don't want to buy
there and even if you buy there next
time you're looking for some
Alternatives and the only thing that
you'll remember is basically the
frustration raise your hand if you ever
witnessed that
oh not that many people
uh
so actually Amazon conducted a study it
was long ago in 2006 but what they found
out is that every 100 milliseconds of
additional loading time of the
application is costing them one percent
in revenue and of course it's not that
much for a small shop but for Amazon it
is insanely a lot so only in the first
quarter of 2023 they earned 127 billion
dollars and major part of that Revenue
comes from the Amazon e-commerce so I'm
leaving math to you but you could
imagine that it's quite worth optimizing
it
and if you need a good source of
arguments this is the screenshot time
for your boss to take care of
performance check out web performance
optimization stats this is a wonderful
website and it will give you a great
Insight on how actually optimizing
performance helps other companies to
grow their revenue because this is a
quite common problem like we developers
we understand the importance of
performance right then we are coming to
the business saying hey you have to
invest this amount of money to actually
improve that and they are saying asking
why why would I do this so here are the
arguments
so the way how we overcame the slowness
of magenta apis was unfortunately quite
complex and we had to find a faster
database then we had to mirror the
magenta data there and keep both in sync
so we used elasticsearch for that as it
was a proven solution to work
effectively with quite large and
complicated data sets
so our initial headless architecture got
a little bit more complicated than on
the previous diagram so what happens
here exactly so
in the left hand side we have
microphones right so in the left hand
side we have Magento and
magenta was actually
pumping the data to elasticsearch for
data pump so how it worked basically it
was a chrome job that was syncing those
two
data sources between each other and then
we had something called resource and API
and this server and API was actually
immediately where that was calling the
elasticsearch but also for some Dynamic
calls like user sessions for example it
was calling magentor directly then the
front end the front-end that we built in
VJs it was also a progressive web
application and the beauty of that is
that the front end was completely
unaware of the complexity at the back
end it was only calling visa from the
API in this server and API was actually
taking care of resolving everything
uh
and if you ever work with vgs by the way
I should have asked this at the
beginning how many of you work with VJs
yes more than a half good I was a little
bit afraid I don't know so if you ever
work with VJs you will see that the
project structure was no different from
a regular videos application really like
we saw from that at that time was just a
headless front-end boilerplate so you
clone the repo and from there it's your
project to take care of zero
responsibility from our site and the
only meaningful addition there that we
made were elasticsearch configuration
file and even bus
if you don't know what even the bus is
it's quite simple pattern that allows
you to create a separate view instance
that will notify all of your components
about certain things happening in your
application so it can expose events it
can react to the events uh you just
import this in different files and
and for all those events and it's quite
useful but if you had too much of those
events your application quickly becomes
very hard to debug and this also
happened in our case so from the time
perspective honestly I wouldn't
recommend using even bus mostly because
it opens a lot of possibilities for
writing bad code and we don't want that
right
so as soon as this surfing became more
widely adopted and believe me got
adopted very fast user started asking us
about things that we could provide with
just you know
we couldn't provide for just this copy
pasteable boilerplate like upgrade
upgradability or extensibility of
default functionalities without actually
losing this upgradability
so
it was kind of clear to us that our user
needs something else not just a
boilerplate but more like a framework
a framework with a path to upgrade a
framework with a powerful extendability
system and a rich ecosystem of
extensions with different third party
providers but also just you know
extending the default functionality of
the storefront
and you will actually see this slide a
few times today because when you're
building a tool for developers
there are two key things you have to
focus on to make sure it's good really
only two things
first of all you need to ensure that
your users are able to benefit from new
features you add to it in the simplest
possible way so a good upgradability
in addition they should be able to
modify the default behavior of your
application without losing this ability
to upgrade
so finding a good solution to both
problems and keeping good balance
between extensibility and upgradability
are kind of keys to building a good
library or a framework this is what I
learned in the last six years and to
achieve that you have to split your
boilerplate into different parts
to achieve that balance you know your
app needs layers
and it's very important to make the
distinction between the parts that are a
core functionality of your application
the ones that your users will be able to
update and extend only in a very
controlled weight from the extension
point for example and this is the
framework itself so the orange part is
the framework itself but there's also a
boilerplate code that they are free to
modify and it's basically custom part of
the project so at the moment when they
bootstrap the project it is their code
it's not upgradable they can modify
literally everything in there they can
just throw everything to trash and the
application should still work because
the framework
is not there
so according to this distinction we
divided our application into three
layers the core was the framework itself
and it contained essential
functionalities required for the
application to work like e-commerce
business logic video setup but also
things like server set rendering at that
time it was quite hard to achieve that
with VJs believe me I mean the Baseline
setup was quite easy but then the amount
of corner cases it was just
beyond our imagination really so
extensions were functions with access to
some of the core functionalities like
view store that they could overwrite or
extend
and teams but the actual custom
applications so they consumable core and
extensions and they provided a UI layer
for the application and Kims were just a
custom code so it was not upgradable and
again as soon as you clone the repo it
was your code to maintain and you had
absolute freedom to change anything
there
so the high level structure of the
project changed changed and it looked
like this
so the SRC directory it was basically
the custom application in the car
directory shouldn't be updated as long
as you want to receive updates now
keeping the core in the repository
instead of shipping it as npm package
allowed our users to consciously decide
if they want to receive updates or maybe
treat the whole project as the
boilerplate and start from there was it
a good decision I will tell I think in
like 15 minutes
so
in general it turned out to be a good
decision because it allowed our
framework to be more flexible but it
also had some downsides
now if you look deeper at the internals
of each part you quickly notice that a
lot of things were spread across all of
the players for example components so
similar structure of the core similar
structure of the team similar structure
of the extensions they made learning
curves liquor and once you understood
one of them it was quite straightforward
to understand the rest and in general if
you can use the same patterns or
structures across your application uh do
it look for similarities try to solve
the same problems the same way this will
contribute to much better developer
experience
so yeah we splitted our application into
layers we had quite nice extensibility
system that allows users to alter core
functionality without losing this
extensibility so on paper it all looked
very good
but then the reality track came in
so if someone wanted to change the
behavior of a certain feature let's say
a card they needed to attend many
aspects of the application for example
changing the card vendor to something
else it will require you to look through
all the the whole project to see what
components you want to alter what's
first you want to alter what helpers you
want to alter
and you know JavaScript files related to
the certain features they were
everywhere so this is a lot of work and
it's also quite easy to overlook
something so we'll alter this car then
after half a year you will discover that
there's a lot of code related to the
previous card it was still running
running your performance it's not
contributing to good maintaining
maintainable code base
so we had to find a way to make it
easier we started to look for a solution
and you know again when people want to
alter some default Behavior they usually
don't think about altering a specific
view store component or out in some
small cases yes but this is not a good
accessibility mechanism it is too
granular so they want to change a
certain feature as a whole and do it
quite easily without searching the whole
application so each feature like again a
card product catalog CMS integration to
look at their own view stores route
components Pages or helpers
so the solution to that problem was
domain driven design anyone knows the
main driven design
it's absolutely wonderful concept and
once you dig into this I I can guarantee
that you will love it so what is the
domain driven design the main driven
design also called DDD is the concept
that prioritizes business Concepts over
types of classification of your code
base like for example grouping bar file
type so what does that mean exactly
so it means that you should structure
and group your code based on the main
business domain which is the problem and
it's subdomains so categorize parts of
the problem which we see here the
problem here is e-commerce domain and
you can have a lot of subdomains such as
product catalog customers orders
inventory
so this the image that we see on the
screen illustrates the standard view
folder structure so if you want to
replace some features we have two times
files you know all of those folders We
have to look for them in all of those
folders DDD Embraces writing code with
this actual business logic in mind which
means that we organize our code and
folder structures on the business
features such as customers instead of
technical terms like components store
services
and honestly this way of managing code
makes it much easier to maintain it and
honestly I think that should be the
default
so if everything related to a certain
feature is in one place it's quite easy
to understand how it works because
there's no risk of overlooking some
parts it's equally easy to just fully
remove the feature because it's called
it's not distributed across the whole
application right
so another benefit would be the fact
that we can very easily reason about the
business part of our application and its
features just by looking at the folder
structure this is a really good
developer experience
okay enough Theory let's see the actual
implementation
so in view servant one we split the
whole application into domain modules so
on the left side you can see some of
them
and to add a feature you are simply
importing this entry point and passing
to the register module function so it
was equally easy to remove them one line
to add one line to remove a feature
quite cool right
so from the inside each module was just
a single function that had access to
vitals parts of the application so the
function was taking care of registering
vixors adding new routes hooking into
events of other modules Etc and our hook
system was also extremely cool but I it
would take too long to explain so maybe
another time
so visual modules were one of the
concepts I'm extremely proud of with
them for internal features third-party
dependencies local extensions one happy
to rule them all
remember when I said like try to solve
the same problems in the same way try to
have the same passwords consistently
across the whole application that was
the Holy Grail of this how cool is that
and if you want to dig deeper into this
topic I wrote an article about this
concept on View School block few years
ago
and it's based on YouTube but it's quite
Universal still so while the first
version of your servant was full of
great ideas it was also something we
were learning on and we're learning as
we go when I started research I was a
junior developer so imagine how many
mistakes I made so it's impossible to do
everything right for the first time and
in addition at this stage this certain
became quite popular really our users
brought a lot of different use cases and
we also learned much more about how the
software is used and how it should work
like it was 2017 like remember
about headless Commerce no one knew how
to do this we also had no idea how to do
this but we're you know stupid or brave
enough to just put things on GitHub and
learn as we go
so after a few years of use of an
existence and new problems emerged some
of them were caused by our decisions
some of them were simply a result of
user feedback and new cases they brought
some of them were caused by external
factors first of all we've built this
Surfers from scratch this means that we
not only had to come up with the
mechanism that I mentioned but also
maintain the whole SSR logic logic like
I think the best comparison would be to
next like we've built our own next
really and in addition we needed to
maintain ecosystem of Integrations
extensions that were going far beyond
just e-commerce it was a Virgin
Territory really like we needed the
extension for stuff like SSR caching SSG
this sort of thing is very basic
uh also view 3 was already announced in
2019 I think
and we knew that composition API is the
future it was just much better way of
using code and we knew that to keep good
developer experience we would have to
adapt it another problem was the fact
that overall architecture was quite
complex you've seen this right we agree
it was complex right
I agree and at that time magenta also
learned from their mistakes and they
actually had their own elastic search so
we didn't need it anymore and we knew
that fixing all of those problems will
introduce so many Breaking changes so
many iterations that everyone would hate
us uh
so it will take so much time that's
probably it's better to do a full
rewrite so make people hate us once
instead of making them hate us for every
long period of time with many brake
engineers and this is how we started
building with storefront 2. and
I want to emphasize one thing full
rewrites are rarely a good idea and they
come with a cost of resetting your
ecosystem pissing off a lot of people
and you can you can usually do this once
really and even if you do this once you
still do a lot of harm to your ecosystem
so it's a trade-off and sometimes you
just have to do this trade-off and at
the same time we simply didn't have
enough people to maintain everything and
we also learned that we're recreating
classroom of Crash so next shopping
Brothers they were reaching out to us at
the very early days so we start from but
next was quite immature at that time so
we decided to do this in our own way
so we started to fully rewrite and we
started it with those goals in mind
first of all of course we didn't want to
maintain the whole framework with this
extensibility mechanism ecosystem we
just wanted to focus on e-commerce that
was our domain of expertise that was the
value that we are providing and you know
everything else was already out there
with next and it was quite well
established this is why we adopted next
for Vista front tool
also we wanted to simplify the
architecture make deployments simpler
and make hosting these orphans cheaper
so no elasticsearch no data pumps and
chrome jobs just a symbol not the
hosting that should be enough to use
restore from
and also the problem that we're solving
headless just not only a problem of
Magento and we wanted to make this
surface available for all e-commerce
platforms and of course it has to be
built with your free apis in mind and
migration in mind
someone is asking me to log into Wi-Fi I
don't want this
uh
okay
okay so on the high level the new
architecture look much simpler instead
of four applications and elastics are
database like before it contains just
two applications really so there's front
end itself and then the API middleware
everything below our third-party
services that we're hooking into so the
goal of API miniware was actually to
orchestrate though different third-party
apis so imagine you have a CMS API
payment API e-commerce API search API
and a lot of other apis
and you know instead of installing
dozens of different sdks in the front
end probably with different protocols we
can just call one API the middleware and
the middleware will take care of
resolving everything for us
so let's dig a little bit deeper into
this middleware each integration with
the third party API was implemented in
the form of API client API client will
just a set of functions really calling
different apis of a certain service like
e-commerce platform or CMS we'll
actually dig into the details soon
and from the user's perspective and I'm
quite proud of this the middleware was
just a single configuration file that's
it so when you wanted to add a new API
client you were just simply adding it to
the integration subject by providing the
path and the necessary configuration for
example for your Ecommerce or
whatever and you are also able to extend
each API client so we'll get back to
this in a moment
under the hood each API client was just
a set of functions and
the way how middleware worked was that
it was automatically transforming each
of the functions into an API route so if
you wanted to run a certain function
from a certain integration you are just
using the URL built from the name of the
integration and the name of the function
and if this sounds familiar to you and I
hope it does at least to some of you it
means that you have heard about adpc
protocol which works quite in a similar
way and which we actually took as an
inspiration and this concept got a
second life recently so anyone here
heard about trpc
nice
I love it really it's a really nice
concept from the developer experience
perspective
so I won't lie using the single
configuration file to control the
middleware it was really a good choice
because it was just one client-facing
file and the configuration structure was
rather high level not tied to
implementation detail which by the way
is quite important when designing apis
to have them you know abstract enough to
not be tied to implementation detail we
would be able to even rewrite all the
internals of the middleware without
introducing breaking sensors this is how
good it was so at the same time this
simple configuration was enough to give
our users all the necessary features so
in addition because the API client
itself was quite simple the
extensibility was also straightforward
so let's take a look it's extension
allowed to create new API client methods
or override existing ones by creating a
new method with the same name so one API
that allows for both overriding default
functionality and creating an apis cool
right
so in some cases extensions also wanted
to create custom API routes this is why
we also expose Express instance we also
provided some hooks that allowed
extension to modify for example the
configuration or parameters of certain
API calls or also the after call hook on
the other hand it was quite useful for
logging so it was
part every time we log we we run a
certain function and did I mention that
we also built a UI Library
I I probably didn't
so one thing our customers were
struggling with was quality of the UI
and for some reason it's still super
hard to make it right for most of the
developers and I mean I probably know
why I won't dig uh into this during the
stock it has a lot to do with boot camps
by the way so this is why we've built
storefront UI our component library and
I love to talk more about this but it
would take ages and I see I have only a
few minutes and I will exceed the time
anyway so for now just remember that it
exists and if you want to learn more
about this check the documentation it's
completely free it's open source you can
use it in your projects if you like it
you can contribute to this which I
really encourage you to do uh so we we
already understand how the API
middleware worked and now let's take a
deeper dive into the front-end part so
just like the previous version of user
found you had two types of layers first
one that cannot be modified and is
upgradable and this time we shipped
elements of this layers nmpm packages to
simplify this upgrade process so no
longer git pull
second one was a boilerplate and in that
case just like in the previous version
it was a team
so you probably notice lack of
extensibility mechanisms for the
framework itself well this came out of
the box with next
so the team itself again was just a
regular Nexus application it was
absolutely nothing special about it
except the middleware config.js file uh
that we already talked about so on the
right hand side you see a standard
magazines project structure
composables they were taking care of
fetching the data from the API malware
and biding it with the state and viewer
activity system
so if you are a view developer you
probably already know what composables
are if you're not a view developer think
about them as hooks but for View and
each composable was tied to a specific
domain so you can think about them as
evolution of modules and here you have a
real world example of composables usage
which composable was exposing different
objects and functions latest but to
specific domain again like hard previous
you don't see all of those functions but
you could imagine that use card for
example is also exposing a clear cards
add to cards removed from cards Etc
and when it comes to the view surface
module it was really simple and
contained basic configurations boring I
I will just skip that
and when so what we can say right now
about upgradability of the front-end
setup here do you think it was good or
bad
right if you think it was good
race if you think it was bad
you're too polite but actually after two
years it turned out to be quite
resistant to the breaking changes and I
think the reason behind that was the
fact that apis were declarative and not
tied to implementation details so
therefore we're able to make a lot of
changes internally uh in the packages
without impacting the public API layer
so I cannot stress enough again how
important it is to not tie your apis too
much to the implementation details if
you don't need to so when it comes to
extensibility of composables where the
situation was a little bit more
complicated so we learned that our users
wanted to use the composables in a
completely different ways I often they
were consuming graphql apis and wanted
to make one request per page instead of
separating four calls for product data
reviews recommendations Etc so this is
where this domain driven model kind of
failed because shipping composables from
the npm package was very limiting and
often led to more Network requests than
it was necessary so this is why we
ultimately decided okay let's ship those
composables as part of the boilerplate
and let users modify them in any way
they want
so the final architecture of user from
front end looks like this team and
composables exposed to the user why
components and configurations as npm
packets it's in that every problem was
solved finally we have the perfect
developer tool and it was great until it
wasn't
because remember when I was talking
about making visa from viewfree ready
so
V3 became stable in September 2020 and
from this date V2 was considered kind of
like all technology and next tool that
we're using was using YouTube
so next three that was seeing beta was
using viewfree
the only problem is that it became
stable two years later
so view storefront is an open source
project but it's also a business as you
could imagine it was very hard to sell a
product that was using an old version of
a framework in addition our clients they
wanted to migrate to viewfree oh but
they couldn't
so next release it was delayed so many
times that we saw unreliable we can only
say to our customers that we are waiting
that's all
and don't get me wrong I have a lot of
respect for the next resisting's work
next three turned out to be a wonderful
framework and I'm a huge fan of it
highly recommend it but software
projects are getting delayed and
actually it was our fault that we made
ourselves dependent on like so much that
we couldn't do anything so obviously we
didn't want to repeat that mistake in
the future and we're coming to an end
soon uh because we wanted to became more
independent this is why you made it we
made a decision to make this servant
independent from any front-end framework
and meta framework and become framework
agnostic so you could support not only
view but also react and angular
Frameworks and I know I know we need to
change the name of the company it's
another problem that we weren't
expecting
but becoming becoming framework agnostic
requires much less changes than you
might think so let's see how the new
architecture looks like
and yeah like this is definitely even my
my best diagram uh but until I learned
how to make a better ones let me explain
what happened here so at the bottom we
see the middle right diagram from the
previous architecture nothing changed
here it was already a pure JavaScript
server-side Project without any
connection to the front end which what
changed is the front-end layer so
instead of the next module we created a
universal JavaScript SDK in typescript
that was responsible for establishing
collection with the middleware and it
had a lot of features under the hood
that were aiming to optimize the network
requests and make them more reliable and
the concept was quite simple each API
client from the middleware means SDK
module so the front end that is
responsible for fetching the data and
you're trying that some if something
goes wrong
and from the code perspective this is
everything you have to add to your
front-end to establish a connection with
the middleware so after running this
code you can consume all middleware apis
just add modules when you add new API
clients and that's it quite cool right
so we wanted to keep the same Simplicity
as before with Max module but make it
framework agnostic and this is why it
was purely just a typescript library
the new Final perfect front-end player
after six years of iterations look like
this female composable or react hooks
they are part of the body plate and this
way our users achieve the best
customizability SDK which binds the
front end and the middleware is shipped
as npm package and same with store Front
UI so after so many years I'm quite
confident that this approach has the
best balance between flexibility and
upgradability
and this is my friends after exceeding
my time is how we build the perfect
toolkit for e-commerce development but
we'll see in a year from now if it is
really perfect so thank you so much for
listening to my talk I hope you learned
something valuable
thank you and I hope you know the stock
will help you to actually build better
libraries or a better software in
general I'll post my slides on Twitter
enjoy the rest of the event and enjoy
the break because the lunch is there
thank you
for the super amazing and inside
and I'm definitely gonna plan in the
future coming to Poland and I'll maybe
I'll get some food food you know
food ideas from you like where to
graduate but yeah definitely that's on
my plan list so yeah definitely thank
you
awesome I know you all are hungry we all
are hungry so let's go eat
um we have the fire uh for the
conference tickets that you have that
have the paid food option you can go to
the fire the lunch is already placed
there and few of your peers will be
already there and for those of you who
do not have the food coupon we still
have the food court and the food court
has a lot of options you have it you
have you have everything there so please
go on to the food court and you know
have some good lunch and come back with
the same energy as you were there and
also one more last thing before we all
leave so uh as you folks already know
there's a community Lounge section and
if you had watched the like the opening
ceremony of the conference and you are
interested about how uh jammed music and
JavaScript together in our opening so in
the community Lounge there is going to
be a talk where abine is going to be
talking about partying with algorithms
uh he's from algorithm India so feel
free to check the talk out in the coming
Lounge so yeah and like see you after
the lunch break thank you thank you
everyone I think I I got to know that uh
there are some Momos and like uh let's
go let's go
all right see you guys
[Music]
what if digital could help your
organization change the world for the
better better Technologies better
experiences better tomorrows we're
publicist Sapient a global digital
business transformation partner helping
organizations improve lives through
digital elevating experiences optimizing
data and Reinventing products all to
create a better tomorrow for who matters
most everyone
publishes Sapient
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
we just need to understand the data
see the proof
know what works call that being
particular we call it being precise
we don't want head scratching gaps
guesses assumptions or opinions We crave
insights and Answers born from data
we're Engineers who love how having all
of our Telemetry metrics events logs and
traces cuts through the crosstalk
separate signal from noise
fact from opinion
it's not data for Shell it's data that
shows because it saves us time settles
debate cancels meetings before they even
start and says hey look over here this
is the problem when Dev Ops security and
business teams come together around data
it washes away the doubt it reveals the
connections we all know are there the
threads that point to the path forward
and what will really work
this is data for engineers
[Music]
the visual editor is the heart of
storyblock
the intuitive user interface allows you
to manage your content simply by
browsing your website
by clicking on a component in your live
preview the configuration appears on the
right hand side
you can jump to multiple components and
drag and drop your content wherever you
prefer
to add and change the layout of your
content
rearranging text or optimizing and
adding new images is as easy as it can
be
creating great content is a team effort
storyblock makes it easy for all teams
to collaborate in real time within the
visual editor
once you're finished editing you can
either start a feedback loop with a
custom publishing workflow
or publish instantly users create
content and go to market faster with
storyblocks visual editor
try for free at storyblock.com
tired of missing missing on event photos
with pre-magic do
e those are good just scan the QR code
snap a selfie and let the AI work its
magic instantly access event photos
through a link sent via email and
WhatsApp but that's not all boost event
sponsors Roi and visibility with our in
gallery placements supercharge your
event experiences with pre-magic
real-time photo distribution pre-magic
your memories delivered in real time
what if digital could help your
organization change the world for the
better better Technologies better
experiences better tomorrows we're
publicist Sapient a global digital
business transformation partner helping
organizations improve lives through
digital elevating experiences optimizing
data and Reinventing products all to
create a better tomorrow for who matters
most everyone
poopless is sapient
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
we just need to understand the data
see the proof
know what works call that being
particular we call it being precise
we don't want head scratching gaps
guesses assumptions or opinions We crave
insights and Answers born from data
we're Engineers who love how having all
of our Telemetry metrics events logs and
traces cuts through the crosstalk
separate signal from noise
fact from opinion
it's not data for show it's data that
shows because it saves us time settles
debate cancels meetings before they even
start and says hey look over here this
is the problem when Dev Ops security and
business teams come together around data
it washes away the doubt it reveals the
connections we all know are there the
threads that point to the path forward
and what will really work
this is data for engineers
[Music]
visual editor is the heart of storyblock
the intuitive user interface allows you
to manage your content simply by
browsing your website
by clicking on a component in your live
preview the configuration appears on the
right hand side
you can jump to multiple components and
drag and drop your content wherever you
prefer
to add and change the layout of your
content
rearranging text or optimizing and
adding new images is as easy as it can
be
creating great content is a team effort
storyblock makes it easy for all teams
to collaborate in real time within the
visual editor
once you're finished editing you can
either start a feedback loop with a
custom publishing workflow
or publish instantly users create
content and go to market faster with
storyblocks visual editor
try for free at storyblock.com
with pre-magic those days are gone just
scan the QR code snap a selfie and let
the AI work its magic instantly access
event photos through a link sent via
email and WhatsApp but that's not all
boost event sponsors Roi and visibility
with our in gallery placements
supercharge your event experiences with
three Magics real-time photo
distribution pre-magic your memories
delivered in real time
what if digital could help your
organization change the world for the
better better Technologies better
experiences better tomorrows we're
publicist Sapient a global digital
business transformation partner helping
organizations improve lives through
digital elevating experiences optimizing
data and Reinventing products all to
create a better tomorrow for who matters
most everyone
publishes Sapient
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
see the proof
know what works call that being
particular we call it being precise
we don't want head scratching gaps
guesses assumptions or opinions We crave
insights and Answers born from data
we're Engineers who love how having all
of our Telemetry metrics events logs and
traces cuts through the crosstalk
separate signal from noise
fact from opinion
it's not data for show it's data that
shows because it saves us time settles
debate cancels meetings before they even
start and says hey look over here this
is the problem when Dev Ops security and
business teams come together around data
it washes away the doubt it reveals the
connections we all know are there the
threads that point to the path forward
and what will really work
[Music]
this is data for engineers
visual editor is the heart of storyblock
the intuitive user interface allows you
to manage your content simply by
browsing your website
by clicking on a component in your live
preview the configuration appears on the
right hand side
you can jump to multiple components and
drag and drop your content wherever you
prefer
to add and change the layout of your
content
rearranging text or optimizing and
adding new images is as easy as it can
be
creating great content is a team effort
storyblock makes it easy for all teams
to collaborate in real time within the
visual editor
once you're finished editing you can
either start a feedback loop with a
custom publishing workflow
or publish instantly users create
content and go to market faster with
storyblocks visual editor
try for free at storyblock.com
with pre-magic those days are gone just
scan the QR code snap a selfie and let
the AI work its magic instantly access
event photos through a link sent via
email and WhatsApp but that's not all
boost event sponsors Roi and visibility
with our in gallery placements
supercharge your event experiences with
three Magics real-time photo
distribution pre-magic your memories
delivered in real time
what if digital could help your
organization change the world for the
better better Technologies better
experiences better tomorrows we're
publicist Sapient a global digital
business transformation partner helping
organizations improve lives through
digital elevating experiences optimizing
data and Reinventing products all to
create a better tomorrow for who matters
most everyone
poopless is sapient
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
no no no
[Music]
no
[Applause]
no no no no no
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
we just need to understand the data
see the proof know what works call that
being particular we call it being
precise
we don't want head scratching gaps
guesses assumptions or opinions We crave
insights and Answers born from data
we're Engineers who love how having all
of our Telemetry metrics events logs and
traces cuts through the crosstalk
separate signal from noise
fact from opinion
it's not data for show it's data that
shows because it saves us time settles
debate cancels meetings before they even
start and says hey look over here this
is the problem when Dev Ops security and
business teams come together around data
it washes away the doubt it reveals the
connections we all know are there the
threads that point to the path forward
and what will really work
this is data for engineers
foreign
the visual editor is the heart of
storyblock
the intuitive user interface allows you
to manage your content simply by
browsing your website
by clicking on a component in your live
preview the configuration appears on the
right hand side
and jump to multiple components and drag
and drop your content wherever you
prefer
it's simple to add and change the layout
of your content
rearranging text or optimizing and
adding new images is as easy as it can
be
creating great content is a team effort
storyblock makes it easy for all teams
to collaborate in real time within the
visual editor
once you're finished editing you can
either start a feedback loop with a
custom publishing workflow
or publish instantly users create
content and go to market faster with
storyblocks visual editor
try for free at storyblock.com
tired of missing out on event photos
with pre-magic those days are gone just
scan the QR code snap a selfie and let
the AI work its magic instantly access
event photos through a link sent via
email and WhatsApp but that's not all
boost event sponsors Roi and visibility
with our in gallery placements
supercharge your event experiences with
free Magic's real-time photo
distribution pre-magic your memories
delivered in real time
what if digital could help your
organization change the world for the
better better Technologies better
experiences better tomorrows we're
publicist Sapient a global digital
business transformation partner helping
organizations improve lives through
digital elevating experiences optimizing
data and Reinventing products all to
create a better tomorrow for who matters
most everyone
Sapient
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
all right
[Music]
laughs
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
we just need to understand the data
see the proof
know what works
call that being particular
we call it being precise
we don't want head scratching gaps
guesses assumptions or opinions We crave
insights and Answers born from data
we're Engineers who love how having all
of our Telemetry metrics events logs and
traces cuts through the crosstalk
separate signal from noise
fact from opinion
it's not data for Shell it's data that
shows because it saves us time settles
debate cancels meetings before they even
start and says hey look over here this
is the problem when Dev Ops security and
business teams come together around data
it washes away the doubt it reveals the
connections we all know are there the
threats that point to the path forward
and what will really work
this is data for engineers
[Music]
the visual editor is the heart of
storyblock
the intuitive user interface allows you
to manage your content simply by
browsing your website
by clicking on a component in your live
preview the configuration appears on the
right hand side
you can jump to multiple components and
drag and drop your content wherever you
prefer
to add and change the layout of your
content
rearranging text or optimizing and
adding new images is as easy as it can
be
creating great content is a team effort
storyblock makes it easy for all teams
to collaborate in real time within the
visual editor
once you're finished editing you can
either start a feedback loop with a
custom publishing workflow
or publish instantly users create
content and go to market faster with
storyblocks visual editor
try for free at storyblock.com
tired of missing out on event photos
with pre-magic those days are good just
scan the QR code snap a selfie and let
the AI work its magic instantly access
event photos through a link sent via
email and WhatsApp but that's not all
boost event sponsors Roi and visibility
with our in gallery placements
supercharge your event experiences with
three Magics real-time photo
distribution pre-magic your memories
delivered in real time
what if digital could help your
organization change the world for the
better better Technologies better
experiences better tomorrows we're
publicist Sapient a global digital
business transformation partner helping
organizations improve lives through
digital elevating experiences optimizing
data and Reinventing products all to
create a better tomorrow for who matters
most everyone
publicist Sapient
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
we just need to understand the data
see the proof
know what works call that being
particular we call being precise
we don't want head scratching gaps
guesses assumptions or opinions We crave
insights and Answers born from data
we're Engineers who love how having all
of our Telemetry metrics events logs and
traces cuts through the crosstalk
separate signal from noise
fact from opinion
it's not data for show it's data that
shows because it saves us time settles
debate cancels meetings before they even
start and says hey look over here this
is the problem when Dev Ops security and
business teams come together around data
it washes away the doubt it reveals the
connections we all know are there the
threads that point to the path forward
and what will really work
this is data for engineers
[Music]
the visual editor is the heart of
storyblock
the intuitive user interface allows you
to manage your content simply by
browsing your website
by clicking on a component in your live
preview the configuration appears on the
right hand side
you can jump to multiple components and
drag and drop your content wherever you
prefer
to add and change the layout of your
content
rearranging text or optimizing and
adding new images is as easy as it can
be
creating great content is a team effort
storyblock makes it easy for all teams
to collaborate in real time within the
visual editor
once you're finished editing you can
either start a feedback loop with a
custom publishing workflow
or publish instantly users create
content and go to market faster with
storyblocks visual editor
try for free at storyblock.com
missing out on event photos with
pre-magic those days are gone just scan
the QR code snap a selfie and let the AI
work its magic instantly access event
photos through a link sent via email and
WhatsApp but that's not all boost event
sponsors Roi and visibility with our in
gallery placements supercharger event
experiences with three Magics real-time
photo distribution pre-magic your
memories delivered in real time
what if digital could help your
organization change the world for the
better better Technologies better
experiences better tomorrows we're
publicist Sapient a global digital
business transformation partner helping
organizations improve lives through
digital elevating experiences optimizing
data and Reinventing products all to
create a better tomorrow for who matters
most everyone
publicist Sapient
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you foreign
[Music]
we just need to understand the data
see the proof
know what works call that being
particular we call it being precise
we don't want head scratching gaps
guesses assumptions or opinions We crave
insights and Answers born from data
we're Engineers who love how having all
of our Telemetry metrics events logs and
traces cuts through the crosstalk
separate signal from noise
fact from opinion
it's not data for Shell it's data that
shows because it saves us time settles
debate cancels meetings before they even
start and says hey look over here this
is the problem when Dev Ops security and
business teams come together around data
it washes away the doubt it reveals the
connections we all know are there the
threats that point to the path forward
and what will really work
this is data for engineers
[Music]
the visual editor is the heart of
storyblock
the intuitive user interface allows you
to manage your content simply by
browsing your website
by clicking on a component in your live
preview the configuration appears on the
right hand side
you can jump to multiple components and
drag and drop your content wherever you
prefer
to add and change the layout of your
content
rearranging text or optimizing and
adding new images is as easy as it can
be
creating great content is a team effort
storyblock makes it easy for all teams
to collaborate in real time within the
visual editor
once you're finished editing you can
either start a feedback loop with a
custom publishing workflow
or publish instantly users create
content and go to market faster with
storyblocks visual editor
try for free at storyblock.com
tired of missing out on event photos
with pre-magic those days are gone just
scan the QR code snap a selfie and let
the AI work its magic instantly access
event photos through a link sent via
email and WhatsApp but that's not all
boost event sponsors Roi and visibility
with our in gallery placements
supercharger event experiences with free
Magic's real-time photo distribution
pre-magic your memories delivered in
real time
what if digital could help your
organization change the world for the
better better Technologies better
experiences better tomorrows we're
publicist Sapient a global digital
business transformation partner helping
organizations improve lives through
digital elevating experiences optimizing
data and Reinventing products all to
create a better tomorrow for who matters
most everyone
poopless is sapient
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
we just need to understand the data
see the proof know what works call that
being particular we call it being
precise
we don't want head scratching gaps
guesses assumptions or opinions We crave
insights and Answers born from data
we're Engineers who love how having all
of our Telemetry metrics events logs and
traces cuts through the crosstalk
separate signal from noise
factor from opinion
it's not data for show it's data that
shows because it saves us time settles
debate cancels meetings before they even
start and says hey look over here this
is the problem when Dev Ops security and
business teams come together around data
it washes away the doubt it reveals the
connections we all know are there the
threads that point to the path forward
and what will really work
[Music]
this is data for engineers
the visual editor is the heart of
storyblock
the intuitive user interface allows you
to manage your content simply by
browsing your website
by clicking on a component in your live
preview the configuration appears on the
right hand side
you can jump to multiple components and
drag and drop your content wherever you
prefer
simple to add and change the layout of
your content
rearranging text or optimizing and
adding new images is as easy as it can
be
creating great content is a team effort
storyblock makes it easy for all teams
to collaborate in real time within the
visual editor
once you're finished editing you can
either start a feedback loop with a
custom publishing workflow
or publish instantly users create
content and go to market faster with
storyblocks visual editor
try for free at storyblock.com
tired of missing out on event photos
with pre-magic those days are gone just
scan the QR code snap a selfie and let
the AI work its magic instantly access
event photos through a link sent via
email and WhatsApp but that's not all
boost event sponsors Roi and visibility
with our in gallery placements
supercharge your event experiences with
free Magic's real-time photo
distribution pre-magic your memories
delivered in real time
what if digital could help your
organization change the world for the
better better Technologies better
experiences better tomorrows we're
publicist Sapient a global digital
business transformation partner helping
organizations improve lives through
digital elevating experiences optimizing
data and Reinventing products all to
create a better tomorrow for who matters
most everyone
poopless is sapient
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
we just need to understand the data
see the proof
know what works call that being
particular we call it being precise
we don't want head scratching gaps
guesses assumptions or opinions We crave
insights and Answers born from data
we're Engineers who love how having all
of our Telemetry metrics events logs and
traces cuts through the crosstalk
separate signal from noise
back from opinion
it's not data for Shell it's data that
shows because it saves us time settles
debate cancels meetings before they even
start and says hey look over here this
is the problem when Dev Ops security and
business teams come together around data
it washes away the doubt it reveals the
connections we all know are there the
threads that point to the path forward
and what will really work
this is data for engineers
[Music]
the visual editor is the heart of
storyblock
the intuitive user interface allows you
to manage your content simply by
browsing your website
by clicking on a component in your live
preview the configuration appears on the
right hand side
you can jump to multiple components and
drag and drop your content wherever you
prefer
to add and change the layout of your
content
rearranging text or optimizing and
adding new images is as easy as it can
be
creating great content is a team effort
storyblock makes it easy for all teams
to collaborate in real time within the
visual editor
once you're finished editing you can
either start a feedback loop with a
custom publishing workflow
or publish instantly users create
content and go to market faster with
storyblocks visual editor
try for free at storyblock.com
child of missing out on event photos
with pre-magic those days are gone just
scan the QR code snap a selfie and let
the AI work its magic instantly access
event photos through a link sent via
email and WhatsApp but that's not all
boost event sponsors Roi and visibility
with our in gallery placements
supercharge your event experiences with
three Magics real-time photo
distribution pre-magic your memories
delivered in real time
what if digital could help your
organization change the world for the
better better Technologies better
experiences better tomorrows we're
publicist Sapient a global digital
business transformation partner helping
organizations improve lives through
digital elevating experiences optimizing
data and Reinventing products all to
create a better tomorrow for who matters
most everyone
publishes Sapient
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
see the proof
know what works call that being
particular we call it being precise
we don't want head scratching gaps
guesses assumptions or opinions We crave
insights and Answers born from data
we're Engineers who love how having all
of our Telemetry metrics events logs and
traces cuts through the crosstalk
separate signal from noise
back from opinion
it's not data for Shell it's data that
shows because it saves us time settles
debate cancels meetings before they even
start and says hey look over here this
is the problem when Dev Ops security and
business teams come together around data
it washes away the doubt it reveals the
connections we all know are there the
threads that point to the path forward
and what will really work
[Music]
this is data for engineers
the visual editor is the heart of
storyblock
the intuitive user interface allows you
to manage your content simply by
browsing your website
by clicking on a component in your live
preview the configuration appears on the
right hand side
you can jump to multiple components and
drag and drop your content wherever you
prefer
simple to add and change the layout of
your content
rearranging text or optimizing and
adding new images is as easy as it can
be
creating great content is a team effort
storyblock makes it easy for all teams
to collaborate in real time within the
visual editor
once you're finished editing you can
either start a feedback loop with a
custom publishing workflow
or publish instantly users create
content and go to market faster with
storyblocks visual editor
try for free at storyblock.com
tired of missing out on event photos
with pre-magic those days are gone just
scan the QR code snap a selfie and let
the AI work its magic instantly access
event photos through a link sent via
email and WhatsApp but that's not all
boost event sponsors Roi and visibility
with our in gallery placements
supercharge your event experiences with
three Magics real-time photo
distribution pre-magic your memories
delivered in real time
what if digital could help your
organization change the world for the
better better Technologies better
experiences better tomorrows we're
publicist Sapient a global digital
business transformation partner helping
organizations improve lives through
digital elevating experiences optimizing
data and Reinventing products all to
create a better tomorrow for who matters
most everyone
publishes Sapient
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
we just need to understand the data
see the proof
know what works call that being
particular we call it being precise
we don't want head scratching gaps
guesses assumptions or opinions We crave
insights and Answers born from data
we're Engineers who love how having all
of our Telemetry metrics events logs and
traces cuts through the crosstalk
separate signal from noise
fact from opinion
it's not data for Shell it's data that
shows because it saves us time settles
debate cancels meetings before they even
start and says hey look over here this
is the problem when Dev Ops security and
business teams come together around data
it washes away the doubt it reveals the
connections we all know are there the
threads that point to the path forward
and what will really work
this is data for engineers
[Music]
the visual editor is the heart of
storyblock
the intuitive user interface allows you
to manage your content simply by
browsing your website
by clicking on a component in your live
preview the configuration appears on the
right hand side
you can jump to multiple components and
drag and drop your content wherever you
prefer
to add and change the layout of your
content
rearranging text or optimizing and
adding new images is as easy as it can
be
creating great content is a team effort
storyblock makes it easy for all teams
to collaborate in real time within the
visual editor
once you're finished editing you can
either start a feedback loop with a
custom publishing workflow
or publish instantly users create
content and go to market faster with
storyblocks visual editor
try for free at storyblock.com
tired of missing out on event photos
with pre-magic those days are gone just
scan the QR code snap a selfie and let
the AI work its magic instantly access
event photos through a link sent via
email and WhatsApp but that's not all
boost event sponsors Roi and visibility
with our in gallery placements
supercharger event experiences with
three Magics real-time photo
distribution pre-magic your memories
delivered in real time
what if digital could help your
organization change the world for the
better better Technologies better
experiences better tomorrows we're
publicist Sapient a global digital
business transformation partner helping
organizations improve lives through
digital elevating experiences optimizing
data and Reinventing products all to
create a better tomorrow for who matters
most everyone
poopless is sapient
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
we just need to understand the data
see the proof
know what works
call that being particular we call it
being precise
we don't want head scratching gaps
guesses assumptions or opinions We crave
insights and Answers born from data
we're Engineers who love how having all
of our Telemetry metrics events logs and
traces cuts through the crosstalk
separate signal from noise
fact from opinion
it's not data for Shell it's data that
shows because it saves us time settles
debate cancels meetings before they even
start and says hey look over here this
is the problem when Dev Ops security and
business teams come together around data
it washes away the doubt it reveals the
connections we all know are there the
threats that point to the path forward
and what will really work
this is Theta for engineers
[Music]
the visual editor is the heart of
storyblock
the intuitive user interface allows you
to manage your content simply by
browsing your website
by clicking on a component in your live
preview the configuration appears on the
right hand side
you can jump to multiple components and
drag and drop your content wherever you
prefer
to add and change the layout of your
content
rearranging text or optimizing and
adding new images is as easy as it can
be
creating great content is a team effort
storyblock makes it easy for all teams
to collaborate in real time within the
visual editor
once you're finished editing you can
either start a feedback loop with a
custom publishing workflow
or publish instantly users create
content and go to market faster with
storyblocks visual editor
try for free at storyblock.com
tired of missing out on event photos
with pre-magic those days are gone just
scan the QR code snap a selfie and let
the AI work its magic instantly access
event photos through a link sent via
email and WhatsApp but that's not all
boost event sponsors Roi and visibility
with our in gallery placements
supercharge your event experiences with
three Magics real-time photo
distribution pre-magic your memories
delivered in real time
what if digital could help your
organization change the world for the
better better Technologies better
experiences better tomorrows we're
publicist Sapient a global digital
business transformation partner helping
organizations improve lives through
digital elevating experiences optimizing
data and Reinventing products all to
create a better tomorrow for who matters
most everyone
publishes Sapient
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
Chit Chat
because
[Music]
foreign
I'm guessing most other people people
are from
other cities
who's from Delhi
nice how many of them had ghee Puri idli
from Bangalore
oh so if you're if you're visiting
Bangalore and if this is your first time
you definitely have to have at least
or the Dosa and make sure you do not go
back outside Bangalore unless you have
keep really or dosa
and yeah most of my fillers normally are
talking about food because I'm a big big
fan of food
but with this we will get started with
our first talk after lunch and we have
with us our next speaker Vivek pal who
is going to talk about
a lot of things including about web
assembly so let's get started Vivek
please we'll be happy to have you on
stage
let's give him a round of applause this
is his first talk in public so let's
make sure he feels special and he feels
energized for his first talk let's let's
give him a round of applause
[Applause]
how how are you feeling Vivek for your
first talk
last night I am with with one hour sleep
so actually if I fall as I sleep here so
don't mind please
don't worry we have first aid and we're
all set
all set Vivek
till Vivek is setting up his uh laptop
does anybody have any special
anecdotes from their first public
speaking session or first talk that they
give something very funny weird awkward
if somebody fell down on the stage like
he was mentioning does anyone have
anything to share
I think most of them are oh we have
someone
yeah I'm coming to you with my mic
let me run
hi my name is faizan so I did a one of
the react items right and I prepared a
topic on how to let's say do some State
Management readers but for certain
particular Niche use cases so before I
went to talk the other speakers
obviously in the list right and this one
guy comes and the topic title is don't
use Redux all right
and it goes on like a half an hour rant
on why Redux is the worst thing in the
world and you should be using some other
technology other than readers and so
when I walk up to the stage I'm like so
this is why you should be using Redux
so yeah so that was a quite fun talk
thank you so much and yeah please go
ahead yeah
yeah so hey all I am Vivek I am building
sastra OS it's a decentralized desktop
operating system so it's based on Linux
so it's a dist Linux distro so I am I am
just using my own custom made Linux
disto here
so today I am going to talk about
webassembly system interface so it
so
so today we are going to talk about
webassembly web assembly system
interface which is a system interface
for webassembly to run by assembly
outside outside of browser
and we will also talk about integration
of Json webs web assembly so like you
can made your custom web assembly
JavaScript modules
to run your code on webassembly
we will also talk a little about
assembly script which is a typescript
for webassembly
so let's talk about webassembly so like
we have heard a lot about webassembly so
it's it's a binary instruction so it's a
binary format code that runs in your
browser so which means you can run on
near native
performance code on your browser
so
it's a binary instruction for stack
based virtual machine so what's what's
stack based virtual machine actually so
stack machine is based on last in first
house first out basis so like you you
have data element put in and you have
data element put out of the stack so
so this is how uh this is how web
assembly code executes so like we have
other programming languages we can
compile seek see code C plus plus code
rust code and
go code to and this python llvm code to
webassembly so
uh web assembly virtual machine runs
that code on our native machine that's
that is your x36 or arm
so what are virtual machines so virtual
machines are uh you can say a machine
that that is virtually running on your
real Hardware so
these machines are like you have given
sort of resources to these machines so
so there are two types of virtual
machines stack based Android service we
talked about stack based so webassembly
runs on this stack based virtual machine
so why web assembly
performance obviously uh webassembly
runs on near native performance due to
its
it's
kind it's a structure like your code is
compiled directly to a binary format
that runs in your browser
cross chain compatibility cross platform
compatibility so it you can run website
a single web assembly code in your any
sort of device whether it's x86 or
um
so language agnostic you can run any
language possible on your browser using
web assembly security
it's it is it runs in a sandbox
environment like if we all have heard of
Docker Docker runs in a sandbox
environment well suppose if you get a
code and you want to run in different
words different machines without
breaking your code without
you want to just give a compatibility
layer to
to that code for all machines so
you have sandbox environments so it's
also a Sandbox and webassemblies also
sandboxed environments so it provides
security so that uh the your code will
only take resources that are been been
executed to it so
so
basically your
your code is
so web assembly is INTERPOL so bird
industry support so like we have a web
assembly lots of there are lots of
communities there is also web assembly
web secret community so we have uh top
levels about like uh very famous
companies Google Apple are working on
webassembly
community and ecosystem like I have
talked about it has lot of lots of
communities and ecosystem is developing
rapidly fast
webassembly in browsers
so uh almost
majority of browser support webassembly
so your browsers like uh before assembly
your brothers had a V8 engine so that
get your code run and your JavaScript
code and into the browser but in four
web assembly we have Servo even V8 and
spider monkey are also working on
webassembly so that your code
webassembly code is compatible with that
that V8 and spider monkey engine
so like we have Firefox which support
webassembly chromium-based browsers and
Safari and Edge
web assembly modules these are the you
can say very important part of
webassembly so web assembly modules are
the modules that that takes your code to
the binary format so these are building
blocks of webassembly applications
so webassembly modules are compiled from
source code into binary format that can
be executed by webassembly virtual
machine that's in our case like if we
are running our code in browser in our
case it's Servo engine
so webassembly modules in Java
JavaScript so here
we can fetch our mode was a module in
JavaScript and run our JavaScript code
in webassembly so here like we are
adding two numbers five and three if if
we want to execute in binary format we
can create this Vasa module and run it
run our code in webassembly
so now let's talk about vasi vasi is a
secret source that can put your web
application to the next level like you
can now run web assembly to servers so
your servers become more faster more
more performant and secured than ever
ah watches stands for webassembly system
interface so
it's a standalized set of apis for that
allows was was a modules to interact
with the host operating system and its
serious resources in platform agnostic
agnostic manner this means that now your
those web assembly modules can interact
with your Hardware level functionalities
such as let's say files or your memory
and your internal architecture
so let's talk about portability so you
can here see the C code that is
that is converted to wasm byte code and
now that was um byte code can run on any
user that is
x36 or arm so on any platform like Linux
or Windows or Mac
so
first of all sandbox environment of
course like
there's a trade by one of a Docker
Docker co-founder
he he talked about like uh
if at that time if they
if
wasam and Wazi was well they didn't have
to create Docker so
they talked about these things and books
environment so while she runs uh
outside of even outside of your browser
in a sandbox environment so that you can
initiate all files and uh in a
particular manner that you want
so standardized API standard so vasi is
a standalized API means that
your
you have a set of API that can
run on any a sort of virtual machine
so minimalistic interface so version
code is very lightweight lightweight so
that provide well assembling system
interface very minimalistic interface
isolation and safety so due to this side
works and environment so we have a
highly secured interface
it's a platform agnostic like
webassembly
interoperability like a web assembly and
its feature proof also
building web applications with vasi
so you can build file system operations
like
ah if I saw you
this is ipvm if you have a heard of ipfs
it's a interplanetary file system so
basically your several nodes are running
globally so you can install your files
on those nodes in a distributed manner
so I ipvm is a virtual machine
implemented on ipfs so actually it is
giving computation power to ipfs
so it's a good kind of implementation of
web assembly system system interface for
file system operations
so actually we at sasta os are also
working on uh ipvms to provide
distributed package management system on
any Linux distro
networking so you can build networking
applications uh you can build system
integration
applications uh database access
secure cryptography there lots of like
blockchains developing on webassembly
system interface
command line tools we can build command
line tools with vasi so it gives those
command line tools uh
platform agnostic uh
manner
so let's talk about as
assembly script
assembly script is a typescript that is
built for webassembly
so now you can run your typescript code
to webassembly directly like without
creating webassembly modules
so type type script to webassembly
compiler so it's a type script to have
assembly compiler so
here is our variation it has a assembly
script code that calculates a factorial
of a given number so here is a factorial
function so it
it here it
it answers its result
using webassembly using assembly script
module in JavaScript so if we want to
run assembly script if we want to run
assembly script core in JavaScript we
can use these kind of modules that I
have talked you about it before
some use cool use cases of web assembly
so now I am going to show you some cool
projects that are being built on
webassembly so tensorflow.js
running on webassembly web back end so
tense of tensorflow are implementing web
assembly
so like
earlier machine learning codes were like
a little bit difficult
for to run on tensorflow Js
so Google Earth Google Earth is the
application like most of most of us have
used it's also rendering 3D
representations on webassembly
webassembly package manager so it's a
package package manager of webassembly
so if if you want to build applications
on webassembly you can
have lots of inbuilt packages for
webassembly
QT QT is uh like if you have used Linux
you have a heard of KDE KDE is a KD is a
desktop environment that's used in
various Linux distros so it's a web so
QT is a widget toolkit for uh
applications are built on QT so QT is
also implementing webassembly system
interface
so vasmer was more is our runtime
for wireless memory system interface
so
with so vasmar is also made with
webassembly
and ipvm that I have talked to you
before
another cool case that I found recently
is
swc compiler if you have used next.js13
they are using as swc compiler using it
like you are having a huge performance
Improvement in next next JS projects
because of this swc compiler it's
written in Rust
limitations and future of vasivasi is in
production like they are having very
good community and team
ah one of them is len Clark they are
having monthly and weekly meetings over
webassembly so it's in
it's in development and it has lots of
limitations uh internal limitations
conclusion like uh we
we all wanted to like run our code on
browser at a very
performant manner so
webassembly is key to that thing
resources if you want to find the
resources you can scan this QR code it
will get you to my
my slides repository so here you can
find resources I will update this I will
also keep updating this repository in
upcoming future time
also you can head over to me at Twitter
so this is my Twitter
you can just head over to me to my
Twitter and give a follow back and
ah my DMs are always open
so
thank you everyone so this was my talk
hello sir yeah thank you
thank you so much Vivek uh it was an
amazing talk and it was your first talk
we're honored to be the conference where
you gave your first talk I think we need
to have a huge round of applause for him
for Having the courage to be on his page
such wake up a stage for the first time
so before you leave we have one question
for you is that okay if we ask you a
question
so what is it that you know made you
interested into engineering what is it
that excites you the most about it you
can use a mic
so actually engineering is a sort of
experiments that you can do every day
so that's excited me about engineering
like I was in about third or fourth
class when I got my first laptop so I
started from there but uh I was
indulging studies and school manner I
prepared 4J now after getting over my
last 12th I started learning about these
things and now I am in second year
college
oh wow
I think that deserves a Roundup Applause
second year of his college wow you're
doing amazing thank you so much
that reminds me of a question when did
you get your first laptop what was your
first experience with the desktop or a
laptop
my first experience with a desktop was
was which belonged to my dad in the
office and uh we me and my brother both
of us used to wait until used to go out
on for his work so that we could play uh
pocket tank does anybody remember that
desktop game pocket time
yeah that is still I I don't know I I
don't play Xbox I I don't like games but
my heart is still stuck on pocket tank
and the way those uh you you throw those
machines over each other and you break
each other's mountains it's amazing that
was my first time with a desktop what
about you so I think I'd had a exposure
to laptop much later so the first
experience was definitely to a desktop a
big computer a big monitor with a big
CPU and all that system and my first
game is I think pinball who all have
played it almost all of us right and
then I think Mario was my second game
that I played it's a quite amazing
childhood memories we I think Mario we
used to play on that uh sad console at
least I I we had to hit that consoles
but it worked because it never worked
for me
definitely definitely so I think now
let's get to our next talk
um so we have our next speaker with us
uh you can join us on the stage so we
have a talk on a practical guide to
implementing CSP to secure client Side
by lava Kumar he's the founder of
domdog.io let's welcome him with a huge
round of applause
yeah all yours stage is yours
so we're gonna get started
okay
hi everyone can you hear me
yeah perfect okay hello I'm lava Kumar
and my talk is on a practical guide to
implementing CSP uh before I get started
I want to thank you all for attending my
talk because the other speaker in track
one she's been trying to poach people
from yesterday she even asked me to come
and attend their talk so
I'm glad you guys are here uh and in a
developer conference too it's good to
see so many people interested in
security uh before I get started I want
to know how many of you are already
familiar with CSP uh can we have like a
raise of hands
okay awesome
Okay cool so for the rest of you CSP
it's an It's A New Concept so
what I'll do is I'll talk about uh you
know the rise of client-side attacks
because before we talk about CSP CSP the
production mechanism we'll first try and
understand why client-side security is
important and then we'll talk about what
we can actually do uh you know in terms
of predicting it and then I'll talk
about some practical steps in terms of
implementing it because the ones who are
familiar with CSP or if you have tried
to implement CSP you know it's always
difficult it's kind of like you know uh
trying to get six packs it looks good in
theory you know everybody goes to the
gym you know very excited the first week
they're all dieting very well and
everything and afterwards you're like
you know what fine I'm okay with having
a bigger belly but you know I cannot go
through this so there are some
techniques and tips if you follow that
it actually becomes easy for you to
deploy CSP in a very practical way and
that's what I'm going to cover and along
with that what I'm also going to do is
I'm releasing a free scanner this
scanner is for analyzing your
client-side code and identifying
security related stuff right and you can
also use it for debugging and other
things as well so that's also something
I'll you know I'll show you where you
can download from how you can use right
so that's in a nutshell what the agenda
of the talk is
all right so when we think about
security most of the time you know you
normally think your server side which is
your firewall uh you never have a web
application uh facing the internet
without a vaf right so that's a bare
minimum and then you have other things
as well secure coding pen testing a lot
of things happen for the back end but
for front end when we talk about
security you know people are sometimes
confused it's like what we do security
on the front end as well right but if
you think about it uh all of the
sensitive stuff you have on your back
end everything is accessible from your
front end right if if your backend is
like a vault instead of the attacker
trying to break the Vault and get in
like the show in the movies you know
they just have to steal the key right
and your client side is the key so if
they manage to inject the few lines of
JavaScript code into your client side
they can access all your backend code
just you know riding on a user session
and there have been so this kind of
because there's lack of focus on
client-side security it creates a low
hanging fruit and attackers are you know
very lazy people believe it or not
hackers it's not like how they show in
the movies you know that's why they do
all the bad things because they can work
for one or two months make a lot of
money and they can you know relax for
the rest of the year so they typically
tend to go behind easy targets low
hanging fruit and because the
client-side aspect of your
infrastructure is more weaker we've been
seeing a lot of rise in attacks on
client-side so there is a specific
attack called as magecard so if you know
any of you have anything remotely to to
do with e-commerce or you know payment
processing and so on then this is very
relevant for you uh this is an attack
which has been going on for the last
three four years and there have been
hundreds of millions of credit card
deals which have been stolen all by
injecting a few lines of JavaScript code
right
so this kind of forces us now to look at
security of the client side because this
is being actively exploited and uh if
you're thinking about whether I should
you know try and put emphasis on
client-side security so this should
probably help you decide which is if
your company uh or your organization is
you know related to e-commerce if it's
doing any kind of you know flight
booking hotel booking any kind of
transaction online if it's dealing with
sensitive information like say
Healthcare data or fintech information
you know then you might want to think
about client trade security
and again you don't have to look at
client-side security throughout your app
because you might have a very big
application right and it might get
overwhelming to try and lock down
everything you can pick up the most
sensitive sections of your site which
could be your checkout Pages
registration Pages login pages and you
know any other Pages where you are
collecting sensitive information from
users right
all right so when we look at security on
the client side these are some things
which you can think of as your high
level goals of what you can achieve
which is your web page is loading a lot
of resources images iframe CSS
JavaScript from different different
places right so you need to have some
kind of a control of what you're loading
from where right so that is one thing
which is you know what kind of content
you're loading from third parties and
then the big one is your JavaScript what
JavaScript you're loading on firmware
right so you need to have some kind of
control over that
and then you need to have control over
the JavaScript Behavior itself so I'll
give you uh an example where uh in a
major attack what the attackers did was
they went and scanned the internet I
think I'm sure all of you are familiar
with S3 buckets right and you know that
there are S3 buckets if they are not
configured properly then anybody can
write to an SD bucket right so what they
did was they went and scanned the
internet to find writeable publicly
writable S3 buckets and once they found
those S3 buckets they scanned those
buckets to look for JS files and once
they found those files they injected
their malicious web skimming code into
those files right they didn't know if
those files will be loaded by a website
or not and if that website would be a
payment you know page processing website
they didn't know all of that they just
went and you know like it's kind of like
putting a landmine they just you know
threw it everywhere and surprising a lot
of you know scripts were being loaded
from SDA buckets into checkout pages and
that attack was very successful right so
even if the file is the same right it's
your own file it's being loaded from the
same place the content of the file can
change you know due to some attack which
is completely outside the developer's
control right because in this case this
was you know because somebody
compromised S3 buckets right which is
not something the developer has any
control over so you'll have to uh have
some way to control your Behavior as
well as content and then the data flow
on the client say because this is very
important you accept lot of sensitive
data from the users in your forms you
need to kind of see where this data is
going I've seen examples of winter
companies where they collect you know
pan card information and then they send
it to like you know Google analytics or
somewhere else all because they had
misconfigured it you know when they were
setting up the third party code right so
this is also something you will have to
keep track of
all right so now that we have
established those as the high level
goals that you can Aspire towards right
when we're looking at client-side
security
where do you get started so I would say
client-side security is a journey there
are a lot of things you can actually do
but the first step you can focus on is
having a Content security policy and
content security policy is a client-side
web standard it's part of your browser
right and in terms of the amount of time
you would spend on implementing a CSP
policy you would get the maximum return
on investment so if you had to start
somewhere then this is probably the best
place to start from
all right so this is a little bit about
CSP like I said CSP is a standard web
standard so you create a policy which is
like a firewall it'll essentially say
what resources your page can load and
from what places right in a nutshell
that's what a CSP policy is and you add
it as an HTTP response header and it is
sent to your browser right so when the
browser loads your page it will first
look at the CSP policy and it will use
it as a reference before it loads any
resources let's say your web page says I
have to load JavaScript from xyz.com so
before your browser loads the script it
will look at the CSP policy and as the
CSP policy says xyz.com can you know
load JavaScript only then it will allow
it right so that's how it does its
filtering and it's all built into the
browser so you don't have to worry about
performance it's extremely fast
extremely efficient and you know uh the
browsers do a lot of things internally
to make sure that it does not affect
your regular load speed and other things
all right so CSV is great I'll not talk
about the definition like you know what
the CSP policy looks like because you
can do a Google Search and you can find
all of that but I'll speak about like I
said you know how you can actually
Implement a CSP policy right what are
the actual steps you can follow to
implement it in an easy way
so typically people find this difficult
but it does not have to be if you follow
the right way
uh
all right so we can break down our CSP
policy journey into two steps or two
stages I'll say stage one is having a
monitoring Mode Policy so with
monitoring mode you get into a position
where you have visibility into what into
what is happening on your client side
I'll give you an example let's say
tomorrow your site starts loading
JavaScript from you know
abc.ru for example right would you even
get to know about it today right
probably not so our first step is to
actually get visibility which is if we
are loading some resource which looks
you know suspicious or it looks you know
a little weird
as a site owner you at the very least
you should be informed about it right so
that's our monitoring Mode Policy and
once you get there and if you're
comfortable you can actually go to the
next stage where you can actually block
these things from being loaded itself so
the first step is detect take an attack
this you know uh the second step is you
know to see if you can actually go and
block the attacks as well
okay so to get started as a step one you
will have to create an initial policy
for your site and you will have to
deploy it and for doing this
ah so like I said we are you know
there's a free scanner that we are
putting out you will be able to download
it from this URL uh we also have some
pamphlets which we'll distribute it'll
have the download URL for you and this
is kind of what it looks like
I think this should play yeah
so you start the scan and then you can
go and visit your website
and you can go and you know like uh go
through all the workflow that you have
on your site authentication whatever
because all the data is kept locally
nothing is sent to our service
and after you do that if you stop the
scan then automatically a CSP policy is
generated for you so here you see an
auto generated CSP policy
so this is the policy and it also
explains to you as to what kind of
capabilities the policy you know
provides for you like for example
loading another JavaScript files is a
load by this policy but it will trigger
a violation which means if an
unauthorized JavaScript is loaded it'll
be it will not break your site
functionality it'll load but you will be
alerted about it right
so uh there are other capabilities of
the scanner as well I'll probably talk
about it a little later but this is one
thing you can use to actually create a
policy in like a matter of few minutes
ok so once you create the policy then
comes the other part which is okay I've
defined some things in the policy saying
I can only load JavaScript from a.com
and now my site is loading JavaScript
from b.com right so the if there is a
policy violation
but I'll have to consume this violation
somewhere right I need to have some kind
of a monitoring system where I get to
know that hey there was a policy
violation taking place and for that you
typically use what is called as a CSP
report violation you know monitoring
systems report monitoring systems there
are a lot of them you can set up some
system of you know your own you know uh
it you just have to open a rest API and
you know you can start consuming them
it's just in Json format these
violations or you can use any of the
commercial Solutions available which you
know do this for for you and
the best systems what they do is you
would get a lot of violations from the
browsers a lot of them would be noise as
well and it can get confusing to
actually make sense of all this you know
uh stuff you get so a good report while
report monitoring system what they will
do is they'll consume all those data
they'll clean it up and they'll give you
very clear information as to hey this is
the new behavior that you know something
that you'll have to look at
so for example this is you know like a
listing from our dashboard like where we
show you what are the you know new kinds
of violations that you're getting and we
also try and categorize these uh
behaviors into malicious or you know uh
benign or unknown right if it looks bad
then we say it's a malicious one if it's
very well known behavior let's say it's
good you don't have to worry but and if
you're not able to make a determination
we'll tell you that okay there is a new
behavior for which we don't have much
data maybe you can go and evaluate it
right
okay so you set up your CSP so first
thing is you put your policy and after
that you set your report monitoring
system and after you do both of that you
look at your reports that come you know
kind of like this and based on that you
keep updating your policy which is to
say you put your policy and now you see
that your site is loading scripts from
b.com right you're getting a lot of
violations for it now if b.com is a
trusted domain and you're legitimately
loading it you can update your CSP
policy to also say Okay I want to load
scripts from b.com as well right so you
keep doing it and in a short period of
time you should typically have a stable
policy
for monitoring mode this is our
estimation in terms of working with a
lot of customers so we process about
last month we process 3 billion CSP
violations so you know from our
observation
uh the initial policy will take you 10
minutes for a static site and 20 minutes
for a dynamic side
under stable policy is when it's got
into a stage where you don't really have
to update it too much right maybe you
updated once a month or once in two
months at most when you are doing some
major changes to your app
so typically for a static site you can
get to that stage in one week and for a
dynamic site you can get to that stage
in about two weeks right and so if
you're planning to like uh plan some
effort estimation this should give you
some rough idea right it's kind of like
okay you want to go get six packs this
is saying that at least it will take you
six months so in your head you are clear
that okay that's the minimum amount of
time I'll have to you know spend so your
enthusiasm is not lost after the second
week you know nothing is showing up
ok so now that we have covered the
monitoring mode we can get to the second
stage
uh before getting to the second stage if
you stop with just the monitoring mode
you are still in a very good position
because you have attack detection
capabilities if there is a compromise on
your client side at the very least you
would get alerted about it which is
which is a very good place to be at
compared to where you were earlier where
you had complete you know uh lack of
visibility into what is happening on the
client's client side of your
infrastructure
but after having done that you want to
go further then we can actually try to
go for a Blocking Mode Policy and
Blocking Mode Policy is where it gets
starts getting tricky and most people
struggle here and this is this is where
they give up so it is like uh if I were
to go back to the same six-pack analogy
for for full disclosure I don't have a
six pack I don't know why I'm using that
example but
anyway so it's easy for you to build the
muscle inside what is hard is to
actually cut the fat so it's visible
okay so this is the fat cutting part so
this is the most difficult part of you
know getting your uh this thing six pack
so Blocking Mode Policy is hard to do
and the reason is
what people do is they get a monitoring
Mode Policy and they try to convert that
policy into a Blocking Mode Policy and
that usually doesn't go very well
because there is a risk of your site's
functionality breaking right so because
of which there is either they are too
nervous and they never move it to you
know
blocking mode it's like that email very
angry email you wrote but you never
clicked on send you know it's kind of
like that they have the perfect policy
ready but they never put it in you know
blocking mode and uh or they wait for
like you know either the management says
for one of our customers the management
said it does not matter if we have
business loss for a few months we want
this policy because the attacks match
cut attacks that were happening was a
very real threat for them right so if
you have a business buy-in like that
then you can you know go and say okay
fine I'll deploy it
but otherwise what you can do is uh you
can actually keep your monitoring Mode
Policy because the browser supports
multiple CSP policies at the same time
okay which is you can have a monitoring
Mode Policy and at the same time you can
have a Blocking Mode Policy so you are
monitoring Mode Policy can be very
comprehensive and your Blocking Mode
Policy you can keep adding things one by
one right whichever you think is like
safe to add you are not seeing too many
violations you're not seeing too many
behavioral changes like for example
JavaScript
you have you know you have said okay I
can load JavaScript from a.com b.com
c.com d.com and your site has not loaded
JavaScript from any new domain for like
you know like a month or two right then
you can confidently go and put just your
script section of the policy in blocking
mode right because there's not a whole
lot of changes uh taking place but for
images maybe there are new domains which
are loading images all the time so
images maybe you'll never put it in uh
blocking mode right you will always keep
it in monitoring mode only so that's an
approach you can actually take and uh
right so if if any you know uh type has
too much Dynamic content like I said
images usually you know you never have
to put it in blocking mode
and if the script for example JavaScript
is changing too often right you're
loading JavaScript from a lot of
different domains and all that
then
you would want to put it in blocking
mode because script is a very sensitive
kind of uh you know item
but you cannot put it just by giving a
host list you know by giving a list of
hosts so what you can instead look at is
an option called as using nonce so with
nonce you can why you can actually uh
you know whitelist a section of scripts
and you say okay these scripts I'm okay
with loading on my site and I authorize
these scripts to go and load any other
scripts on my site right so if for
example you're loading an ad provide us
JavaScript and they go and load five
other scripts on their site
you don't have to mention those domains
in your CSP policy because you're saying
okay the primary script I'm authorizing
and I'm also saying it can load further
scripts so this way you can actually put
your script SRC I mean your JavaScript
in a blocking mode without having to
have like a very big list of you know
domains that you're maintaining and
constantly updating right
all right so uh we can first move items
which have the highest importance like I
said script with nons and this thing
strict Dynamic uh one of the easier
things to move is like your form
submissions because form submissions
usually are you know to a limited set of
domains you don't add new domains so
much but form submission is a very
sensitive thing right you don't want
your form submissions going to random
website so that is something you can add
to the Blocking Mode Policy so you can
see which ones are very sensitive at the
same time they're not changing much and
you can keep moving them one by one
right and other ones maybe some of them
you never move to blocking mode right so
there's remain in the monitoring mode
which is completely okay you have summon
blocking summon monitoring and with that
you will get to like not the best
security but you know like what is good
for you right so and this is a bit of a
effort estimation of how much time it
would take for the different kinds of
resources that you have on your site
for scripts uh if it's the site is not
very Dynamic you could you know go to
blocking mode in about a week for
scripts that are Dynamic you could you
know it could take you like two weeks
sometimes even never uh you could go
with the nonsensitive dynamic but
sometimes
the development effort for doing that is
so high that you never you know get to
do that so you can just keep it in
monitoring mode form submission is very
easy to do like I said because it does
not change so much so anyway this uh
this is available in the slide so you
can use it as reference so if you're
making a plan you can use it as a
reference and then you can say hey you
know what this is how much time I'll
have to essentially spin right so that
should give you some idea
all right so with that I've kind of
covered the uh you know most of the
points which I wanted to talk about so
now what I can actually do is I can show
you a bit of the scanner that we wanted
to you know launch here
so the scanner is available as uh
extension to this tool called burp suit
is a free tool if you are if you have
done anything related to security then
you know you would definitely know this
tool so it's free you can download
install it there's a lot of
documentation available as to how you
can do it and you can add an extension
to it uh in verb and then you can open
your browser you can configure your
browser to use burp suit
and then you go to scanner.dom.io okay
and this will actually load our scanning
engine our scanning engine is is like a
web assembly uh module right so that
will download it locally onto the page
and this webassembly engine and the web
extension they work together to do the
analysis so all of the data remains
locally nothing gets sent to your server
although it says scanner.io nothing is
going to my server right and you can
confirm that also so and with this what
you get is and it's a passive scan if
you browse it'll tell you what CSP
policies you have
how good those CSP policies are for
example I just scanned amazon.com uh
it'll tell you what security is provided
by the existing policies
you can look at all the JavaScript that
the site is loading
so you can look at you know all the
third party code you're loading and you
can see what each of those third-party
code is doing on your site right because
your own site your own scripts behavior
is something that's you know known to
you but when you load an external script
you do not know what it is doing is it
accessing your you know storage is it
changing sending Ajax calls is it using
you know insecure API is like eval for
example right all of that information
will be listed here so like for example
here it says that the script is using
two dangerous apis and
I can see what those apis are it's using
the inner HTML property
and it says that this script is making
Ajax calls to these domains and so on so
yeah so you can see the individual
behaviors of all the scripts that you
have and you can also go and see
category wise like for example data
security so here it says that uh
whatever data I enter into the field for
example I went to Amazon and I searched
for JS conf India and it says that the
data from this field which is my you
know keywords field was being sent to
amazon.com and I can click on it I'll
actually tell me the you know actual URL
in which the data is being sent
uh
so here the data is being sent in a post
request so for example if you have a
registration form right where you're
accepting user data you can actually use
this tool you can fill in the form and
you can see if any of your sensitive
data is going to some third parties that
you don't want to send it to right
right I will tell you what are the key
log is which scripts are reading which
input fields and so on so that's uh in a
gist what it does so uh you can go try
it out and if you have any you know
feedback you have suggestions ideas
whatever it is you can let me know I'll
be more than happy to incorporate it uh
again I'm not a devil I mean I write a
lot of code but I wouldn't call myself a
developer so you know so this is a
security tool but you know being shown
to developers so whatever you guys think
hey lava you know what this way you are
doing it is completely stupid can you do
it like this instead you know please
feel free to send it yeah okay that's it
guys
so if you have any questions whatever
you can come talk to me yeah
that was an amazing session sure
multiple mics working at the same time
yes
I know in college I used to sit behind
so that I never had to show my
assignments but come on yeah No One's
Gonna check it out of the last like back
Ventures here we can see some of them so
the seats in the front are unoccupied if
you want to come you can come here
in the front we also have some bean bags
if you want a spread your legs and relax
for a bit Yeah because we're already
talking to a lot of AI and at least here
we would like to talk to some you actual
people and not feel like we're talking
to Black chairs empty chairs please
commented in the forward if it's fine if
it's not it's completely okay cool cool
so I think we are a little low on energy
here so what are we we are going to do
is that we are going to give some fomo
to people who are outside or people who
are in the other track so we are gonna
give a huge cheer so that all of them
feel that something exciting is
happening here because that is gonna
happen all the upcoming talks are very
interesting so let's do it okay on the
count of three two one you have to give
me a huge shout out a cheer or anything
okay but please make sure you don't
cheer because the future
okay let's do it okay three two one
please
oh
who was that that seemed like an
engineering College sure pretty much
cool cool let's play a quick game what
do you say sure I'm I'm always up for
games okay so for that what we have we
have like four actions so when I say
stand up you have to sit down when I say
sit down you have to stand up okay that
is as simple as that and let's see how
many defaulters we have do you want to
modulated
uh I think I'll give it to you you know
the game better cool cool so sit down
and you have to be quick okay let's be
quick
Stan
stand
we have some defaulters
sit down
oh my God it's so hard for people
sitting on bean bags please don't fall
guys it's okay if you don't want to
stand up
cool I think that's a good enough right
so I'll leave it to you to introduce the
next speaker yes uh our next speaker is
going to talk about something that a lot
of people
is basically around most of the
conference that's happening that's in
the front-end domain and
I did take some time to ask how the talk
was what what it was revolving around
and I personally found it to be very
interesting so yeah we have sarvana
srinivasan talking about building a
better micro front-end application that
offers platform Freedom let's give a
round of applause for him
louder please let's let's cheer him up
thank you
and Justice again
okay
so hello and welcome everyone to the
talk build a better microphone
application that offers platform freedom
I am saravana Balaji srinivasan I work
as a senior software engineer at Red Hat
mainly on JavaScript Technologies I've
been contributing towards uh business
building I mean business automation
products and
uh serverless workflow specifications
Etc so yeah that's about me
well
we are in JavaScript conference right so
let's talk about JavaScript uh
JavaScript is here for almost 28 years
right uh it has uh passed single Jubilee
years marks of 25 years already
um even the growth of JavaScript over
the years has been tremendous
um even the Frameworks that was built on
top of JavaScript are here for quite
some time uh react uh recently has
celebrated its 10th year angular and
nodejs are here for almost 14 years and
ugs is here for nine years and the list
goes on right
it means the applications that are built
on JavaScript are quite getting bit old
but I mean old uh
it is it has been so long the
applications are being developed or
maintained right eventually the
applications are growing growing and it
is growing on an exponential rate right
so when an application is going bigger
they tend to have a lot of issues with
it
um scaling in bigger application will be
quite complex and to maintain bigger
application also will be made will be a
tedious task at least
um
I mean eventually we cannot say that it
is just because of JavaScript or the
JavaScript Frameworks there are a lot of
reasons associated with it uh it is all
together a separate discussion to have
but one thing that I can emphasize is
that
um breaking I mean to have a bigger
application or you have a smaller
applications it that depends on the
organization decision or the plans that
they take on how they want to design
their application uh be it had had
similar situation uh that takes me to
the next slide
the Red Hat story
um we we at Red Hat had a product called
jbpm which is a business automation
product at some point I mean it is a
legacy one at some point we decided to
enhance it by accommodating laws some of
the latest tech stacks and also we
wanted to ship that particular product
as a service with Cloud Technologies
uh at that point of time we already had
microservice uh running on the back end
but the front end was one huge chunk of
Monolithic application
um we were in a situation to find a
solution to break that
um we that's that's when we started
exploring various architectures that
were available
uh one thing I can closely uh give you
more detailed context about the
architecture here starting with an
evolutionary architecture which uh
evolves over I mean incrementally over a
period of time based on the business
needs our customers feedback or any end
users uh
um I mean reports or something I mean
arguing the feedbacks uh then we have
this microservices which is there at the
back end where I mean collectively
multiple uh services or combining
together to perform specific tasks also
we have the buzzing word here uh that is
serverless where we have backend as a
service that include custom code runs as
a function and then we have microfen
tense on the front end world
I would like to quote
um from I mean I point a quote from the
renowned software developer who is Cam
Jackson he mentions an architectural
style where independently deliverable
front-end applications are composed into
a greater whole
now let's get into micro front end we'll
get to know the context why I mean the
code there
what are microfrontins okay I'll just
hold down here I don't want to give you
the definition of micro frontin uh I'm
sure that you would have already got
this definition on a number of tasks and
talks or other conferences so I don't
want to bore you again with that
definition uh but still if you want to
know the definition I would strongly
recommend you to uh go through those
stocks so that you will get an idea
about it uh but I would like to keep it
simple and I wanted to directly jump
into
um the main motto or the objective of
micro front end
um
it is this uh the main objective of
microfen 10 is decoupling uh if you want
to break a bigger chunk of Monolithic
application into smaller chunks or to
decouple a bigger application into
smaller chunks smaller applications or
other consider as a main motto of
microfronting
there is a saying don't put all your
eggs in one basket right so it is
obviously very difficult to manage as
shown in this picture uh this applies to
your technology as well if you put
everything on one particular uh chunk
then it will be definitely hard to
maintain you can always diversify your
technology diversification is just not
about the wealth or money that you have
you can always diversify your technology
and you can keep it simple
yeah so far we have seen uh the
objective objectives of microphone 10 uh
also I would also emphasize that
microfen tense is not the just the only
solution you have as I mentioned in my
previous slide
um
you I mean it purely depends on the
organization uh whether or the team
decision I'm sorry
or the team's decision whether they want
to really want to choose a microphone in
or they they want to go with another
approach so as an alternative there are
other approaches as well which I'm going
to mention in this slide uh one is the
first one the monolith again you can
still go with monolithic basic based
applications uh considering consider by
a while you have in a simpler
application that performs one particular
task or something so then you can just
go with monolithic application where you
have just your front end and you're back
in that they just communicate between
them in order to perform a particular
task also in case if you want my
monolithic application and still you
want to have some features of micro
friend and you can always go with
modular monolith application where the
front end chunk is broken down into
smaller modules which are not totally
independent but they are slightly
coupled I mean Loosely coupled between
them also it makes replacing of module
will be very easy uh you can whenever if
you want to change the module with
another one you can obviously can do
with modular based monolithic
application and
there is another one which is called as
integrated application where you can
have various applications smaller
applications I mean which communicate
between them on the build time
composition and finally we have Micro
front ends again we have smaller pieces
of code uh I mean a smaller pieces of
micro microfinding applications they all
communicate between them on the runtime
composition so micro Fenton has its own
advantages which I can list so many but
the main things that I can point here is
the scaling of an application or
maintaining your code will be made easy
each team can have I mean the
application have uh each I mean
autonomous teams they can work on
individually on their independently on
their product without depending on other
teams for any particular task or
something they can have their own
release Cycles in order to deploy
something so it makes the work easier of
our developers
so I I just want to hold back here again
and we'll have to go back to the title
build a better microphone in application
that offers platform freedom and I would
like to emphasize what I mean by the
term platform here
as I mentioned uh I'm working uh with a
team where we build two links for Server
serverless workflow specifications and
business automation products so at the
end of the day these tools are used by
the developers and the communities where
whom with whom we are working so
um we wanted to Target the tools or the
platforms uh which developers and
communities mostly use those could be we
all know that some Ides or Visual Studio
as a developer we also have been using
that and we wanted to target vs code and
we have the two links which are again
web tools I mean they are built on web
components to be running on BS code as
an extension and the same set of code
has to be running on GitHub as an
extension and browser as an extension it
could be Chrome browser or a Firefox
browser and finally we should also have
web web-based application which built on
top of react so we were targeting these
um
platforms also this I mean uh we were
targeting other platforms as well but
these are the more I mean focused
targets that we had at the point
uh the reason the motivation that we got
how we can deploy or complex make our
components to be running on uh those
weird platforms is that because of the
web technology web technology has a
complete dominance over the I mean
software industry at this point it is
considered as the go to choice for most
of the people who wants to build an
application for their use case this is
because
web technology has stronger Foundation
stronger standards techniques and
patterns it also has
rich in ecosystem uh after the
introduction of JavaScript yeah the
ecosystem has fastly grown after the
introduction of I mean a lot of exciting
Frameworks it uh enables it more
actually
and
later after introduction of the
typescript people like me who started
the with the Java developer started
liking web technology after the
introduction of typescript because I
personally feel that my code is totally
typed safe while using typescript right
so I I would still say that I mean
introduction of typescript is considered
as one of the path breaker on the web
technology world
also I would like to emphasize now you
can say see browser everywhere you can
see browser on the desktop mobile or
tablets or you can see on the server
also you can find JavaScript I mean uh
browsers on the platforms that I
mentioned you can see it on vs code
extension or GitHub extension or the
browser extensions so this gave us the
motivation that we can make our
components to be running on those those
spaces so that it will be accessed by
the developers easily
so these are the some screenshots that
we took um there are two links are
running on vs code like this come in
GitHub and browser as an extension and
finally we have the react-based web app
uh the the two tools that you see here
or the BPM and dmn uh do tools that we
use for the business automation products
and the other other tool that we have a
serverless workflow uh editor that we
have uh which is also based out of um
um I mean the main tools that we build
once a such example of this uh I mean
micro friend and act I mean approach
that we wanted to uh come to get get it
so here uh this tool I mean maybe this
picture I mean this screenshot looks
simple uh you may think why I we went to
uh microfinton for simple UI but uh our
tool links are actually far more bigger
than this this shot is very small but uh
we have a lot of components uh almost
like uh 600 700 components I have and we
have various modules as well so just for
example this container application
contains various microcentens in it and
each microfinance are maintained by an
individual team uh and they all work on
I mean work autonomally
so getting getting into the features of
microfinance
um so one of the core patterns that
microfin 10 offers is BFF it is not
abbreviated as basement for forever but
it is a best friend for both micro
Fenton and the micro service at the back
end or or the backend so if you closely
look at this diagram here uh there is no
communication their communication
happening between the micro front ends
all the communications are happening
inside the container and container takes
a major decision here so and also if you
see there is no communication from the
micro front end and to the backend
microservice it happens via BFF so here
BFF takes the decision I mean receives
the request from the micro front end and
picks it in such a way that a micro
service can attend I mean accept I mean
handle it I also uh even whatever
response that comes from the
microservice is passed onto the
microfurant and Via BFF uh here again
BFF intra interrupts and then it just
tweaks that response in such a way that
can understand it
so it basically enables a seamless
communication between the micro front
end and the micro service
so while implementing microfrington
um type of integration is considered as
one of the most important thing uh we
need to keep in mind uh because this
strategy is most more important uh there
are two types of integration that we can
discuss here that is one is runtime
integration which is considered a good
choice for most of the teams who want to
implement micro frontin let's see what
it is so let's consider the scenario we
have a team a and Team B uh in case if
you're team a builds a component C it is
they just deploy it uh it is available
in the URL uh where you have the URL
name and Slash and the particular
company name.js it is directly available
there if the other team wants to see
that particular component they just have
to hit the URL it is readily available
there okay so deploying is made easier
with this runtime uh
integration it is very fast as well but
it has its own downside the tooling and
setup of this approach is quite
complicated complex
as I mentioned there is another approach
which is build time integration again
I'm taking the same scenario where we
have Team a and Team B working for an
app on an application where a team a
builds a component C they deploy it in
npm registry or any other registry they
can
um the other team who wants to use that
particular component they can just uh
include that in their packages and as a
dependency so that they can directly use
it in case they have that already as a
dependency they can just bump the
version to pull out the latest changes
made or the latest code that has been
pushed on the mpm registry uh so in this
way they can uh I mean the deployment
and all this and since it is provided by
npm uh that that the team EA's work is
easy here but the other team the team B
has to rebuild their entire application
if they want to use the latest code uh
provided by the team a so again the
build time may be long depends on the
application again
also there are
um styling concerns associated with the
microfrontings uh saying say for example
if you have multiple microfringtons and
you have uh written class names along
with certain properties CSS properties
they could be chances uh if there are
class names uh common uh some similar
class names associated with my other
microfrin tin there could be child and
chances that one property can overwrite
on other one uh So to avoid that you can
better go with CSS and JS there are a
lot of available Frameworks uh the major
one is style components
um then also you can use namespace for
the CSS files and also there is a
traditional approach of using iframes
most of the teams uh they still go with
iframes while working with microfinance
they wrap their microfrin application uh
in a iframe and they just render it so
that they can completely isolate their
microphone and from the outside world so
that it does not affect on any other
external
um I mean SNL requests so how this is
made I mean if you see closely look at
this code here
um as scripta containing various routes
here and each route points to an uh
micro front end
okay
so with this iframe
um yeah as I mentioned it is not a new
or fancy thing it is uh age-old approach
a kind of an egg right so it has its own
pros and cons uh the pro is mean yeah it
could be uh it is it is it provides a
complete isolation but uh as a downside
it has it makes your application look a
bit old
um as I mentioned unread is less
flexible and you cannot make any
communication from the other to the
other micro front ends
so after this after thinking about all
these features that microfinance offers
we decided to go with
um a framework uh we decided to overcome
these complexities that we had so we
started thinking of a new and
architecture why we needed a new
architecture
we had these requirements
uh we wanted to have our web tools
running on uh various platforms that I
mentioned like vs code as an extension
browser as an extension uh I mean would
be Chrome browser or so Chrome extension
or Firefox extension and we also wanted
that to be running on GitHub and finally
we also wanted to have it in uh as in
web app so these were the distributions
we were targeting and also we have we
had to do that with very minimal code
changes and finally we also wanted to
create a bridge for the two uh future
Tech Stacks as well
yeah before getting into that framework
uh I just wanted to show a quote from
Ralph Jansen uh about software
architecture so architecture is about
the important stuff whatever that is
uh so it architecture mainly focus on
the important stuff of an application
that's what he's trying to say about the
Discord
let's get into multiplying architecture
so this is the framework that we built
on top of micro front and strategies in
order to uh accomplish the requirements
that we had and the that I haven't just
showed in the previous slide
the main uh motto or the objective of
multiplying architecture is to have
abstraction
okay
let's see what I mean by abstraction I
mean uh what sort of layer we have for
abstraction here so these are the core
components of multiplying architecture
where we have Channel envelope View and
editor starting with channel so channels
here the the host environment or the
platform where we wanted to run our
tooling here in our case it could be vs
code or GitHub or the browsers so these
are considered as channel here and the
other right on the extreme right you see
editor sorry uh here in our use case we
had it here so I just mentioned here
editor in case someone wants to try the
multiplying architecture they can just
place your application here it still
works perfectly fine
um and then there's a view which wraps
this editor uh this view is built on our
asset Yak component so it just wraps the
editor and there is a layer between the
channel and the view which is envelope
it access in uh I mean intermediate
layer between the channel and View and
enables the communication between them
uh it completes the completely abstracts
one another for instance uh view or
editor will complete will not know on
what Channel it is running it is totally
abstracted by envelope and also channel
will not know what sort of what what
sort of communication happening in the
inside the editor it just know nothing
so whatever that is provided by the
envelope it just runs on the channel
so these are the few screenshots where
we wanted our tooling to be running on
the online Channel like this uh the
outer layer is the channel again inside
we have the editor and the envelope
facilitates the communication between
them
we wanted to have the tool to be run on
desktop as a channel like this
GitHub extension like this I'll be
showing you a quick demo about all these
things in the uh the last
and we wanted to have uh ready to be
running on vs code extension like this
so again this this slide actually I can
show you the how the communication
happens between the editor and the
channel if you closely look at this
diagram uh here no iframes are used it
is just div the editor is done just
rendered as a web component so still we
were able to achieve or we will we were
able to isolate the micro front end
without any external effects
by the use of envelope we'll see what
are the advantages we get through
envelopes because we spoke a lot about
envelope it provides us the context
isolation uh we were able to isolate the
micro front ends uh with I mean with the
outside world
it enabled us to work on an autonomous
team uh we could able to have our own
releases our own life I mean uh Pipeline
and finally it provides us the types of
communication what I mean by the types
of communication here we all know that a
frame provides uh I mean communicates
with outside world using post messages
right so
this post messageity is just a string so
we always don't want to have a string
for any of the images that we pass
outside right so we wanted to have we
thought we must have some sort of type
safe communication to the outside world
innocence are the other microfen tens uh
this envelope offers the types of
communication something with the with
something we have called shared values
that enables us to have uh types of
types of communication
let's see my multiplaying architecture
in practice
um for which I have
some of the toolings here
so I can share this repository maybe if
you want to say see how this looks uh
maybe if this tooling is boring to you
maybe uh you can just see this as a
different but if you want to try that
I'll show you the code I'll show you the
code base of the last where you can go
and try yourself about this multiplying
architecture and you can build an
application top of it uh so yeah this
BPM in tool again uh this represents the
business process of uh I mean as I
mentioned since we are using uh we are
building tourings for business
automation products so this BPM and
represents uh business process notation
so yeah this editor that you see here is
built with this multiplying architecture
we we're just able to accommodate this
multiple I mean uh editor here on the vs
code uh with a very minimal set of code
changes of course we had to write code
uh codes to build this extension vs code
extensions uh but the core component of
this editor are just reused
let's let's see how this looks on
the browser extension so for uh for
which I have
um Chrome Market store
and go here and can search for
bpmn
yeah it gives me the editor here I
already have installed here so it works
for me
and
if I go bpmn.new
it opens me this editor you see here
this editor is same as what you see on
the BS code extension I can
upload some files here maybe I'll upload
the same file
see so it is the similar the same editor
is used both on two different platforms
uh we'll see another editor that we
built which is
serverless workflow
so this editor again it is built on
multiplying architecture so on the left
uh it shows the serverless works
specifications whatever it is shown on
the left it is like edit I mean edited
by the editor here and process provides
a diagrammatical representation of that
particular workflow
so these these editors are built on top
of multiplying architecture
uh
how this multiplying architecture works
so in case if you want to try that I'll
pass you this URL uh maybe I'll just
have a slide at the last where you can
note that and we have a separate folder
called examples that provides you uh
some classic examples of ping pong or
to-do list uh these these examples are
built on top of micro front end these
are separate channels and you can run
the same ping pong applications on vs
code or on browser or GitHub everywhere
the same approach is followed here as
well
you know if you have a web app which is
the container application or other
channel I mean the content application
which contains all this
um multiplying I mean individual micro
printings and maybe you can just run
this application to see uh how it
individually works
so getting back to the slide here
so even after having uh the multiplying
architecture in place we had the final
dot to connect we still had the problem
with choosing the integration strategy
as I mentioned it is one of the uh the
most important choice that we have to
make
um so if you closely look at this
drawbacks that I mentioned here with the
build time issues and the runtime issues
uh the common one common thing will be
the duplication of Library loading
right uh what I mean by the term Library
loading here so if you have consider
closely look at this diagram if you have
a multiple micro friend tents say for
example uh microphone and A and B and C
has to react as a dependency to it three
different instance of react is created
here if all these things goes to a
container I mean the entire application
would be in huge in size just for one I
mean dependency it's fine but if you
just imagine if you have a lot of
dependencies that are repetiting across
multiple micro front ends and if you
have n number of micro front ends
definitely it is going to affect your
application a lot right so I eventually
I also don't have to do this you can
just share the dependency how we can do
that
Federated module came to our rescue uh
we all maybe you might have heard about
this Federated modules it is introduced
uh with webpack file it gave us a
solution to
um to implement runtime integration for
in our multiplaying architecture how did
it work
so yeah this is our repair configuration
um
we are just like my module Federation is
just imported and then at the line
number 18 you have remotes which
specifies various routes each route uh
is assigned to particular micro front
end so when this particular route is
called and the corresponding microfinton
will be loaded and and if you see the
line number 23 the dependencies are
shared with the property called shared
so these dependencies are shared are
more I mean there are certain
dependencies which we point here uh will
be shared across uh this multi three
micro sentence that we have
also uh by using the lazy loading
concept that we have in react you can do
lazy Imports and you can just with the
routes you can just uh I mean render
those microfinance whenever it is needed
or when that particular URL is hit
finally with all this my um and
multiplying architecture and frederated
modules we were able to achieve our goal
of multiple distributions with the
minimal code changes and we also able to
create a bridge to the Future text
stacks
so these are the points that we were
able to achieve uh we finally able to
implement microfinance strategy
um using multiplying architecture and we
also took the advantage of runtime
integration via Federated modules and
each we also created autonomous teams
and there was no duplication of I mean
Library loading and so on
as I mentioned so the code is available
at this repository which is an Open
Source One anybody can uh have a look at
it if you want to try this definitely uh
I would recommend it it's about giving a
try
if you want to snap a pic I'll just wait
for a minute
cool
so yeah that's about my talk
thanks
in case if you have any questions I'm
available so you can reached me uh with
your any questions that you have thanks
thank you
thank you oh that was an amazing talk I
personally learned a lot about micro
front ends so let's give him a huge
round of applause
[Applause]
I think our fomo that we did a huge here
that helped
back yeah please turn on her Mike's wall
it's not on I guess
I can help you
there you go hello check check yes
great so how many engineering managers
do we have in-house today here raise of
hands engineering managers even leads
managers leads team leads managers who
have people reporting to them can we
have one of you or two of you as
volunteers on the stage please
nobody's going to ask you to life code
don't worry we just wanted to make this
space a bit more open and have a small
rant session if you want to so we want
one engineering manager or lead to come
up on stage and we want one um
developer or anyone who's had a good
experience or bad thank you so much for
volunteering to come so I'll ask you to
be on the podium and tell us where you
work currently
oh you could have given your mic yeah
you can use her mic and it's fine if you
don't tell where you work
it's no longer a secret so this is
a senior principal manager
when his teammates said like we don't
build Rockets but we are a rocket
company okay now is there any frustrated
engineer in the house who wants to rant
about their manager anyone you know who
has some complaints and wants to take it
out keeping in mind that you have to
follow the code of conduct and
not say anything inappropriate
anyone who would want to volunteer
why would anyone oh that's a good
question why would anyone on a public
stage you know rant about it
okay
or we can ask him like what is it that
that they could
have something that annoys you about
a rant called like there are too many
meetings like that's the story in every
company who all agree that there are a
lot of meetings every day and it takes
productivity away
can he give us a cheer who all agree to
this point
so I think we have a Unison here so I
think thank you so much sir we do not
have any ranting Engineers in-house
today yeah I'm seeing the audience is
very very politically correct they do
not want to anger anyone in the current
market so that's really good
cool we have our next speaker then
oh my phone got locked yes so
before we go to the next talk
um as we first talked about if there's
any ranting set we we try to ask your
folks to rant about what you don't like
but talking about the good things
if is there anything that you want to
share in terms of how you started your
journey into the whole world of tech
engineering development if there's a
story uh I that's one of the speakers
who's going to come up and his story is
something that I really really enjoy
okay we can start with the introduction
in that case yes and in the next set of
fillers we can do it just
just a minute
yes next we have Amir Jaan with us who
will be talking about building large
scale stateful JS applications so let's
give up give him a round of applause
the stage is yours
hey hello everyone
is the mic working
okay Mike working I guess it's working I
just have one quick announcement so
someone here has lost their phone
so if it is yours yeah
all right
hey hello everyone
how are you folks I see a lot of dull
faces so you know what what I'm gonna do
let's do some sit-ups yeah let's stand
up sit up yeah let's do some sit-ups
come on come on folks yeah let's stand
up
yeah please please
no answer joking you can sit down you
can relax
you can relax okay I thought I think the
the thought process of doing a setup
already brightened you up so I think so
if not we'll do sit-ups okay so if I
feel anywhere I'm losing you we'll do
sit-ups deal so stay with me stay with
me for the talk
so with this I guess you would be little
more curious to know me so this is Amir
and I lead the ID team okay
okay good
uh so this is Amit I lead the ID team at
hacker rank so all the IDS that you see
in our platform is mostly managed by us
and if you see anything going wrong hit
me okay so yeah when I'm bored with IDs
I I really love building small tools
that bring a lot of developer
productivity when I'm bored with
building those small tools I play a lot
of valorent I mean by that I mean a lot
in the Mumbai server so anybody anywhere
and fans in the home
oh nice
play the agent gecko
nice so yeah you will be able to relate
little bit more to the talk so
yeah so
I am a full-time cat dad you know how
tough that is so
people often ask me I mean how do you
deal with people right my answer is
simple I have a cat he teaches me a lot
you can deal with the People by just
ignoring them all day with no reasons
right so get a cat you will get to learn
a lot of people skills and this is from
experience okay
to brighten you up more this is my cat
amulu look at him how cute he is
30 seconds I'm going to leave this on
the screen so that you all get soaked
that energy look he's looking at you and
asking are you up for the talk
are you up
oh nice look he's very curious about you
know what what you're gonna think about
it but yeah
bonus this is
he just became a dad you know
um he's like one week old
yeah another 20 seconds I'm gonna leave
it for you too
to you know get pumped up for the talk
I'm gonna create one after this okay
um
he was supposed to be my plus phone for
the conference
but his dad didn't allow it like any
every other dad he wants to do more
parenting so I left him at home
yeah with that said today I'm here to
you know share a bit about how we can
build you know scalable JS applications
right by this I want to leave you folks
with a set of thoughts that may feel
like we are rethinking some best
practices right that's why there's a
question mark some might may think this
is the right way to do some may think
this is not the best practice so it's up
to you folks to decide
most of this is
a set of Reflection from my learnings of
working at ID working on IDs at hacker
rank so yeah
I want to start with a question that
like think about this what is the most
complex rental application that you
would have ever used or created right
everyone have their own opinions so
think about it right for a good few
seconds think about it get something on
your mind
and if you ask me like like at least for
the past year my answer has to be in vs
code right we never address vs code as a
web application right we address vs code
as a desktop application do you folks
agree you folks all use vs code I guess
yeah anyone use jetbrains
there is the door
just joking okay just joking but think
about it vs code is a web application
running inside electron and it's running
as a desktop application do you think
its performance is like just absolutely
amazing right even jet bands couldn't
catch up it's a native application right
so vs code is so performant so my
opinion has always been for the past
year that it's one of the most complex
printed application that has been ever
built right at least it's very
JavaScript heavy
what's so special about it right it's
just another filter application
uh when we like you know had a look at
its source code we maintain a fork of vs
code at hacker rank there are some
surprises right first of all they don't
use react
for that sake they don't use any
UA Library so they don't use view they
don't use wealth nothing they have their
own hand-rolled JavaScript UI library
for most part it's imperative right our
mindset for the past decade has been
declarative UI is the best way to write
it can you imagine how complex vs code
is and their entire UI is imperative
they are not using declarative right and
we think using declarative is the best
practice
and the code that they have written is
very scalable maintainable and it still
grows right every every month we get
updates for vs code
second there is no traditional rest
endpoints in vs code I guess most of you
would have used quote sandbox projects
or
code spaces from GitHub right in which
you get vs code in the browser and
you're connected to a remote VM or a
container and you're make doing your
work from the browser but it's like you
know saved on the VM right so in that
case the vs code in your browser is the
front end and the backend is the remote
container right
so how does the back end and front-end
communication happen right it should be
very complex because vs coordinates
itself is very complex lot of
interaction it's very very reactive
right how does that happen right and
they don't use traditional rest
endpoints that was very surprising and
they make heavy use of difference
injection
so you might know that there is a
version of vs code that runs entirely in
the browser which is vs code.dev there's
a version of vs code that I was talking
about runs in code spaces where you
connect to a remote machine and you do
your work from the browser the summation
of vs code that runs in your local
machine right there are so many versions
of it right using dependence injection
they have made it to adopt to different
environment without much code changes
the same code base that can run in
multiple environments using dependency
injection and I have not seen many of
our front ends using dependence
injections right
and it has desktop class layout right it
has a very very excellent layout engine
right it has so many complex views you
can dock views undock views make them
work to work with each other right so
many great stuff but we don't reuse any
of the layout engine we built hand-roll
all our layout engine right nothing
comes close to the layout engine of vs
code has
even there are so many great things
about vs code that I can I can talk for
an r in the talk but since there is like
23 minutes left I want to specifically
talk about one thing which is front end
to bracket communication that happens in
vs code by this we're going to talk
about the second point which is there is
no traditional rest endpoints in vs code
how does it do front end to backend
communication right
rather than me taking you through a
slide let's take a take a demo app right
and let's walk us through it like let's
take an app that is built on a
traditional approach and then let's
rebuild it how vs core would do it right
so can you all pray for the demo code
it's gonna gonna be demo after this so
hopefully pray that the demo doesn't
break okay I hope the the code is
legible let me know if I want to if you
want me to zoom further right
so it's a simple and sober app nothing
much going here we have a backend folder
we have a front-end folder okay the
front end is a wheat app which has just
single file okay what the file is trying
to do it's trying to hit an endpoint
which is
in 8000 port and it's hitting the
endpoint read file right and it's
getting back the file content and I'm
displaying the file content in the div
tag which I have in index.html which
also Imports the index.ts file
right and I have a back and forth
backend folder which is uh you know very
basic Express
server which has an endpoint which we
just saw read file and what it's doing
it's using the fs module of you know
node and it's reading the file and just
returning back the file content right
and it's reading sample.txt which is
just a bunch of you know a lot of maps
on that I put in put together right so
let's let's see the output right so let
me start the server
okay this is
cool as simple as that we got the file
content and we are seeing it in the
front end right uh if you just look at
it there are a bunch of associated first
of all in the front end I have no idea
what the back end is returning right if
I look at what's the file content it's
just any I have no idea what is the
response format from my backend right
and it can change any day for example my
backend developer goes things like I'm
going to screw my front-end developers
live today so
screw him I'm gonna change it to
content no more file content this is how
I like it right he goes to sleep
and you get called that your application
is broken right
what can you do now you have to debug
and figure out like it was back and
developer let's screw him again right so
that happens all the time right it
happened to me a lot of times right
let's just say you want to as a let's
just say imagine this is an ID right now
I want to implement a new functionality
let's just say I want to implement
delete file right now I have to go ahead
create a new endpoint say delete then
change this to unlink do all bunch of
stuff now make another API hit from the
front end whenever I want to delete the
file right it just easily gets
unmaintainable right what if there is a
better way to do it what's a different
way to do it right so let's have a look
at it right this is this is the
traditional way of doing it and it works
and it has been working for decades for
us
so I did little cheating so don't care
about it I did a bunch of restructuring
here to save your time the back and
folder is gone because no one wants to
do a right APN points okay the back and
forth is done I just deleted it in the
front end folder there is a new file
here called fs.0.ts okay
and in the fs.server.ts file I have a
read file which is using the node FS
package FS built-in module to read read
any file based on the file path that
you're giving to the function it's
returning the file content right as
simple as that and exporting the read
file
okay and there's an index.ts file which
is our front and entry point and it's
directly importing that FS from the fs
server and calling fs.read file I am
getting full type intelligence here that
there is a function called read file it
takes string and it returns a file
content I'm just showing it different
how many of you think that this would
work how many of you think this is legal
ok
I guess you already have a fair sense of
idea why this is illegal right but what
if this is possible right why is not
possible
this has lot of benefits let's just say
tomorrow my backend developer decides
let's screw my front-end developer I'm
going to remove the argument no more
argument for read5 I give you a random
file whenever you read it right
that's not possible my front end breaks
I can say what did you do my front and
build is breaking right that would be
great but doesn't happen today right too
good to be true but still let's try it
nothing wrong in trying right so let's
let's just try it
doesn't work let's see have a look at
the console like I hope if the console
log is legible to you it says that it
cannot bundle FS slash promises because
that is not compatible right that was
not a surprise for us you cannot use
load built-in modules or you cannot use
a database connection nothing you can
use it because browser doesn't support
it either you you polyfill the fs module
or you either don't use it right
okay so we know that doesn't work
what if we can make it work right
what if we can do some form of black
magic right and make this work
let's explore that back Magic
to make that black magic work I have
rightly aptly named folder called Magic
so let's explore some magic in it so
there are two files in it the first
magic that we'll be looking at is a
wheat plugin for now I'm just calling it
gecko plugin the folk in folks who are
playing valorent will get the reference
but yeah if not you should play Valerian
okay
we are calling test white gecko plugin
so don't get scared that we are trying
to write some plugin for wheat or this
can be done as a webpack plugin also
it's a very simple plugin okay so beat
plugin is a piece of code that you can
give wheat which is our bundler to tell
it to do things differently right now
wheat is being little stupid he's trying
to bundle our back-end code also with
front end which obviously doesn't work
right I need to tell him that you know
this is how you need to do for that I'm
creating a wheat plugin a wheat plugin
is a function that returns an object
right the object is the plugin that we
want to build and the object has a bunch
of property the first property name as
it says it's the name of the plugin
which is speed gecko plugin then the
second property called enforce tells v20
to run this plugin right pre means it
needs to run this plugin whenever before
it does pre-bundling right without that
this doesn't work so there are a bunch
of options I'm not going to explore
those options but enforce that does till
we went to run this plugin right and
then you can provide a bunch of
functions which we call it as Hooks and
wheat what does this hooks does is it
tells wheat whenever you're doing a
certain operation let me know I will
provide you with more more information
or I will tell you to do things
differently this resolve ID Hook is
called whenever wheat is trying to
resolve a file path that you're
importing let's just say you imported
fs.server.ts right
it needs to be dissolved into an
absolute path which would look like
front end slash FS slash server.ts we
know that if it tries to bundle that
file it's not going to work because it's
a backend file right what I'm going to
tell you it is okay if you find any file
which has server in its file name don't
bundle it rather I'm gonna provide you a
stuff use this tab called backend
proxy.ts which is the second magic which
we have in our magic folder backend
proxy.tf
okay so somewhere quickly summarizing we
are building a wheat plugin which is
telling wheat don't bundle any file with
server in its file name just use this
tab that I am providing which is
back-end proxy make sense now we have a
backend proxy.ts
and it's also not that complicated we're
just creating a new JavaScript proxy
JavaScript proxy is nothing but a
special object that provides you
trapdoor so that you can know whenever a
property was accessed on that proxy
object right for example if I create a
new proxy object let's just say FS that
I'm importing right if I do FS dot read
file I will get to know that the read
file was accessed on that particular
proxy object right to create a new proxy
just say new proxy provide the object on
which you want to place a trapdoor for
now I don't have any specific object in
mind so I'm just giving an empty object
and then I'm and then you provide the
trapdoor which should be called whenever
a property is accessed on this proxy
object and this trapdoor has a bunch of
functions that you can Define the
function that we are interested in is
the get function right the get function
is called whenever a property is
accessed on the proxy and it gives you
gives you a set of arguments like
property what was the property that was
accessed on the proxy object right now
what is happening is when you are
importing fs.server we are telling wheat
don't bundle the server file rather
bundle this proxy right now FS is
actually not your backend file but it is
rather a proxy when you do FS dot read
file in the proxy you are accessing that
read file property so this get function
would be called and will be getting this
property which is read file right so
when you import FS dot server FS becomes
the proxy and when you do dot read file
on proxy we will have this get function
executed which will tell us okay the
property read file was accessed in the
proxy object right for all the property
accessed I'm gonna always return a
function which is going to take a set of
arguments and then I'm gonna just for
now just console log it right console
log accessing property property from
proxy with a set of argument right so
summarizing it we are just rather than
bundling the server file we are saying
that I'm going to give you a default
proxy using the proxy I'm gonna get
information on what was the function
that you are trying to call on the back
end and what were the parameters that we
are trying to pass to the backend right
so let's try it out if it works I'm
gonna go to my front end go to the wheat
config and import this plugin
okay let's go back and see if it worked
okay the old error is gone but we do get
our console log right you see in our
console that you know beat is no more
trying to bundle the backend file rather
it is telling me that you are trying to
access the read file property on the
proxy with these set of parameters we
have another error which will fix soon
but now we have this information on the
front end that what was the backend file
you are trying to import and what was
the property that you are accessing on
the backend file and what were the
parameter that you are trying to pass
right with this I think we can achieve
what we wanted to do right what if I can
make a fetch call with this information
to the back end and execute the function
actually in the back right let's explore
that that is possible Right
so for that again to avoid too much
typing I'm going to do a little bit more
cheating I have created a scaffolded
Express server which has a single
endpoint right I'm going to call this
endpoint gecko okay does this bring back
any memory of graphql so similar to
graphql we're going to have only one
endpoint in our server which is going to
be called gecko okay now in the backend
proxy I'm gonna just hit the backend
with the information that I have right
I'm gonna make a fetch call
to
so I'm going to always use the post
method just like graphql and I'm going
to say headers
content type
is
application slash Json
I'm going to send the body which is
gonna I'm going to Json stringify the
body and the body I'm gonna set
information about what was the function
name that was being called which is
property and what was the function
params that were passed to my front end
right
I'm gonna say it's gonna be params right
let me get back the response
from my fetch call
and then get back the result
I'm going to assume that in the Json
response I'm getting the result is where
the result of the function is going to
be right and I'm going to just return
the result
okay now making a front-end call which
is an APA call to my backend now let's
handle the API call in my server again
right so I'm going to be hitting gecko
so I'm gonna get back the parameters
that was passed in the request.body
what are the parameters that we passed
it is nothing but function name
and function params
now it is super easy for me I can just
require my backend file which is in
front and Fs server.ts get the default
export from it get the function that I'm
trying to call and call it with the
function params I just got right I need
to just await it so that since it's an
async function and I'm going to get back
the result
and I'm gonna just say response.json the
result
just let us quickly check what we did in
the backend proxy with the information
that we just got from the front end that
the user was trying to call a function
on the back end which is read file with
a set of parameters I am making a fetch
request to the back end with the
function name is this and the parameters
of this
and we created a simple Express server
with a single endpoint which is Gecko
and I'm getting this information from
the front end and I'm just executing the
function in the back end right I'm hard
coding This Server file here but this
information can also be passed from the
front end and I can execute this
function in the back end itself right
in theory this should work so let let's
check if it worked but before that I
have to restart my server because we did
a bunch of stuff which needs to restart
so
let's check create the demo God and it
worked
and it worked
in theory you imported a function from
back end just like a file import and you
call that function
that's it you are done you didn't create
any API endpoints you know you backend
developer cannot screw you right
and tomorrow let's just say I want to
have a new function right let's just say
I want to say async log info
and it's going to take a message which
is string
you know it's tough typing in the stage
function yeah and I'm gonna
cancel log the message
and I need to not forget to
export it right
just say log info
hello from
ksconf
not config yeah so
quick question where do you think this
console log would come up
guesses
yeah
but just you broke myself right but
let's still open up the console and
reload there's no cancel log in the
browser we have the control log in the
back end
which actually means you are executing
your functions in the back end but you
are calling them as if they existed in
the same file on the same project from
the front end
right
I hope that clears things up
I guess it is it is time now I need to
give this magic some name I can't call
it black magic forever so let's rename
it the folder to the rightful name RPC
so what we did is nothing but a poor
man's version of remote procedure call
okay so there's a procedure in a remote
machine and you are trying to call that
procedure from another remote machine
which is your browser and both of them
feel like the function that you're
trying to call feels like it is in the
same machine or in the same browser but
it is not it is in a remote machine but
you have strong contracts because your
contract here is not an API endpoint
your contract here is a function
functions have very strong contracts and
with with the ID Integrations and type
checking we can ensure that you know
your backend developer can never screw
it right so
cool so
okay do you think this is new
I would say it's not new it's not novel
for example Java RPC has been there
before I born right I just checked in
the internet there is something called
Java RPC it's no more supported but this
concept of remote project call has been
existing for a very long time right
and there is grpc which I know that if
there are some front backend developers
here they might be thinking yeah yeah he
has stolen this from the back end we
already use grpc we already use protobuf
and for if you ask any back-end
developer how they how do they
communicate between two services in
backend they use grpc they don't use
HTTP because grpc provides them strong
contracts it's a very similar concept
you use functions as contrast contracts
you don't use endpoints as contracts
right I guess most of you would be aware
of bring stand stack blink it kind of
works on the similar concept they just
say there is a there's an RC RPC magic
inside it it's not really a magic it's
as simple as this behind the scene it's
this is what it is doing right and I
guess you folks would be aware of this
nexjs action that came in right you just
give an action in the front end but it
feels like like it exists in the front
end but it's being called in the server
right behind the scene react server
component actions in next 13 I guess
also uses RPC behind the scenes right
and then quick was the first one who
tried to introduce this into the front
end and I was planning the talk around
the same time and like quick already you
know broke broke the silence on the rpcs
right so it's more I would say that it
is not just limited to your day-to-day
AP endpoints you can use this in many
other places right I guess there was a
previous speaker who was talking about
we want to ensure type safe
communication between micro front ends
we can use rpcs for it right and a
microphone into microphone and
communication is nothing but an iframe
communication right or it could be a
communication from one webworker to
another web worker right it could be an
inter-process communication so in vs
code whenever you are running an
extension right the extension is run as
a separate node process so that it
doesn't hamper the performance of vs
code right when you create a style
process you need some form of
communication between them and that
communication should be in a type safe
way otherwise it cannot be maintained or
scaled over a long period of time and vs
code uses the same RPC for those
Communications right to term it right
this RPC is called Json RPC because you
are serializing your method calls into
Json sending your to another process and
executing in that and sending back
right and you can also use this for
websocket communications right I know we
have lot of web socket Communications
where we put arbitrary messages saying
that connected message and message
received those can get very very fast
right you can put this RPC into
websocket Communications and using
little bit more Plumbing work you can
have something like you are just calling
a method on the websocket channel and
you're getting response in real time
right
so I want to leave you folks with a
thought that you know next case
revolutionize this idea of you know
routes as file system why can't rest be
based on file system right what why
can't I just go today create another
file called you know
process.server.ts and I'm just importing
it right here the file system can always
follows unique file names and the
functions names can be always unique so
why should we keep on creating unique
API endpoints right when we know that
you know it is it is not fun to do right
why can't the file system be your API
endpoints right that's what I want you
to think about challenging the best
practices today
and that's it thank you folks
[Applause]
that was an amazing talk and we all I
think love your cat a lot now
yeah we are waiting for umlu's fan
account
so can we have a huge uh Round of
Applause for him he had a wonderful talk
and let me also tell you a fun fact
about him so he told me that he once had
a fist fight with someone who said that
something can't be built with JavaScript
so if you are someone who is
anti-javascript steer clear of him yeah
you know who to stay away from
that is how I think the the code of
conduct was built right right so we have
a bunch of talks here as well but I see
that a lot of people are standing so I
do see a lot of empty seats in the front
this side so if you want to grab a seat
feel free to come this side in the front
and we have a bunch of exciting talks
coming up but before that we'll take a
quick music break so I'll ask the audio
team to play some music and then we'll
get started with the next talk what are
we playing what's your favorite song I
think I would like to hear for Suri oh
just playing everywhere we have some
music
our next speaker will be just setting up
his get up till then
a quick fun fact about our next speaker
so our next speaker is also known as The
Undertaker Undertaker of Tech I I hope
I've said it right I'm not a big fan of
whatever that sport is who all were also
at react India
a raise of hand
who all were there at react India so I
hope you all remember the guy who had
the Undertaker entry so that's him
that's part and he's gonna be our next
speaker and there's one more fun fact
about him he's the youngest engineering
manager at 1mg so if you have any
questions regarding engineering manager
Rose you know who is the guy to contact
you
hahaha
let's call parth
so yeah our next speaker is parked and
we LED parth also give an introduction
to him and he wants to have a quick chat
with everyone so we're gonna give the
stage to parth
and I'll just give a quick introduction
of him as I already told you all he's
the youngest engineering manager at 1ng
and his talk is going to be around
vaccinate against third party
performance impact using party town so
I'm also quite excited for his talk
and park please tell us a little bit
about your experience as please join us
on the stage manager let's give him a
huge round of applause everyone
thank you so much so what do you guys
want to know
first of all hi everyone how is
everything everyone doing
awesome
let the seats fill in meanwhile if you
guys have any questions please go ahead
shoot
anything any any queries for uh you know
engineering manager any ranting to be
done
anything
tell me a quick thing that how many
among your uh among you
have uh you know this query wherein some
engineering manager or anyone from the
leadership is approaching you and
telling you that you know your web
performance is not good
try to improve that
if you really want to let's say
you know go ahead and really want to
prove yourself you have to uh you know
improve your web performance anyone can
I see some hands please
anyone interested in improving the web
performance
that's I can see some hands now
now what if I tell you that you could
improve your web performance by maybe 15
percent
probably 30 percent
if you are interested please raise your
hands
I can see some hands in 30 percent
and what if I tell you that not just 30
percent you can double your performance
or even more
are you guys interested for that
can I hear some noise
awesome awesome awesome
great so meanwhile we are setting out uh
I'll just give you a brief context at
how we reached here
so it's it's a quick story that uh we at
Tata 1mg are really obsessed with the
web performance right be it uh serving
to the end users and providing the best
experience in the healthcare
or let's say be it uh you know providing
the best user experience
and that is when we encounter this
problem
a very intriguing problem
uh we optimize our performance
still we can't hit that perfect 100
score
why is that
any guesses
anyone who might have faced a similar
issue
you do everything right you do code
splitting you optimize your JavaScript
code you do everything you do server
side rendering HTTP multiplexing so on
and so forth
but still you get a very laggy
performance
intrigued
so that's what we are going to cover
today
so hi everyone as you already know
uh I am parth Mahajan engineering
manager at Tata 1mg and I majorly work
at uh you know the performance and
improving the performance
so today uh we are going to talk about
vaccinating web performance
and create a vaccination against third
party requests
do you guys use let's say anything like
Google Analytics
uh probably Facebook pixel
critio Google tag manager all these
things
now all these scripts and sdks are
generally used by your analytics team
and the marketing team and they just
show up and come up and they say that
you know
maybe just this is a new SDK and you
have to integrate maybe this is a new
SDK for your payments this is a new SDK
for uh you know tracking something else
what impact does it have on your web
performance
let's have a look at it
but do you think that JavaScript can be
dangerous
yes probably
and what about uncontrolled third-party
Scripts
if you are not if you're JavaScript is
something you cannot control personally
your JavaScript is controlled by any
third-party company be it Facebook
Google or any other different company
can you actually just start
so before
you know getting into uh different sort
of scripts let's understand what exactly
is third party Scripts
are third party scripts equaling to
cross region
a lot of people might think like that
but that's not always the case
so for example over here we have you
know different assets for example
different sort of images JavaScript CSS
files
that will be coming on to my web page
right
from a different subdomain so that isn't
considered a third party even though
that's a cross domain
but at the same time you can have
analytics Facebook address on and so
forth
so that is exactly what we are looking
for
so this is something uh that we do at
1mg
we have 4.5 billion plus weekly requests
to handle
at that scale we cannot expect to have a
sluggish performance for the end user
each and every second each and every
millisecond matters
we have
Diagnostics we have Pharmacy we have
e-consults and we have a variety of tech
challenges to be solved on the
performance level
and we cannot just go wrong
so this is where
you know the problem really arises
wherein the third party starts to invade
and this is not something which is being
faced by just us
we observed that this particular issue
is being phased by each and every
company uh in the ecosystem
and why this is problematic
reason being it can block your main
thread completely
and basically interrupt in between
the processing of your main JavaScript
which you do not want
let's suppose that you ship an
e-commerce page
and you want to add any product to your
card right and you are not able to do
that the moment you do that the screen
is Frozen
why because analytics want to track
whether you have come on that page or
not
and again due to this there are so many
different network requests
and also it is very resource intensive
in terms of parsing and execution
and very likely you would see that when
these resources gets downloaded
the caching time on the browser is let's
say seven minutes five minutes ten
minutes
that's not ideal I don't want to Cache
my third party resources which would
change let's say after a quarter or so
in let's say five to seven minutes I
don't want that right
foreign
so
the question of the r
is there a vaccination yet
so meet Party Town
Party Town acts as a vaccination against
third party Scripts
wherein this is a library by builder.io
it helps you to run your third party
scripts on a parallel thread
right it could be a worker thread but if
this were so simple why we were not
doing it so far
what exactly is the issue
can we run each and everything
on a parallel thread on a worker thread
that we are doing on let's say the main
thread
so the issue arises when you start let's
say exploring uh or basically accessing
any native web library for example you
want to access window you want to access
the window size you want to access
whether the click has been done or not
anything like that cannot be accessed by
the worker thread directly you do not
have direct access on that
and also as we all know that JavaScript
is a single threaded language right
and by default everything in JavaScript
runs asynchronously
right so the kind of let's say we do
fetch requests they are asynchronous we
do promises those are asynchronous
then how do we make synchronous calls
from the worker thread to the main
thread
and if we don't do that so imagine what
could happen right you are clicking on a
button you are clicking on let's say add
to cart button and you go to the next
page and let's say it is an async task
and gets executed after just a second
and that event gets dragged on the wrong
page
you could lose the complete context
so you wanted synchronous
so how does this work
so as we have already seen that with
Party Town you have everything running
on your main thread each and every
source is competing for a single thread
and with party down
we have the complete uh you know
bifurcation between the main thread and
the worker
so let's code and before we uh get on
get on to the coding
a simple thing
so here is 1mg
loading on local right as you can see
that everything loads perfectly but the
moment I add any blocking script it
could be any third-party script any
analytic script
right and this is something that we are
doing without party town and you'll see
what kind of effect it has on a real
world application
now the moment I reload this page
you'll see what exactly happened
nothing gets clicked nothing is loading
because
the main thread is getting competed by
the third party script
this is something which we want to
mitigate
now let's get on to the code and try to
understand how exactly it is done
so it's relatively simple so let's say
that you have installed Party Town as a
package all you have to do next is add a
script
and the type of that script so let's
assume that you wanted to run Google
analytics in Party Town right so what
would you do
you would just add an additional
attribute that would be type and text
would be uh you know the type would be
text party down that's it
and the code would be running in a
parallel worker thread
right
so behind the scenes what party town
does is it's run the query selector
it sees that you know
wherever I am getting this particular
data attribute I'll execute all those uh
you know code Snippets in a worker
thread
also at the same time imagine let's say
you do not know you know at the build
time what exactly what kind of scripts
do you want and you need certain scripts
on the runtime for example let's assume
that when the user goes to a certain
page a YouTube scripts come in right and
you want to on the runtime dynamically
append these scripts and want them to be
executed in a worker
so that can also be done
so simply what you have to do is you
have to dispatch one custom event that
we put that would be put update
and basically fire your uh dynamically
appended JavaScript into that using that
so this way Party Town would know that
you know uh this JavaScript this piece
of code is also needed to be run in a
parallel thread
so this is how the communication works
so from the main thread there is a post
message to a service worker that's gets
installed on your domain for the party
town
and from the service worker we do a
synchronous xhr request
so the people who might have been
working in web for a very long time
would remember this that earlier browser
used to have this xhr request and this
used to be synchronous
but for the main thread browsers have
disabled it now
but it is still available on the service
worker and different workers
so what we are essentially doing is we
from the service worker we are telling
to the web worker that you know
stop your execution and make this code
execution synchronous
and then web workers does it you know
execution and then again post message is
sent back to the main thread so let's
see this in action
imagine that this is the code which you
wanted to be run on the worker
so it identifies that
window.location.href is a line for which
I'll need to access the worker thread
right because I do not have access to
window
so I will create a proxy
I will say that let me proxy the main
thread
and it will create something like this
and even in the Live code you will be
able to see that there are multiple
requests Network requests which go uh
you know as slash proxy town
now the main thread again sends a post
message and from there
you know the values are generated on the
main thread and sent back to the service
worker
and this is how exactly all these things
tie up in the end
most of the thing most of the execution
happens on the worker thread
just the communication bit
and the data sharing from the main
thread and the context sharing from the
main thread happens on the service
worker and the main set that's it
and let's now let's just see
the behavior
after we do the party tone
implementation
so all we are doing is we are just
adding a custom data type
now this is with Party Town
we are just gonna reload our page
and everything works everything is
loading
we can interact we can go on the next
page
and that script is running in the
background in our vocal thread
now how do we run this in production
now the issue with party down is party
town right now is in beta
right and it is generally recommended
not to use party down in production due
to certain use cases
so what we have done is we have created
a wrapper our custom library on top of
Party Town
and which is completely safe and we have
tested all the use cases and we are
serving currently so many different
users using this custom Library
so this is how it works
you install the party down
and you see whether the browser version
is supported or not
because the advanced service worker
communication or the atomics and shared
arable for communication that is done by
Party Town is not supported in all the
browsers
I'll be getting into uh so atomics and
shared array buffer in a while
so if let us say the browser version is
not supported I'll create a fallback and
that fallback will be solely responsible
for loading all the scripts as it were
if they were not loaded with party down
and similarly I'll check if the service
worker is supported in a particular
browser or not if yes then I'll add the
Party Town config otherwise I'll just go
on the fallback
now let's just get into the code
so here is the sample code
I'll be sharing uh this code in the end
over a QR so you can just scan it and
get this code
so it's a five layer process
in each step we ensure we have a check
and we we have a fallback in case
anything goes wrong
this is more like a simplified version
of what we have implemented on our
production
so in the step one we are simply
checking for the supported browsers
so we are checking uh the browser and we
are checking if it's greater than the
supported browser version
check if the service worker is present
so that's how we do this right and this
is the custom Party Town configuration
Library so let's say if you were to
share some context from the main thread
to the worker thread this is how you do
that so you say that you know data layer
dot push method I want it to be
accessible on my worker thread and
similarly data layer dot splice that
also needed is needed on the worker
thread
all right
followed by we we can also do one more
thing for the optimization
that we proxy our request which is going
to be the third third party and host
them internally for example you you were
to request uh GA right Google Analytics
so rather than requesting on the
Google's domain to avoid any sort of
course errors we can even host them
internally and
you know create a URL resolver
uh with the Party Town
and it will do the heavy lifting for you
and the fourth step would be that we
have embedded the party towns native
code itself in this library because we
do not want to make that extra Network
call
on the browser even for fetching the
Party Town service worker
so that's how we have done that and the
final step would be that simply adding
the script and offloading the body term
so that's how you do this
so anything goes wrong in this code base
there is a fallback that is mentioned
with it which is load analytics script
so you can you know if anything goes
wrong you can load the scripts in a
regular fashion
so next we have the results
how much do you think that we could have
actually achieved
with all these optimizations
any guesses
let's see for ourselves
so we could see a whopping 200 percent
Improvement
in our total blocking time
as you can see earlier the total
blocking time of the main thread was
near
1.2 seconds
which is now reduced to 570 milliseconds
so that is something which you can
achieve
with the help of party town and that is
right now when we haven't you know
offloaded all the scripts on the party
down we have just offloaded let's say 60
to 70 of the scripts there is still
scope for improvement
and now let's look at the amenity
booster that comes with atomics and
shared array buffer
so you can understand that you know all
this communication between main thread
and the service worker and from the
service worker back to the worker thread
and this is this is a complete uh you
know a big loop
and there is some cost Associated to it
so let us say if we were to you know do
some very precise analytical
optimizations
there could be some delays some events
could have been missed right
so for that atomics and shared array
buffer come into the picture
so this is something which we have
already seen
and let's focus on the third party
Scripts
in the third party scripts you can even
have let's say iframes or videos
there is a very typical use case wherein
you can have an embedded YouTube video
and as you scroll down and click on that
particular video there is an
advertisement running
but is that advertisement are those
scripts are these companies trustable
can they uh you know
take excess of your data
maybe let's say you are putting in any
credit card information at the time of
payment
and there is you know a marketing script
over there can it get access or hold on
to your credit card details
so can
YouTube and Facebook really steal your
data
let's
have a look
hopefully not because we use same origin
policy
so the browsers same origin policy
ensure that
each and every uh script that is getting
executed from the third party is
particularly Allowed by that particular
domain by that particular vendor
so that's what is meant by same origin
that let's say if you were requesting
from 1mg.com then either 1mg.com has
explicitly allowed all these origins or
they are they belong to the same origin
until specter
not this one
this one though
anyone has heard about meltdown or
specter
I can see a few hands
so this is a vulnerability which Chrome
announced back in 2018
so these were two attacks which took the
web Community by storm
this actually proved that let's say
there is a malicious site running on a
tab
and your uh you are let's say adding
your credit card details on another one
it can get access to your personal
details and how does that happen
accuse higher Precision timers
and speculative execution
so what happens is these days
even browsers are in a competition
so they want to optimize how the CPUs
work
they want to optimize each and
everything of the CPU and give you fast
results
so there is a cache in the CPU
and let's say you were to run a for loop
from 0 to 1000
and the value of your indicator is
beyond 1000. the CPU would assume that
the value would be within the limit and
start executing your code
that's how speculative execution works
right and then later when it realizes
that you know this is not the correct uh
what do you say correct value by the
indicator
it falls back but there is a time for it
so that is where Precision timers come
into the picture
each and every
each and every record of these timers
each and every micro second can be
recorded and can be
you know again traced back the pawn to
see whether this result is coming from
the cache or this result is going back
and fetched from the memory
so what did browsers do
so browsers basically
completely did two things one they
changed their architecture
and second they disabled powerful
features like shared array buffer and
the features which used High position
timers
in the new architecture what they did
was
that rather than you know
other tabs or other processes being able
to get access to your memory
let's have a completely separate
a completely separate I would say
workspace for this process right so this
process would individually have
its own memory and its own CPU
but again we cannot be dependent upon
the browser's architecture because
Chrome went ahead and implemented it
then Firefox followed but still is in
process of implementing that so there
needs to be some standardization
among the browsers so that is where site
isolation came into the picture
so what do we mean by side isolation
by site isolation we essentially mean
that we are isolating our website right
and we are allowing particular domains
to have access over our memory
and our CPU
but why to get into all this hustle why
do I need let's say atomics or shared
array buffer
so this enables us to have 10x faster
Communications between the threads
because now what I have done is I have
eliminated the service worker completely
from the picture
now anything the main thread which is
storing on let's say your memory the
worker thread can access that memory
using shared array buffer and the
library which is called atomics on top
of that
and also there would be no network
request from proxy town
and again one lesser request for the
service worker as well
this is how you enable this
there are two headers which you have to
enable in your document response
one is cross origin embedded policy
and second is cross origin opener policy
by this we say that
only the domains which I personally
allow can have the excess
to my resources
and also let us say that you are having
your own personal assets
from different subdomains which we
generally have
so for
allowing those assets what you can do is
you can add an attribute called cross
region
and wherein you do not have access
directly onto these assets you can have
a response header which says cross
origin policy for that particular asset
is also set to cross a region that means
that asset is supporting the latest
cross origin isolation
now here is the browser support for the
same
and now before I wrap up
there is a quick quote
unleash the web performance and defy the
limitations of third-party Scripts
with Party Town you can actually do that
and this is the quotation not by me
I took the help of charge apt
as far as the code goes
if you want to have access over the code
you can scan this QR or take a picture
of it
and you will get the optimized code
which you can actually genuinely run on
your production applications
now a big round of applause for our real
life Heroes who have actually
implemented went ahead and really delve
into it wherein this was a very
latest thing that has come in the
industry and we have pioneered that
so big round of applause for all the
developers who have worked on that
thank you so much this was my time
thanks everyone thank you
for any questions for anything else you
can meet me outside I am more than happy
to answer the questions try I left like
otherwise I love the company culture
yeah yeah
it was the other Mike and kushboo's
outside but
thank you so much PA that was an amazing
session and yeah as part mentioned you
can reach out to him if you have any
questions because we are running early
we will be having a pretty big coffee
break now so please go out network with
folks there uh there's all Publishers
also having and hiring uh challenge
right now so make sure you go out with
some offers if you don't have one kindly
and have a great time see you see you
back here in some time till then yeah
have enjoy your coffee thank you
what if digital could help your
organization change the world for the
better better Technologies better
experiences better tomorrows we're
publicist Sapient a global digital
business transformation partner helping
organizations improve lives through
digital elevating experiences optimizing
data and Reinventing products all to
create a better tomorrow for who matters
most everyone
publicist Sapient
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
we just need to understand the data
see the proof
know what works call that being
particular we call it being precise
we don't want head scratching gaps
guesses assumptions or opinions We crave
insights and Answers born from data
we're Engineers who love how having all
of our Telemetry metrics events logs and
traces cuts through the crosstalk
separate signal from noise
fact from opinion
it's not data for Shell it's data that
shows because it saves us time settles
debate cancels meetings before they even
start and says hey look over here this
is the problem when Dev Ops security and
business teams come together around data
it washes away the doubt it reveals the
connections we all know are there the
threats that point to the path forward
and what will really work
this is data for engineers
[Music]
the visual editor is the heart of
storyblock
the intuitive user interface allows you
to manage your content simply by
browsing your website
by clicking on a component in your live
preview the configuration appears on the
right hand side
you can jump to multiple components and
drag and drop your content wherever you
prefer
to add and change the layout of your
content
rearranging text or optimizing and
adding new images is as easy as it can
be
creating great content is a team effort
storyblock makes it easy for all teams
to collaborate in real time within the
visual editor
once you're finished editing you can
either start a feedback loop with a
custom publishing workflow
or publish instantly users create
content and go to market faster with
storyblocks visual editor
try for free at storyblock.com
tired of missing out on event photos
with pre-magic those days are gone just
scan the QR code snap a selfie and let
the AI work its magic instantly access
event photos through a link sent via
email and WhatsApp but that's not all
boost event sponsors Roi and visibility
with our in gallery placements
supercharger event experiences with free
Magic's real-time photo distribution
pre-magic your memories delivered in
real time
what if digital could help your
organization change the world for the
better better Technologies better
experiences better tomorrows we're
publicist Sapient a global digital
business transformation partner helping
organizations improve lives through
digital elevating experiences optimizing
data and Reinventing products all to
create a better tomorrow for who matters
most everyone
Publis is sapient
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
la la
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
we just need to understand the data
see the proof
know what works
call that being particular we call it
being precise
we don't want head scratching gaps
guesses assumptions or opinions We crave
insights and Answers born from data
we're Engineers who love how having all
of our Telemetry metrics events logs and
traces cuts through the crosstalk
separate signal from noise
fact from opinion
it's not data for show it's data that
shows because it saves us time settles
debate cancels meetings before they even
start and says hey look over here this
is the problem when Dev Ops security and
business teams come together around data
it washes away the doubt it reveals the
connections we all know are there the
threads that point to the path forward
and what will really work
this is data for engineers
[Music]
the visual editor is the heart of
storyblock
the intuitive user interface allows you
to manage your content simply by
browsing your website
by clicking on a component in your live
preview the configuration appears on the
right hand side
you can jump to multiple components and
drag and drop your content wherever you
prefer
to add and change the layout of your
content
rearranging text or optimizing and
adding new images is as easy as it can
be
creating great content is a team effort
storyblock makes it easy for all teams
to collaborate in real time within the
visual editor
once you're finished editing you can
either start a feedback loop with a
custom publishing workflow
or publish instantly users create
content and go to market faster with
storyblocks visual editor
try for free at storyblock.com
with pre-magic those days are gone just
scan the QR code snap a selfie and let
the AI work its magic instantly access
event photos through a link sent via
email and WhatsApp but that's not all
boost event sponsors Roi and visibility
with our in gallery placements
supercharge your event experiences with
three Magics real-time photo
distribution pre-magic your memories
delivered in real time
what if digital could help your
organization change the world for the
better better Technologies better
experiences better tomorrows we're
publicist Sapient a global digital
business transformation partner helping
organizations improve lives through
digital elevating experiences optimizing
data and Reinventing products all to
create a better tomorrow for who matters
most everyone
poopless is sapient
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
we just need to understand the data
see the proof
know what works call that being
particular we call it being precise
we don't want head scratching gaps
guesses assumptions or opinions We crave
insights and Answers born from data
we're Engineers who love how having all
of our Telemetry metrics events logs and
traces cuts through the crosstalk
separate signal from noise
fact from opinion
it's not data for Shell it's data that
shows because it saves us time settles
debate cancels meetings before they even
start and says hey look over here this
is the problem when Dev Ops security and
business teams come together around data
it washes away the doubt it reveals the
connections we all know are there the
threads that point to the path forward
and what will really work
this is data for engineers
[Music]
the visual editor is the heart of
storyblock
the intuitive user interface allows you
to manage your content simply by
browsing your website
by clicking on a component in your live
preview the configuration appears on the
right hand side
you can jump to multiple components and
drag and drop your content wherever you
prefer
able to add and change the layout of
your content
rearranging text or optimizing and
adding new images is as easy as it can
be
creating great content is a team effort
storyblock makes it easy for all teams
to collaborate in real time within the
visual editor
once you're finished editing you can
either start a feedback loop with a
custom publishing workflow
or publish instantly users create
content and go to market faster with
storyblocks visual editor
try for free at storyblock.com
tired of missing out on event photos
with pre-magic those days are good just
scan the QR code snap a selfie and let
the AI work its magic instantly access
event photos through a link sent via
email and WhatsApp but that's not all
boost event sponsors Roi and visibility
with our in gallery placements
supercharge your event experiences with
three Magics real-time photo
distribution pre-magic your memories
delivered in real time
what if digital could help your
organization change the world for the
better better Technologies better
experiences better tomorrows we're
publicist Sapient a global digital
business transformation partner helping
organizations improve lives through
digital elevating experiences optimizing
data and Reinventing products all to
create a better tomorrow for who matters
most everyone
publishes Sapient
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
we just need to understand the data
see the proof know what works call that
being particular we call it being
precise
we don't want head scratching gaps
guesses assumptions or opinions We crave
insights and Answers born from data
we're Engineers who love how having all
of our Telemetry metrics events logs and
traces cuts through the crosstalk
separate signal from noise
fact from opinion
it's not data for show it's data that
shows because it saves us time settles
debate cancels meetings before they even
start and says hey look over here this
is the problem when Dev Ops security and
business teams come together around data
it washes away the doubt it reveals the
connections we all know are there the
threads that point to the path forward
and what will really work
this is data for engineers
[Music]
the visual editor is the heart of
storyblock
the intuitive user interface allows you
to manage your content simply by
browsing your website
by clicking on a component in your live
preview the configuration appears on the
right hand side
you can jump to multiple components and
drag and drop your content wherever you
prefer
to add and change the layout of your
content
rearranging text or optimizing and
adding new images is as easy as it can
be
creating great content is a team effort
storyblock makes it easy for all teams
to collaborate in real time within the
visual editor
once you're finished editing you can
either start a feedback loop with a
custom publishing workflow
or publish instantly users create
content and go to market faster with
storyblocks visual editor
try for free at storyblock.com
missing out on event photos with
pre-magic those days are gone just scan
the QR code snap a selfie and let the AI
work its magic instantly access event
photos through a link sent via email and
WhatsApp but that's not all boost event
sponsors Roi and visibility with our in
gallery placements supercharge your
event experiences the three Magics
real-time photo distribution pre-magic
your memories delivered in real time
what if digital could help your
organization change the world for the
better better Technologies better
experiences better tomorrows we're
publicist Sapient a global digital
business transformation partner helping
organizations improve lives through
digital elevating experiences optimizing
data and Reinventing products all to
create a better tomorrow for who matters
most everyone
poopless is sapient
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
we just need to understand the data
see the proof
know what works
called that being particular
we call it being precise
we don't want head scratching gaps
guesses assumptions or opinions We crave
insights and Answers born from data
we're Engineers who love how having all
of our Telemetry metrics events logs and
traces cuts through the crosstalk
separate signal from noise
fact from opinion
it's not data for show it's data that
shows because it saves us time settles
debate cancels meetings before they even
start and says hey look over here this
is the problem when Dev Ops security and
business teams come together around data
it washes away the doubt it reveals the
connections we all know are there the
threads that point to the path forward
and what will really work
this is data for engineers
[Music]
the visual editor is the heart of
storyblock
the intuitive user interface allows you
to manage your content simply by
browsing your website
by clicking on a component in your live
preview the configuration appears on the
right hand side
you can jump to multiple components and
drag and drop your content wherever you
prefer
to add and change the layout of your
content
rearranging text or optimizing and
adding new images is as easy as it can
be
creating great content is a team effort
storyblock makes it easy for all teams
to collaborate in real time within the
visual editor
once you're finished editing you can
either start a feedback loop with a
custom publishing workflow
or publish instantly users create
content and go to market faster with
storyblocks visual editor
try for free at storyblock.com
tired of missing out on event photos
with pre-magic those days are gone just
scan the QR code snap a selfie and let
the AI work its magic instantly access
event photos through a link sent via
email and WhatsApp but that's not all
boost event sponsors Roi and visibility
Buddha in gallery placements supercharge
your event experiences with free Magic's
real-time photo distribution pre-magic
your memories delivered in real time
what if digital could help your
organization change the world for the
better better Technologies better
experiences better tomorrows we're
publicist Sapient a global digital
business transformation partner helping
organizations improve lives through
digital elevating experiences optimizing
data and Reinventing products all to
create a better tomorrow for who matters
most everyone
poopless is sapient
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
we just need to understand the data
see the proof
know what works call that being
particular we call it being precise
we don't want head scratching gaps
guesses assumptions or opinions We crave
insights and Answers born from data
we're Engineers who love how having all
of our Telemetry metrics events logs and
traces cuts through the crosstalk
separate signal from noise
fact from opinion
it's not data for show it's data that
shows because it saves us time settles
debate cancels meetings before they even
start and says hey look over here this
is the problem when Dev Ops security and
business teams come together around data
it washes away the doubt it reveals the
connections we all know are there the
threads that point to the path forward
and what will really work
this is data for engineers
[Music]
the visual editor is the heart of
storyblock
the intuitive user interface allows you
to manage your content simply by
browsing your website
by clicking on a component in your live
preview the configuration appears on the
right hand side
you can jump to multiple components and
drag and drop your content wherever you
prefer
to add and change the layout of your
content
rearranging text or optimizing and
adding new images is as easy as it can
be
creating great content is a team effort
storyblock makes it easy for all teams
to collaborate in real time within the
visual editor
once you're finished editing you can
either start a feedback loop with a
custom publishing workflow
or publish instantly users create
content and go to market faster with
storyblocks visual editor
try for free at storyblock.com
with pre-magic those days are gone just
scan the QR code snap a selfie and let
the AI work its magic instantly access
event photos through a link sent via
email and WhatsApp but that's not all
boost event sponsors Roi and visibility
with our in gallery placements
supercharge your event experiences with
three Magics real-time photo
distribution pre-magic your memories
delivered in real time
what if digital could help your
organization change the world for the
better better Technologies better
experiences better tomorrows we're
publicist Sapient a global digital
business transformation partner helping
organizations improve lives through
digital elevating experiences optimizing
data and Reinventing products all to
create a better tomorrow for who matters
most everyone
poopless is sapient
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
we just need to understand the data
see the proof
know what works call that being
particular we call it being precise
we don't want head scratching gaps
guesses assumptions or opinions We crave
insights and Answers born from data
we're Engineers who love how having all
of our Telemetry metrics events logs and
traces cuts through the crosstalk
separate signal from noise
fact from opinion
it's not data for Shell it's data that
shows because it saves us time settles
debate cancels meetings before they even
start and says hey look over here this
is the problem when Dev Ops security and
business teams come together around data
it washes away the doubt it reveals the
connections we all know are there the
threads that point to the path forward
and what will really work
this is data for engineers
[Music]
the visual editor is the heart of
storyblock
the intuitive user interface allows you
to manage your content simply by
browsing your website
by clicking on a component in your live
preview the configuration appears on the
right hand side
you can jump to multiple components and
drag and drop your content wherever you
prefer
to add and change the layout of your
content
rearranging text or optimizing and
adding new images is as easy as it can
be
creating great content is a team effort
storyblock makes it easy for all teams
to collaborate in real time within the
visual editor
once you're finished editing you can
either start a feedback loop with a
custom publishing workflow
or publish instantly users create
content and go to market faster with
storyblocks visual editor
try for free at storyblock.com
tired of missing out on event photos
with pre-magic those days are gone just
scan the QR code snap a selfie and let
the AI work its magic instantly access
event photos through a link sent via
email and WhatsApp but that's not all
boost event sponsors Roi and visibility
with our in gallery placements
supercharge your event experiences with
free Magic's real-time photo
distribution pre-magic your memories
delivered in real time
what if digital could help your
organization change the world for the
better better Technologies better
experiences better tomorrows we're
publicist Sapient a global digital
business transformation partner helping
organizations improve lives through
digital elevating experiences optimizing
data and Reinventing products all to
create a better tomorrow for who matters
most everyone
poopless is sapient
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
with our next session so we have a very
special guest with us he has a session
on pushing the limits of video encoding
in browsers with web codecs and we have
with us
akashya he's a software engineer at
Razer pay please join us
he was Round of Applause from this side
as well
cool so he told me a fun fact about him
that he's a force Enthusiast and one of
his GitHub repositories have 1.9 K Stars
so you might want to check that out he
also told me that there's usually a role
at hackathons that you can't win in two
subsequent editions but he was the only
exception who actually won into other
subsequent editions because this project
was so good so I'm pretty sure that the
talk is going to be amazing as well
let's give him a huge round of applause
and get get started
laughs
okay
um yeah I see a lot of seats empty which
is kind of sad
uh yeah just give everyone a call bring
them here uh nobody should miss my talk
even though the stock in the main stage
might be good
but yeah
but yeah I'm really happy to be here
it's the first in-person edition of JS
Con in India and that's a huge thing I I
aren't you guys excited
I I want it a bit more louder
[Applause]
nice okay so uh welcome to my talk on
pushing the limits of video encoding in
browsers with web codex my name is
Akasha mirvasya I work as a software
engineer at Razer pay I love building a
lot of products on the web and learning
new technologies and contributing to
open source you might know me from some
of my projects Blaze on top diodes
slanted if you don't know about these
projects well you have missed out a lot
you you are probably living under a rock
you should try them out
you can connect with me on my Twitter
GitHub I'm at blender school over there
if you want to know where this handle
comes from there's a long story behind
that I have a website where I talk about
myself.com
so before we get into web codex let's
start with a little backstory
so a while back I was building a video
editor on the browser to make catchy
product videos I have a lot of projects
and I want to present them uh in a
really catchy way on my social platforms
and I looked at various video editing
softwares Adobe Premiere Cinema 4D
blender those are Hefty softwares that
you have to download you have to learn
how to use them also yeah it's uh it's a
very time consuming process so I wanted
to build a very small video editing tool
that would make my job as creating
product videos much faster
now everything was going fine until I
started writing the code for the final
export process which is the most
important part of a video editor
I got stuck at a bunch of places video
formats codecs and codivers muxing
containers does anyone know what all of
these mean
no one or there are a few hands yeah
it's a good thing nobody knows about
this because that's what the talk is
about
but eventually I was able to finally
figure everything out the entire export
process and I want to share this journey
with you all the learnings I had in this
journey
let's start the discussion by
understanding how to draw something like
a video on the web today
video can be simply defined as a set of
image frames that are changing at a
constant rate
and each frame of this video can be
rendered in a variety of ways you can
use CSS animation to render something
like a video
you can modify Dom directly with
JavaScript you can you know set interval
and modify the Dom at every interval it
might be performance intensive but hey
it's still something that's changing at
a constant rate
you can use svgs this is what Lottie
files use under the hood to render the
Lottie animations on the browser
or you can use something called the
HTML5 canvas this HTML5 canvas is a bit
verbose in its API but it's very
powerful you can do a lot with it and I
suggest you if you are building
something like video editor image editor
or anything that is really complex you
should definitely take a look at HTML5
canvas there are a lot of things that
you can do with it and canvas is what
makes most of the apis possible in the
stock
so once when we have rendered the frames
of the video the next step is simply
recording those frames and saving it as
a video file right that sounds easy on
the slide but how do you record
something on screen using JavaScript
now the reason I mentioned canvas is
because canvas allows video capture
already
this is made possible through its
capture stream API which is a part of
the media stream recording API standard
this is some code around this idea where
I Define a function called record
it you know basically takes in one
parameter duration which is the duration
of the video I want to record from the
canvas then I call capture stream on the
canvas past the frame rate which is 30
in this case and that stream I pass to
the media recorder Constructor to create
a recorder object this recorder is what
we can start stop to record the actual
video from the canvas
before we can get started with started
with recording we need to attach to
event listeners first one is data
available so whenever the recorder has
some data about the video available we
can do something with the data in this
case I'm just pushing the data inside an
array called chunks we'll process it
later
and the second event is the stop event
list now this event is called when the
recorder has stopped and we can process
all the accumulated chunks convert it
into a single blob file and download it
on the user's device
once the event listeners are attached
it's simply a matter of starting the
recorder stopping the recorder after the
duration has elapsed really simple code
I really hope this was this simple but
this entire approach it's not really
well suited for this use case uh there
are four reasons to it the first one is
this approach of using capture stream it
does not give you constant frame rate
capture stream takes one parameter which
is frame rate but if you dig under the
hood it's actually the maximum frame
rate that the browser will capture the
frames in so if the browser realizes
that the device's performance is not
enough to render the actual frames it'll
start dropping frames so that the
performance can be improved
there's no option to change the video
file format you're stuck with the webm
file format and I'm not sure if you're a
video editor have you have worked with
webm files before that's not really a
standard file format right
the third problem is low reliability so
capture stream since there's a cap on
the frame rate the browser might decide
even if you mention 30 FPS browser might
decide to record in one FPS and let's
say I have a Macbook here it will record
in 30 but if you have a potato it might
record in 0 FPS so totally low
reliability same code won't give you
same output in two different machines
and the quality is also okay nothing
great it's you know left on the browser
as well
now it might look like I'm bashing the
media recording apis here but honestly
they are not designed to be used for
such precise and high quality video
exports media recording apis are better
suited for transmitting videos in
real-time applications where trade-off
of quality is acceptable when you're
getting higher speeds
so if capture stream cannot work
can we capture and encode each frame of
the canvas ourselves
here's some pseudocode around that idea
so what I do is uh there's a variable
called frame that basically stores the
frame that I'm rendering right now and
for every frame in my animation I'll
render that frame in the canvas capture
it as an image and do some processing
with it so let's go step by step so I
first
render the frame one on the canvas
then I capture that as an image using
the two data URL function that canvas
has and I store that image in the images
array that I have defined
then the next iteration of the loop runs
I see to frame two I capture the frame
as an image I push it in the array I
keep doing this for all the frames that
are there in the video that I want to
capture
once the loop is complete I come out and
I call a function called encode which
takes in the images array and yeah gives
me the final video and I can download
that video
again this is very high level code how
do you actually Define that encode
function which encodes an array of
images to a video
now this is a very hard problem to solve
because till now browsers never had a
way to actually uh take an array of
images and encode them to a single video
file there was never a standard design
for this
there are various implementations in
JavaScript that allow you to do
something like this and at this point I
would like to mention a library called
vami JS vami is a real-time JavaScript
webm encoder
it appeared on Hacker News 11 years ago
I guess most of you were in school
studying algebra at that time when this
library was launched so it's it's very
old at this point but the idea of Whammy
is it takes these snapshots of your
canvas as images and encodes them to a
video file which is essentially what we
are trying to do so if we look at the
encode function that I defined that I'm
calling in the previous slide this is
how it would look like whammy has a from
image array function which we can call
pass in the images data tell it the
frame rate and it'll give you the final
video file that you can download on the
user's device
you can check out vami at this URL
now I tried a lot of these JS libraries
some vasm solutions as well and I
realized that all of them share the same
set of pros and cons
the first pro is you get high quality
output compared to capture stream
because we are manually seeking to every
frame drawing that frame capturing the
frame as an image then converting
everything to a video there's no place
of dropping frames or quality loss you
get really high quality output
you get constant frame rate because we
are manually controlling in our code how
every frame gets rendered and captured
and the entire code is relatively easy
as long as you have a library that can
do the encoding process from an array of
images the overall code was really
simple to understand
that's the only Pro in this approach now
welcome to the cons the list is huge
which is kind of sad
so the first one is the entire process
is very slow and this is because the
apis that we just used are synchronous
the two data URL that we are using to
capture the canvas as an image that is
really performance intensive and when
you run it in a loop for thousands of
frames of a video
a simple video can take a long time to
actually render
there's no Hardware acceleration so even
if your device supports some Hardware
acceleration for faster encoding
decoding these JavaScript libraries
simply can't tap into those
optimizations you're stuck with
execution on the CPU
there's no choice of video formats
you're stuck with the webm file format
and there's no support for adding audio
to
now what
at this point I felt like I've come at a
dead end there's you know I tried a lot
of approaches a lot of solutions nothing
was working I'd almost given up
but after some time I realized that
there's this interesting new standard
that has appeared on the browsers and
nobody has been talking about it enough
there's very little documentation online
about it and I hope this talk actually
fills in that Gap and this interesting
new standard is drum roll there's no
drum roll that's the talk about it's web
codex
so what is web codex
web codecs are a set of API that give
you low level access to individual
frames of a video
once you have the access to these frames
you can do the encoding decoding process
at the frame level of a video stream in
various formats
the nice thing about web codex is
because it's a native you know web
feature it's asynchronous and Hardware
accelerated so any optimizations on your
Hardware web codecs will make it
available to your code
and the apis I've asked it supports more
than just video you can also encode
decode audio too but in this talk I'll
only be focused on encoding videos
now the other day I was looking at the
web codex article on mdn this is the
first paragraph of the article
and I'm not sure if you noticed there's
a part in this article that got me
really excited when I went through it
it's actually this bit
so what the article basically says is
that web codex gives you low level
access to individual frames and it might
be useful to build applications such as
video or audio editors that's exactly
what I'm building right so I felt really
excited when I saw this it felt like I'm
finally in the right direction and this
is the thing that I was looking for
before diving into code let's look at
the video encoding process in web codecs
at a very high level
so the encoding process is divided into
divided into three parts the first part
is actually defining your input source
yeah my formatting is messed up I guess
just the cons of building your slides
using JavaScript uh but yeah you define
your input source using canvas image
bitmap or media stream track so that
that's also the reason I suggested you
to use canvas because rendering frames
in a canvas is very easy image bitmap
and media stream tracks are a bit more
lower level once you have your input
source ready you can pass that to a
video frame you can create a video frame
out of your input source pass that to
the video encoder that we create
video encoder takes in a bunch of video
frames together converts it into a
single encoded video chunk and then you
can do a lot of things with that encoded
video chunk you can transmit it over
store transmit it over Network for
real-time applications or store it
somewhere and do very crazy things with
it but in this talk again I'll be
focused on the storage aspect because we
are encoding a video end to end
so let's finally look at some code to
encode videos using web codecs
the entire process starts by creating a
video encoder so video encoder is
created using the video encoder
Constructor it takes in two callbacks
the first one is output this is called
whenever the encoder has some encoded
chunk ready for you to do something with
and the second callback is the error
callback so if anything goes wrong this
is where you handle the error
so uh for this uh you know
implementation where I'm actually
encoding in video to a file what I need
to do is I need to store all the encoded
chunks in in an array and I'll process
it later so I Define a chunks array and
inside the output callback I simply push
that chunk chunk is basically an array
buffer you won't understand it it's just
ones and zeros but it's basically the
encoded video data so I'm just pushing
this inside the chunk sorry
and so when some error happens I just
console log yeah this is the production
code that you should write
um once you have the video encoder ready
the next step is actually configuring
this video encoder and this is the
important bit
so creating the video encoder is the
first part configuring is where you tell
it what format you want to use what are
the frame rate that you want to use and
various other options we'll go through
some of the options over here
the first one is codec it's set to vp8
I'll come to it in a bit there's a you
know huge part of the talk which is
dedicated to codec second is Hardware
acceleration you can specify whether you
want to use Hardware acceleration prefer
Hardware will give a hint to the browser
whether if Hardware acceleration is
supported try using the hardware
acceleration frame rate is well the
frame rate latency mode so if you are
building a real-time application where
again you can you know have a trade-off
with quality but you want higher speeds
you can set latency mode to real time
then you'll get the encoded video chunks
much faster but there might be some
compromise in the quality
width height bit rate these are standard
parameters now out of all of these
options the most important one is
actually the codec the first option here
how do you find the right codec
it's not as easy as webm MP4 Avi and
various other file formats if you look
at a codec string this is how it looks
like
see they are random right do you
understand what AVC
1.420034 mean
there's a huge document about every
single number in that string and I won't
be going deep into it but the main
takeaway you should have from this slide
is that video Codec is not the same as
video file format and this got me
confused a lot I thought codec is simply
a fancy in a professional way of saying
what the file format is if I'm building
an mp4 file the codec should be MP4 but
no they are completely different and to
understand how different it is let me
give you a 101 on video encoding
so the entire video encoding process
starts with individual frames of a video
you can think of these as image data
frame one two three
all of them are passed to what's called
an encoding algorithm
the job of the encoding algorithm is to
take all the Frame data compress them
convert them and store them in a single
video stream
and this encoding algorithm
is what is called a codec
the output of a codec is a video stream
video stream contains your original
Frame data and this video stream is not
the thing that you see on your hard disk
there are still few more steps left
with the video stream it's passed
towards pass through what's called a
muxer
the job of the muxer is to take a stream
and put it inside a container in this
case I've taken the video stream and put
it inside the MP4 container and this
container is what you see on your hard
disk the video. MP4 that has a video
stream inside it that video stream has
the individual Frame data
now you might wonder what's the job of
the mug serial can't the muxer also do
the con the encoder also do the same
thing that the muxa does
well that is because videos on are not
just visual data right
there can be audios there can be
subtitles and have you ever wondered how
a single file has all of this data well
that's the magic of muxer it takes in
multiple data streams video audio
subtitles combines them multiplexes them
into a single container into a single
file
so here you can see video stream audio
subtitles everything in a single file
let's come back to a codec
so
by the way the battery is running low
over there in case
so uh so codec so codec is an encoding
algorithm again to convert compress the
individual frames of the video
a codec and a container must be
compatible with each other so if you
have a codec that you're using to encode
MP4 videos the container is MP4 but your
codec should also be compatible with the
MP4 code container to be used so this is
a you know a small table which goes over
common containers and codecs so if you
are you know creating an mp4 file which
is quite common you need to use the AVC
or av1 codec ABC is Advanced video
coding I never knew that before if
you're using webm container you have to
use vp8 codec the example strings that
I've mentioned those are actually the
strings that you need to pass to the
codec option in the configure function
so these are the strings that you can
use if you want to use that particular
codec
now to make this even more challenging
every browser suppose different set of
codecs so if this browser supports let's
say the av1 codec some other browser
might not support that codec at all
uh now I won't dive deep into what the
Codex you know the numbers and in those
codec strings mean
um I've left two links over here uh they
are you know a lot of information to
digest but yeah it has all the
information you need about codec
compatibility across browsers
um and what the numbers in those codecs
mean it's a deep rabbit hole
coming back to the code
so this is the same configure I've just
changed the codec to AVC one I want to
use this codec to encode an mp4 file and
since I'm using the AVC codec I have an
option to actually pass some options to
this codec itself so I'm setting AVC and
the format of the video processing to
Annex B I won't dive deep into what
Annex b means
it's just the professional way of saying
I don't know what it means as well
so
yeah this is again you have a lot of
options the next step is so as I
mentioned that web codec certain codecs
might not be supported in certain
browsers right so video encoder has a
function called is config supported
which you can call with the config and
it will tell you whether this browser
supports that config or not so you can
pass in the config data it'll give you
whether this codec is supported on the
browser if it's not supported you can
just tell them this message or fall back
to another codec
if the codec is supported you can call
the configure and pass that config
and this actually creates the video
encoder in this whole process that we
had
the next part
we again write the same Loop that we
just saw in the starting of the stock so
we go through every frame of the
animation render that on the canvas and
once we have rendered a frame on the
canvas to convert that to a video frame
just call the video frame Constructor
pass in canvas if you have other sources
image bitmap media stream track array
buffers you can pass any kind of data to
video frame to create the video frame
object this also takes a lot of options
but we need to only pass timestamp which
is the most important one timestamp
tells which at what time this Frame
shows up in your video so I just do some
math yeah I didn't use star GPD for this
so I just do some math frame divided by
frame rate multiplying it by million
because this property is actually in
microseconds
and then you just simply pass this video
frame to the encoder using the encode
function and close the video frame
because our job is done
and
that's the entire actual encoding Loop
this you know runs for every frame in
the uh video and passes it to the
encoder uh every frame that we have
once the loop is complete we can come
out uh we can call the flush function on
encoder because again these apis are
asynchronous so once you are done with
the encoding process you need to call
flush to indicate that whatever data is
spending to be processed just process
them and yeah convert them to encoded
video chunks and since the job of
encoder is done I can close it and the
next step here so remember I had
attached an output callback to the video
encoder that was pushing data to the
chunks array
now we can actually use all the data and
do something with it
chunks is actually an array of array
buffers as I mentioned and in this type
I actually concatenate or flatten that
array to a single array buffer there are
various algorithms online that you can
refer to do this it's a very simple
process and yeah this basically just
converts an array of array buffers to a
single item buffer
so once we have the video buffer the
next logical step would be to Simply
download that video buffer right
now
recall the video encoding process
this is how it looks like
the first three steps
is handled by web codecs
you get the video stream the final video
stream that you get as the output from
webcodex
what are the steps remaining to get the
file it's muxer and that is not handled
by web codecs when I first got to know
about this I5 what is the use of this
API if it can't even do the entire thing
but once I understood what the
difference between codec and a mug
server was this became really clear
so how do we actually handle the muxing
bit now this again is an operation that
is not documented anywhere nobody has
has had a need for actually muxing a
video who in their day job Max is a
video using JavaScript on the browser
nobody so I had to try out a lot of
things lot of libraries a lot of
webassembly stuff figure everything out
on my own and finally
the discussion of this talk shifts to
this decade old library
called ffmpeg
no discussion of video and audio
encoding gets over with fmpic how many
of you know what ffmpeg is
that's good so ffmpeg is a decade-old
library written in C C plus plus can do
anything related to video audio encoding
decoding and thanks to webassembly we
can use ffmpeg
in JavaScript in browsers today and I'll
be using ffmpeg.wasm project for this
but there are various compilations
available online so you can actually try
out see which one works for you this
ffmpeg.wasm it's the simplest one to
work with which is what I've found
so once when you have ffmpeg wasm
installed on your project
fmpeg exposes one function called create
ffmpeg call that call the load function
this these are you know Steps From the
documentation
now what you do is you write file so
this video buffer that we just got from
the previous step after the whole web
codec stuff we write this file into
fmpeg file system because remember we
are now interacting with a wasm binary
ffmpeg has its own memory space own file
system so we are passing this video data
to ffmpeg using the write file command
the raw.h264 that I've mentioned here
that is also important h264 is again
indicating ffmpeg that this is the codec
that was used to encode this video
The Next Step which is the Run function
that is where the fmpeg command to
actually marks a video from the encoded
video stream to the final video file uh
that is where it's being done so it
takes in the video stream converts it
into a file called output.mp4 and muxing
is a very cheap operation so even though
webassembly binaries are not really well
suited for encoding videos end to end if
you are just using them as a muxer this
should work fine there should be no
performance bottlenecks this process
happens really quickly
once this is done I simply read the
fmpeg file system to get the data out so
I am reading the output.mp4 which it had
created and since I've I'm done with
fmpeg I clear its memory space I delete
all the files raw output and so on
with this output data I converted into a
blob and finally download that on the
user's device
that is the video encoding process not
in a nutshell that is actually what it
is
so the next question is isn't ffmpegwasm
heavy
what do you think is the size of FM how
many of you think it's less than 5 MB
5 MB less than 5 MB
how many of you think it's less than 10
MB
less than 20.
less than 50.
more than 100
more than 100 okay
so it's just 24.4 MB
did you actually take it seriously 24.4
MV
you're shipping this huge wasm binary to
the browser 24.4 MB
just for a simple mixing process
now fmpeg as a library it's very generic
it has a lot of encoders decoders muxes
demuxers a lot of formats it has a lot
of things but we are only interested in
one part of this Library which is the
muxer
FMP calls it live baby format
just because
now since we are interested in only this
part of the ffmpeg library it should be
possible to isolate it and compile it as
a separate web assembly binary
I haven't done this exploration myself
but there are you know uh some libraries
out there like this one Le baby.js uh so
they have some you know setup already in
place where you can actually extract out
lay baby format compile it separately as
a wasm file and include that that will
significantly reduce the size of your uh
was in binary another great read this
one uh you don't have to take pictures
I'll share the slides with you but this
one also this has some details about how
you can customize the fmpeg.wasm project
itself to compile it for exactly what
you need
that's how you encode a video in the
browser let me actually tell you all the
pros with this approach and it will
literally fill the entire screen I'll
show it to you the first pro is high
quality output
we are manually controlling the frames
we are encoding everything in you know
highest quality there's no frame drop
anywhere constant frame rate again we
are manually controlling the frames of
the encoding process
the entire process is really fast and
that is because most of these web codec
apis are asynchronous and they are also
Hardware accelerated so if your Hardware
has some optimizations web codecs can
tap into those optimizations
you can use any video format as long as
the codec and the container is supported
and you have the support for adding
audio to the last step which is the mux
that is where the audio gets added and
ffmpeg already supports adding audio as
well so adding audio is a very trivial
process in this setup
the only Con in this entire process is
it's relatively hard I can see how hard
it is because someone is sleeping over
there
now the good news is it was hard for me
I spent two months understanding all
these things so that you don't have to
so it should be really easy for you now
after this talk at least that's the hope
speaking of browser support
this slide is always there in any
JavaScript related talk
web codex is supported in all browsers
except Firefox which is kind of sad so I
really hope that codex lands on Firefox
as well
webassembly now is thankfully supported
in all browsers so you can use FM pack
vasm and various other nice compilations
of libraries to do crazy things on the
web today
now remember I was building a tool to
make product videos
I finally did end up building it
it's called slanted
it allows you to make catchy product
videos from simple screen recordings in
just a few minutes
and I the video that you see in the
background that was actually made with
slanted so I screen recorded my screen
of me using slanted and then I added
these 3D transitions effects made the
video look like what you would post on
product hunt and get the number one
product of the day tag
uh there are a lot of features in
slanted you can try it out the URL is in
the second box slanted dot app and that
brings me to the end of the stock uh
thank you for listening I hope you
learned something from this talk
[Music]
you can connect with me on Twitter
GitHub at blender school yeah they just
want me to leave so they just remove the
slide but yeah you can connect with me
on Twitter GitHub uh I also have a
website if you are interested in getting
the slides it's already up you can check
it out at
slides.akashamirasi.com thank you
that was an amazing session Akash thank
you so much
we've been very glad to have such a
patient and interested audience
yeah that's that's been amazing and we
will be heading to our last session
we are just waiting for a speaker and
this would be our last session for track
two but after that we'll be moving to
track one where Jamal where Kyle
Simpson's session is going to be there
whoa you can still there's one more
session folks let's yeah
we're gonna regret it Jamal yeah
together
yes so here we have Jamal today from
Netflix
and he's gonna give a talk which was
very hard for me to remember so I'm just
going to read it out it's on time series
forecasting of stock market prizes using
long short-term memory networks node and
tensorflow.js
the stage is yours
[Applause]
all right there we go
hello Bangalore
I flew over here from New York right
all the way from New York City
many many many many miles away
worked every day and I'm flying back
tonight I need a I need a warmer welcome
from my friends here in Bangalore
all right that's what I'm talking about
now now we can start now we can start I
got the proper welcome thank you very
much I appreciate it
so uh let's get this talk started so who
am I uh my name is Jamal Sinclair
o'garro I am a senior software engineer
at Netflix but uh prior to working on
Netflix I worked in the financial
services industry for roughly uh
a lot of years but I worked as a
software engineer building algorithmic
and electronic trading software for the
last seven or so at a uh hedge fund
slash high frequency trading firm uh
building software that actually trades
uh
live orders to the market that process
about a billion dollars a day roughly so
as I mentioned I'm here from New York
City this is my first time in India so I
had a really good time here so thank you
thank you all some fun facts about
myself is that I am a hip-hop head a
sneaker head a New York Yankees Giants
and Knicks fan so let's go Knicks we
made the playoffs finally for the first
time well the second round of the
playoffs for the first time since
forever any fans here at the NBA yay any
Knicks fans
oh we have one all right yeah the next
right international team thank you
all right so let's get into it so why am
I giving this talk so as mentioned I
have a finance background uh recently
the last year or so uh Ai and ml
research has become a hobby of mine my
primary focus has been on economics and
finance mainly for my own personal
investing so I don't believe in uh
paying someone else to manage my money I
want to manage my own money but during
my time working in the financial
services industry on Wall Street I
learned a couple of tricks that I wanted
to pick up on I'm also a JavaScript
engineer very passionate about
JavaScript and have done deep learning
in the past but mostly with python and R
and when I heard about tensorflow.js it
was very interesting to me because I
wanted to see how those capabilities can
be brought to the JS ecosystem by
building deep neural networks and
training them within the browser or with
the node So currently right now I'm
learning more about lstms long
short-term memory networks for a hobby
paper that I'm working on right now uh
comparing the performance of arima
versus lstms for predicting stock prices
because I plan to use whichever one I
find to be more effective within my own
uh active Trading so also I want to
share what I've learned sharing Miss
caring as mentioned I cared so much that
I flew over here from New York City to
see all you guys and give this talk
so let's go into today's roadmap
so first we're going to explore the
background of our problem space right
which is time series forecasting we're
going to learn what that is and why it's
important how we can use it to be better
investors
we can review the basics of artificial
neural networks recurrent neural
networks as well as long short-term
memory networks as well and then we're
going to examine a very simple naive
open source
project that uses lstms for predicting
stock prices we're going to keep it fun
we're going to keep it informative
and the last talk you guys are going to
have to sit through for today so I don't
want to bore you to death before I uh
before I head back to NYC
So today we're not going to go deep into
the mathematics or the low-level
mechanics of Time series forecasting or
the models that we're discussing we
don't have we simply don't have time for
that it's a very very dense topic we're
going to keep everything high level here
so we won't cover how to evaluate or
interpret our models that we're going to
work with and then we're going to look
at a very simple simple naive example
that you should not use to trade your
own active money
so with that being said let's go through
a disclaimer
nothing presented in this talk should be
taken as as investment advice is for
educational purposes only
following anything demonstrated in this
talk is likely guaranteed to cause a
loss of funds you will likely lose money
if you don't like losing money do not
employ this in real production trading
coding whatever you're trying to do so
invest trade and participate in the
financial markets at your own risk
so I know some folks here like Wall
Street bets you probably woke up one
morning you heard about a stock called
GameStop
probably bought a bunch of shares you
know had a briefcase full of money we're
thinking about buying that nice yacht on
the Hudson you know on the Hudson River
in New York living The Wolf of Life Wall
Street lifestyle can't stop won't stop
doing a ditty dance like puffy and mace
you know from back in the day right
until eventually the game did stop it
was game over right GameStop fell and
then eventually you know your your
profits were probably looking pretty
good here as in figure one and then you
ended up with 24 basically nothing or in
some cases you could end up with
something was like this where you
entirely fall off a cliff and lose all
of your earnings and then some so with
that being said do not invest on this
and let's not get to the talk so first
let's talk about what is time series
data so at the end of the day time
series data is basically data point
sequence and time order so we can think
of it as I like to call it time stamp
data so say if I have data over a
particular period of time hours days
monthly years we can take that data and
then add a simple column that labels
actually time that we actually capture
that data it allows us to keep track of
how our data changes over time very
simple high level explanation of what
time series data is some examples you
may have seen in the real world are
changes in temperature over the last 10
hours fluctuations in your heart rate
during a short run rainfall measurements
over the past three years formula one
lap times over the last couple of
competitions and price of a stock over
the last like four weeks years whatever
so here's an example of what time series
data looks like here's an example of
stock prices here we have open high lows
closed adjusted close and we have this
date column here that tells us exactly
the day that we actually stamped this
data so we can see how the price changes
over time and we'll see how that's going
to be helpful for us in a few
so what is time series forecasting
time series forecasting is predicting
our time series data based on previous
trends that we find in that data so
examples are you want to predict the
weather for tomorrow you want to predict
the uh sales for the quarter in your
company based off the last four quarters
of the year or you want to predict your
stock prices off of the last month's
returns
here's an example of what a Time series
forecast looks like this comes from the
Wall Street journal.com this example
shows Apple's price over the last 12
months and they use that 12 month data
to actually try to predict where Apple's
price is going to be 12 months from now
we see that at the lowest it'll be 74 at
the high it'll be 150 and somewhere in
the middle it'll be around like uh 133
so how do we actually forecast the data
how do we actually forecast stock prices
well let me ask you a question can
anyone in this room predict where this
ball is going to go
is it going to go up down left right
come to me off the screen it's going to
go back in the distance like you have no
idea right because without any
additional context we're guessing we're
not making a prediction our goal is to
predict where it's at
but what if I gave you data about where
the ball previously was
do we now have some idea where it's
going to be in the next couple of steps
in our time series
so the same idea the same idea applies
to stock prices so we look at the
previous stock prices we look at the
trend there and use that to project
forward with the new price is going to
be
So currently you can use statistical uh
techniques like regression analysis or
arima which I'm looking at right now to
forecast these prices but more recently
deep learning has become pretty popular
within this space
so what I want to do right now is just
do a very quick overview of deep
learning because some folks here
probably may not be familiar with some
of the terms anyone here is just like is
anyone here familiar with like a M's and
deep learning at all show of hands okay
so a few so that's good to know so I'm
going to give you a high level overview
what deep learning is and we're going to
use it to actually predict some prices
so if I quote uh my good friend Jason
Brownlee he's not actually my friend
he's my friend in my head I love reading
his literature from machine
learningmastery.com he says that deep
learning is a subfield of machine
learning concerned with algorithms
inspired by the structure and function
of the human brain called artificial
neural networks
so whoa there's a lot of jargon a lot of
terminology let's just step back and go
through some of the terms we're going to
have to understand and be familiar with
to continue through this talk
so first thing we saw there was
artificial neural network for our
purposes let's just think about it as a
really good algorithm that can
approximate functions right maybe
there's some function out there that can
take an input of a series of prices and
they can give us back a price or series
of prices projected into the Future
these artificial neural networks work
very well to learn the coefficients of
that function so that we can actually
feed the data and get back uh
predictions that we can actually use to
trade on or perform other business
decisions depending what the domain is
you can either predict values also
perform classifications so some things
that we have to look at are when we're
training neural networks are the epoch
which is the number of iterations we're
going to take to train our model because
what happens is that we have to train
our model in steps we have to do several
steps in repetition in order to make our
a n get better so it can learn to
predict better one thing is a learning
rate for our purposes it's going to be
how aggressively we're going to adjust
the waste in our training step so the
weights are just the coefficients and
that function we're trying to predict
that's going to allow us to actually
predict stock prices and then also as an
input layer think of this as being the
data that we're going to pass through
this model before we train it so it's
going to be some stock prices in the
past then it's going to be an output
layer that output layer essentially is
going to be our prediction right what is
the price or prices we're trying to
forecast and what sits in between those
two layers are what are called hidden
layers and what they do is they just
take our input data and then they
process it some magic happens in between
that allows us to actually learn a
function that's going to give us
accurate prices
two other things are loss function the
loss function just tells us how accurate
our predictions are if the predictions
are way off from our Target values and
not modeling not doing very well if the
loss function is low then we're doing
pretty good and then we use an Optimizer
which is a algorithm that's going to
help us minimize our loss function
so as an a n as you mentioned it's an
algorithm modeled after the way that
neurons in our brains send information
to each other there are function
approximators and they're very good at
approximating functions giving data so
they learn from data
so high level here is a example of an
artificial neural network so here are
the layers they're basically just like
sets of neurons you can think of these
as being individual data points in the
real world there'll be way more items
than this so the idea is we put some
input into this a n
it flows through these hidden layers
some kind of processing transformation
happens to it and then out comes in an
actual prediction and what we do is at
first we just randomly assign some
characteristics and keep it high level
to these hidden layers that will give us
some random output and what we do is do
a process called back propagation we go
back and try to learn like the optimal
values for those characteristics that
are going to give us a prediction is
going to be very close to reality when
we give it some unseen data so that's
like the training process in a high
level nutshell
so
next I want to talk about recurrent
neural networks so we take a quote from
IBM they say that a recurrent neural
network is a type of artificial neural
network which uses sequential data or
time series data they're distinguished
by their memory as they take information
from prior inputs to influence the
current input and output again a lot
more terminology and jargon at the end
of the day we're going to look at rnns
as basically being a special kind of
like neural network that has a memory so
in our previous example we can pass data
through the network it flows from left
to right gives us an output but we can't
pass in essentially like sequential data
so you want to just pass in let's say
like a hundred stock prices from over
the last like two quarters or so right
that's that's when that's not possible
the RNN actually has the ability to
remember prices from a very long time
ago and prices that are current in order
to make that prediction
so here's an example of what an RNN
looks like I'm not going to go too deep
into this but the idea is that we take
some kind of data take some input we
store the state somewhere we produce
some kind of output and then we feed
that result back into the network over
and over and over and over again for it
to before to be recurring and what we
actually do is we do something called
unrolling the network where we
particularly make copies of each
individual input that we're going to
create and do this process over and over
again so value one we go in we get a
state get an output passing value two
and that output and so on and so on but
one thing to notice is that if we have
100 inputs we're going to have to unroll
100 times so we'll talk about how that
can be uh it can be something that's
going to be difficult make our lives
difficult in the future
so
the benefits of using rnns over an a n
is that they use this feedback loop that
we just spoke about right you get some
data in you get some output you put it
back in you can learn and remember
previous data from the past
and you use that to make a prediction
into the future
so what that means is that we can take
today's price plus as many prices as we
have in the past feed this into this
this RNN and then get back a price or
future price objective into the future
as you can see from that from the way
that this works and the way that the
algorithm is built it works very well
with time series data well let's say it
works well with time series we'll find
out what some of the downsides are
so one downside is that if we pass too
much data to it it'll slow down the
training that's because we have to
unroll the network for every single item
so the more the long ways the harder
it's going to be the longer is going to
take for it to train
and they're also subject to it a very
famous problem called exploding slash
vanish ingredient problem we're not
going to go too deep into that I can do
a separate talk on that all together but
it's just something that just knows it's
just a issue that rnns have and the way
that we solve it is using long
short-term memory networks LST young
which are what our talk is about today
and I promise I'm going to show you guys
code I just want to make sure I get
through some of this uh Theory first
before we actually go into some like
some code so we talked to our friends at
MIT they would say that lscms rely on a
gated cell to track information through
many time steps making it easier to
track long-term dependencies in the data
this allows us to model sequential data
more effectively again more jargon like
what are they talking about what does
this mean
so essentially an lstm is this is all it
is is a RNN that uses long and
short-term memories so if the RNN takes
all of our data into account from back
from way back in the past until now and
try to process all of it the RNN has a
way to actually figure out which data
from the past makes the most sense to
look at today
versus
what's least important to look at right
and it doesn't between using these three
Gates or filters that we have so first
is the forget gate that forget gate
decides how much information from our
long-term memory so think stocks from
way back in the past is going to
actually be used for our predictions the
input gate takes a look at how much
information from our short-term memory
we're actually going to keep and then
the output gate decides what's going to
be our new short-term memory based on
the values returned from our forget get
our input gate and it's going to use
that to do the same thing recurring I'll
over take the output pass it back in and
then give us predictions the benefit
here is that so let's look at let's
actually look at a diagram so this looks
also super complicated but just know
that the main things here are these
three sections right so here is our
forget gate it's going to say hey what
is my alarms what is my long-term data
what do I need to keep it's going to
perform a special function on it's going
to like squash the value between either
0 1 and you know if the value is one
we're going to keep all the data if it's
zero we're going to keep none of it and
anything in between determines how much
of that data we're going to keep keep
running forward something similar
happens here with the input gate but
we're looking at our previous hidden
state which is our short term memory
along with our current input data doing
something similar and deciding how much
of that we're going to add back to our
previous long-term State and then we
pass it through to this output gate it's
going to decide okay what is going to be
our new cell setting hidden State based
on what we calculated here within this
LCM and that data gets fed back in in
the recurrent in the recurrent neural
network Style
so what are some benefits of lcms we can
handle longer sequences of input data
than vanilla RNN for reasons that we
mentioned the larger the RNN gets the
harder it's going to be for it to train
with the lstm we have these special
Gates that can actually identify what
data we should actually keep and what
should be and what should have the most
influence on our predictions and it also
has the biggest benefit is why we use
lcms over rnns is that it gets rid of
the exploding vanish ingredient problem
so now let's briefly talk about
tensorflow then we'll look at a very
simple example of how we can uh do some
forecasting
so tensorflow you may have know may have
heard of is a numerical computation
Library open source by Google that's
used for performing deep learning tasks
but it can do much more than that but
it's primarily used for building neural
networks and different deep learning
structures that we can use to uh to
perform machine learning analysis or
data science type tests on it can run
either your GPU or CPU and the data
flows through these different graphs
that you create as tensors just thinking
there's like vectors or matrices of your
represent your data and hence the name
tensorflow these tensors flow through
these different Networks you're going to
create
now tensorflow.js is simply just the
JavaScript and node bindings for
tensorflow so if you ever use tensorflow
and python it's essentially you can do
essentially the same thing you can do in
the python version of tensorflow you can
do it all within JavaScript you can
train models in a browser you can train
them in node you can trade them on on
devices you can import existing models
so if you go to a website like
huggingface.com where somebody has spent
the time to actually build a robust
model you can take it and import it give
it data and start making predictions
right away it also supports webgl
webassembly and your CPU has full Cuda
support so basically everything you get
in Python you have and under the hood it
uses the same C plus engine that the
python version uses so you won't really
see any performance hits the only thing
I can see that's different between like
the JavaScript version of tensorflow and
the python version besides a slightly
different API is that you don't have
things like pandas and sidekick learn
and matplotlib to help with your whole
machine learning and dataflow but if
you're looking to embed models into your
node.js or browser-based applications
you can use a lot of that functionality
within tensorflow directly without
having to set up a separate python
server make a call to it make a four
round trip you can actually train your
models or perform inference directly in
your browser or you can do it directly
with the node if you're writing some
kind of script or
what have you
so very last slide of me like talking
before we actually see some some actual
like stock predictions and looking at
some code is that I want to just very
briefly go over like the Deep learning
process like because we're going to
actually go through this actually
forecast some stock prices is that first
we have to formulate our task and that
is are we making a prediction of or
performing a classification in our case
we are predicting we're predicting stock
prices up into the future then we have
to prepare our data so we have to clean
it shuffle it normalize it right convert
it into tensors or Etc because it's
going to be natively in JavaScript
arrays we have to perform some kind of
data transformation there next we're
going to build and run our model we'll
see that tensorflow actually gives us
several uh methods and Factory functions
that allow us to actually uh create
neural networks and recurrent neural
networks from from scratch
um we didn't select that Optimizer that
we spoke about a loss function and then
we confirmed that our loss is actually
decreasing because our goal is to get
our losses as close to zero as possible
and at the very end we then evaluate the
model so we checked the evaluation
metrics and make sure that everything
looks good so basically what we do is we
hold a certain subset of our data which
we call our test data and we pass it so
this is new data that our actual model
has not seen before and we see the
predictions actually make sense so they
look like what the actual values are if
they do then we can actually use it for
prediction so we're going to go through
that flow in these last uh 10 minutes or
so so let's skip over to the browser and
look at look at an example
now one thing is that I don't have
access to the internet so I can't run
this stuff live so no live demo no I
came with a plan b i preloaded
everything already in a separate tab so
just pretend that I'm clicking these
buttons to actually go through infested
data and then we'll go through what this
open source application does to actually
predict
um stock prices then we'll look at some
of the code to see how it actually works
behind the scenes so first what we do
here we actually load the data stock
price data from Ford from 2000 until now
um we're doing doing at a weekly
frequency so what we're having here is
all the current prices every week is
going to be the adjusted close and the
next thing we're going to do is we're
going to calculate something called a
simple moving average and all we
basically do is pick some kind of window
in this case we said we're going to look
at from time T now we're going to take
all the prices going back 20 days and
then com and compute some average and
then use that to create this smooth
curve that we see here that allows us to
see what the trend in the data is so
with this with this project actually
does it says that if we can take the
simple average and calculate it from 20
days and 20 days in the past pass it to
some kind of recurrent neural network in
our case is going to be a lstm we can
then predict the SMA and that should be
a good approximation of what our actual
price forecast is going to be so we're
actually forecasting smas but we're
saying that this is closeness to the
actual price for it to be an actual
prediction
so this is an idea like what the data
looks like so we see here we have an
array of the last 20 prices that's our X
values our xrx input and what we're
doing here is passing an actual label or
the actual SMA for it and we do that in
week Windows going all the way back to
the year 2000 we passed that to our lstm
we go here to this section and we tune
what we call our our hyper parameters so
we tell how much of the training data we
want to keep in this case the I just
accepted the defaults it did 98 you
normally wouldn't do that you'll
probably look at 80 20 tests test split
you have some 80 training data 20 to
test on but the default here was 98 so
that's fine epochs is how many times
you're going to actually go through that
training process the learning rate we
have here like how aggressive are we
going to try to adjust our weights and
also how many lscm layers that we want
so here we actually look and see that
for each Epoch feature we look at the
actual loss itself so anything so a
higher number means that we have a lot
of Errors we're doing a very very poor
job of predicting the stock prices based
on the data that we give it and every
time we go through iteration we get
better so we should get closer to zero
and as we look at this this chart here
for our 10 epochs we actually start to
converge to zero and you can see the
actual values here on each run we say it
starts to get smaller or smaller and
smaller
now the very last thing is to actually
validate our data so we have the actual
stock price we see that we're not really
predicting a price directly but if we
look at our SMA we were actually trying
to Target we actually were trying to
predict you can see that with this green
line which is our predicted line right
that we got from our training data we're
pretty much like lockstep like pretty
close to like what we're actually seeing
in the actual
labels why the Y values that we actually
passed to it like the actual SMA and
then we actually predicted against the
stock price we see that okay we're not
exactly lying for line for it but if you
look at like 12.79 versus 1241 all the
way down to the last one 12 11 versus
1207. we're getting pretty close it's
not bad it's enough if you you know if
you wanted to trade I don't recommend
you do it you can get a good
approximation of what the price would be
like forecasting stocks are very hard
you're never going to get exactly on the
money you want to get as close as we can
to get an idea of like where the price
is going to go so we can trade now the
validation looks pretty decent let's see
what an actual prediction looks like so
we look here we say okay on June 1st we
had a price of 12.11 cents and we're
going to say one week later we think the
price is going to be 12 dollars and
eight cents right so it looks like this
model actually did pretty decently if we
were trying to predict stock prices
going through the simple flow we might
say that this is something we might want
to probably use we want to try to
continue to tune in to make it better
but if we look here at another example
this is Tesla stock right the same
process same inputs different stock
price we see that we look here at
Tesla's trading somewhere around like
what two hundred and ten dollars or so
yesterday and then this model is saying
is going to drop all the way down to 177
dollars This falls off a cliff just
jumps and dies it says hey you know what
I just want to just give you all losses
we're dropping down to
you know 177 which is highly unlikely so
one thing to take with a grain of salt
if we scroll back up we look at what the
validation looks like we see that
Tesla's stock is swinging all over the
place there are very high changes in the
prices so it's very hard to use at least
this SMA to actually try to predict this
particular uh this particular stock
so let's jump over to the code really
quickly and let's look at how this is
actually built and then we'll talk about
a few takeaways and I will share some
resources and just some other uh
hopefully interesting things with you
let me blow this up so at the end of the
day this is the open source project that
we looked at it's very simple it's a
simple HTML file there are two
JavaScript files one is for all of your
Dom interactions all the magic that you
have is here inside this model.js file
and there are two functions that do most
of the magic one is this train model it
takes all of our
previous prices our X all of our smas
our y values the window size the number
of epoch the learning rate the number of
layers that we all selected and it goes
through and does some processing it
builds it converts our data into tensors
and then what we do here is do the
actual magic where we say let's call
this TF sequential method this gives us
back an instance of a TF sequential
model and we can actually start adding
layers to it so if you look back if you
think back to our diagrams we looked at
earlier we create this model and we have
the different like input output hidden
layers in between this is how you
actually use it you actually create it
through the tensorflow API so first we
create some some simple dense layer do
some reshaping here we actually say for
all of the number of layers that we've
chosen we're going to create an lstm
cell that's the diagram that we looked
at that shows the long-term short-term
memories we take that we add another
layer our basic RNN layer because
remember lstms are rnns but we give it
these actual LCM cells that we've
created
then from there we add a simple dense
layer so we can actually get our data
and like flatten it to get some kind of
output and the very last thing we do is
compile our model so once we actually
build this structure we have to compile
it so we can actually then go through
the training step so when we click train
and actually start training the data and
start trying to learn that function
that's going to give us predictions
based on previous prices we basically
call this fit function and what that
does it takes all of our X values all of
our y values we give it the number of
epochs we want to run in our case that
was 10 then the batch size just says how
do we want to partition this data as we
kind of go through and then this log
callback just says we want to log the
results to the console so we can see it
and evaluate it and then we create some
object that has the model itself the
history some normalized data and we pass
that to this make prediction function so
make prediction very similar we convert
our data to a tensor the one thing here
is that we have to normalize our data
one thing with a long-term short-term
memory networks are just like uh an ends
in general
we don't want to pass the rural prices
for our data to actually model it we
want to normalize it so this is what
we're doing here we're just like
squashing it to some value between like
zero and one so we can have more robust
training and have better predictions we
then pass our normalized input right
which is going to be our training data
and we get back our result and then what
we have to do is convert that back to
the Royal prices so there's this
unnormalized here this unnormalized
function where we actually denormalize
the data and then we return it and that
gives us the stock prices that we
actually uh plotted a second ago so
that's like at a high level how
tensorflow.js Works here's how you can
actually use it to create make
predictions if you have if you have uh
prices you can basically use these same
functions right in the browser like this
example does or just import tensorflow
slash node and run it locally from the
server
so what are some takeaways
so tensorflow.js makes it relatively
simple to create an lstm that can be
used to predict stock prices right we
sold with the Tesla example Ford did
pretty well because the stock the swings
and prices weren't very weren't very
large but with Tesla for example this
price range is reused so it's very very
hard to at least use this approach to
approximate our prices
um we didn't look at it here but in
practice we try to project prices or
predict prices further into the future
is going to be a lot more difficult and
your results are going to Decay the
further out you go out
um and also is uh we noticed that like
changing our hyper parameter values
could give you some better results you
can actually add more layers remove
layers add more epochs but there are
some pros and cons associated with it
there's overfitting things that assets
you have to watch out for
um and then like the naive approach is
good to give us an idea of the direction
the price is going to go into but we
probably don't want to use it to
actually predict prices unless we're
going to like tweak the parameters and
try to figure out what's going to give
us the best result
um and then other things we can do too
to improve our performance is that we
can actually add additional features
instead of just the price we can add the
trading volume or other characteristics
that can be used and learned by the
model to determine what most affects the
price to perform our predictions
so here are some resources that I
recommend if you want to like learn more
about this MIT has a really good course
on deep learning that's online for free
just go to intro to deep learning.com
the tensorflow time series forecasting
tutorial is pretty good it's in Python
you can easily translate it over the
tensorflow.js if you wish the
tensorflow.js docs are really good and
then a demo of the of the actual app
that we looked at and the actual
repository that I just went through just
now is available I encourage you to go
through there look at the code change it
and try to see if you can optimize it
based on what you learn by taking these
courses or reading this time series
forecasting tutorial because again this
is a naive approach
so that concludes my talk
um so you can please connect with me on
GitHub Twitter or LinkedIn
uh also as I mentioned I know my time is
up I want to do a Shameless plug really
quickly like this is a passion of mine
I've been writing lots of papers or a
few papers two papers exactly not a lot
two papers on uh some of this stuff so a
few of them are here I'll share the link
in the slides when you have it so one is
on a deep reinforcement learning uh it
just broke but anyway long story short
uh these links are some papers that I've
written you can feel free to take a look
at them give me some feedback the next
paper I'm writing is going to be on the
arima versus lstms and maybe I'll do
another talk on the actual results and
go deeper into some models and
applications that I've actually trained
so with that thank you so much thank you
for having me here I really enjoyed
being here and I have a long flight back
to New York tonight thank you all
whoops
nice meeting you let's have a huge round
of applause once again for Jamal he has
come from New York to deliver this
session for all of us today with that we
come to an end for all the sessions for
track two we have one more session with
Kyle Simpson in track one so let's move
there and let's close the event
yeah please
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign